Ja, Phil Schäler kommt von links, Scott Forstel dribbelt von rechts. Von rechts und in der Mitte tummeln sich diverse Entwickler, die alle versuchen vergeblich, ihre Demos an Start zu kriegen. Wird der Luftballon platzen? Nein, er kriegt noch nicht mal Luft. War das peinlich? Das war echt peinlich, ne? Und da ist das Zweite, also alles, was so mit externen Hardware-Accessories laufen sollte, ging nicht. Ich hab noch nie so viel schief gehen sehen.
Vielleicht sind ja die Entwickler gar nicht schuld, sondern vielleicht ist die API noch scheiße.
Aber die haben auch echt alle Demos auf einer, die auf seinem iPhone laufen lassen, ne?
Na, ich denke, die haben da wirklich mehrere, die müssten da eigentlich mehrere haben. Sprache hab ich sogar davon, dass da mehrere Adapterkabel da rumliegen haben und so weiter, die sich mal schnell ausdrehen können.
Ja, aber das war so, du hast oben auf der Leinwand gesehen, das war auch bei dem Typen, der das mit dem Luftballon vorgestellt hat. Also du hast ein Icon gesehen und dann war das, also auf dem iPhone der Springboard und unten waren hoffenweise Punkte und dann hat man gesehen, wie tatsächlich irgendjemand da gesessen hat und immer zum nächsten Icon gewischt hat. Und der eine musste auch...
Ja gut, aber ich bin mir sicher, dass sie mehrere iPhones mit dem selben Setup gehabt haben.
Okay, das will man hoffen.
Ja, wir können auch mal begrüßen, oder? Hallo Hörer, wir sind's.
Wir sind's, wieder voll live drin schon.
Genau, Dennis auf links, Max auf rechts, ich in der Mitte.
Tim ist der, der immer zu laut ist.
Die drei von der Tankstelle, ich bin der, der zu laut ist, ich mach mich leiser.
Das ist schon okay, damit die Leute dich erkennen.
Ich hab so ein...
Die müssen sich doch erkennen.
Du würdest ja was vermissen, wenn du nicht der Lauteste wärst.
Ich mach mich jetzt ganz leise, ich zieh mich jetzt beschämt in meine Mitte zurück.
Tim, zu leise.
Ich mach einfach meinen Kopfhörer lauter, dann reguliere ich mich automatisch runter. So, jetzt haben wir das. Ja, und es ging eine Menge schief und vor allem war ja auch eine Menge...
Eine Menge, zwei Sachen.
Das ist eine Menge. Also wenn mal eine Demo schief geht.
Shirt Party Software interessiert da eh keinen.
Man könnte auch sagen, dass es jetzt die 3.0 API für die Steuerung von externen Geräten war. Ja, Apple, ne?
Aber dass da keine Luft rauskommt, dafür kann ja wohl kaum die API was.
Ja, aber ich meine, was macht denn das für einen Eindruck? Da kommen sie mit so, ja, Health Care und es ist egal, dass dein Doktor gerade beim Golfen im Urlaub am Wochenende ist, der kann ja remote auf dich zugreifen und dann irgendwie so ein API Pick-Up und du sitzt da so...
Das war doch mal ein reines Software-Abduce.
Also ja, tut mir leid, dass die Patientin verstorben ist, aber wir hatten da irgendwie ein Bucket-in-Troh-API.
Also wie Mobile-Mirror. Für den Ballon hat ja mit der API nichts zu tun.
Apple Keynote, jetzt ohne heiße Luft.
So, was hatten die da überhaupt da, was haben die denn da vorgehabt mit diesem Luftballon?
Ich glaube, der sollte da Luft rein geben.
Ich glaube, der sollte aufgeblasen werden und dann haben die da wahrscheinlich irgendwie so Sensorik dran.
Wie sehr er aufgeblasen ist. Wie viel Druck gerade drauf ist, dass sie so messen können, bevor er platzt oder was.
Na das ist doch eigentlich ganz, wenn man so ein Luftballon aufpustet, dann kennt man ja auch, dass man am Anfang erst mal so einen richtigen Widerstand überwinden muss. Und dann, wenn es einmal so, dieses allererstes.
Da steigt der Druck ziemlich doll und dann geht es ein bisschen leichter.
Genau, dass sie das da abzeichnen, wie stark die Druck ist.
Und wie stark der Druck steigt, bevor es kurz bevor es platzt.
Das wäre toll gewesen. Das hätten wir alle gerne gesehen.
Das wünsche ich mir für die nächste Keynote. Lego fürs iPhone. Dass man dieses ganze Lego-Zeug darüber steuern kann. Mindstorms, ja. Das wird geil.
Das könnte natürlich auch demnächst...
Als Mobile Brain. So einfach so reinstecken, zack.
Alles will man steuern mit dem scheiß iPhone.
Ein bisschen Sensorik noch da rein und sowas. Du hast doch einen Beschleunigungssensor und das ganze Zeug.
Das ist die Zukunft. Das ist die Zukunft.
So wollen wir jetzt mal Punkt für Punkt durchgehen? Sonst springen wir ja von einer coolen Sache zur nächsten.
Na klar.
Also erstmal muss ich ein bisschen freuen.
Also erstmal sagen wir mal, was hier los ist. Hier ist Mobile Max 029, eine Woche nach 028. Nachdem wir das letzte Mal eine Woche zu spät waren, sind wir jetzt einfach mal eine Woche zu früh.
Dann wäre es eine Woche zu früh und dann wieder in einer Timeline.
Genau. Und können auch schön überprüfen, ob unsere Voraussagen gestimmt haben. Ab Stunde eins, in der letzten Sendung, fangen wir nämlich damit an. Ich habe dann leider nur eine 15 Minuten Zeit gehabt, heute da nochmal reinzuhören. Bis dahin hat eigentlich alles weitgehend gestimmt, wo wir uns so einig waren.
Was heißt das denn so bisher?
Was die Voraussagen betrifft. Wie wollen wir denn da jetzt rangehen? Wollen wir das so in der Reihenfolge machen, wie das in der Keynote war? Weil so habe ich es mir nicht notiert.
Ja, dann lass uns doch einfach das so machen.
Gut, das ist doch was Schönes. Jetzt muss ich nur gucken, welche von meinen kleinen Kärtchen hier die ersten haben.
Ja, um die Spannung der Sendung zu erhöhen.
Wenn Tim mir schon was aufschreibt.
Also erstmal kamen sie mit ihren Zahlen an, mit irgendwie wie viele tolle OS X User doch jetzt hier.
Tim hat übrigens echte Kärtchen. So richtig kleine Kärtchen.
Ja, sowieso, die vorne im Fernsehen.
Auf der Rückseite hat er auch so Mobile Max aufdrücken lassen. Nee, das war ein Witz, aber er hat Kärtchen.
Ich hab Kärtchen, das ist beeindruckend. Ich hab da sogar mit einem Bleistift drauf geschrieben.
Ich hab neulich nur EC-Karten unterschreiben müssen. Ich hab keine Stifte mehr gefunden.
Ja, die meisten Leute sind heute schon gar nicht mehr in der Lage, ihren eigenen Namen zu schreiben. Deswegen muss man schon ab und zu mal wieder schreiben. Ich schreib viel zu wenig, ich merk das auch. Wenn ich jetzt zu viel schreibe, dann ich verschreib mich deutlich häufiger, als ich das so früher...
Und als Snow Leopard gibts so einen Krampf in der Hand schnell. Krampf in der Hand.
Aber ich kann es sogar noch nicht lesen.
Keynote, der neue Apple Krampf in der Hand? Oder was?
Also, dreimal so viele User haben sie behauptet. Da hab ich mich gefragt.
Wie 2007.
Genau, 2007 hatten sie irgendwie so und so viel gehabt. Dann kam das iPhone raus und jetzt hätte sich ja diese Zahl verdreifacht.
Weil, gut, iPhone OS als OS X mitrechnen.
Genau, das ist schon so ein Stretch. Ich meine, für die Developer, das war ja in dem Moment eigentlich die Target-Audience, ist das eigentlich eine korrekte Aussage. Also das Betriebssystem, für das ihr so programmiert im Wesentlichen. Bloß ist es natürlich so, dass da eine ganze Menge Leute doppelt gezählt werden, die sowohl einen Mac als auch einen iPhone haben. Aber da hab ich überlegt...
Das zählt aber für die Leute, die zwei Macs haben. So Wecke zum Beispiel. Und noch ein iPhone, sind schon drei.
Aber es ist sicherlich nicht von der Hand zu weisen, dass dieses Betriebssystem gerade eine, wie nennt man das, eine Proliferation erfährt.
In seiner Blütephase ist.
Ja, es ist einfach hip. Naja, das wollte ich nicht weiter diskutieren. Dann kam schon gleich am Anfang dieses Ding mit ja, wir haben ja diese Laptops und Unibody. Da hab ich mir auch gesagt, oh oh. Da hab ich mir hingeschrieben, Unibody, warum erwähnt er denn das? Naja, und was kam? Hier, Voraussage von mir war vor einem halben Jahr, ihr erinnert euch? Die anderen kommen jetzt auch noch mit der eingebauten Batterie.
Stimmt. Was war vor einer Woche die Aussage von mir?
Dass überhaupt neue MacBooks kommen.
Genau.
Aber ich hab jetzt leider nicht nochmal so weit nachgehört um deine konkrete Aussage.
Ich hab nur gesagt, wenn ich mir ein neues MacBook kaufe, dann kommt immer ein neues danach. Und exakt so war's auch.
Okay, na das ist natürlich ein Maßstab. Da solltest du eine eigene Webseite machen. So für den Jürger, der noch nicht zweis.
Müssen wir uns mal erklären, wovon wir reden, weil, obwohl wahrscheinlich haben alle wirklich die Sendung, also die Keynote gesehen, obwohl vielleicht nicht alle. Die dauert ja schon zwei Stunden.
Die war lang, zweieinhalb Stunden, deshalb noch nie so einen langen Keynote. Die waren sonst immer eine anderthalb Stunden. Die haben sich richtig viel Zeit gelassen, diese langweiligen Spiele tatsächlich.
Wahrscheinlich hat Steve mit seinem Rollstuhl die Treppen schnell noch hochgeschafft.
Da haben wir noch ein Spiel mit einem Auto, was über die Straße fährt. Ich fand das gar nicht so schlecht, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich guck ja an, was das Spiel ist.
Lassen Sie sich nicht darüber reden.
Das ist für mich immer wieder das Leitere.
Ja, wir wollten ja da rein vorgeblendet sein. Um es mal zusammenzufassen, schnell, wir haben neue MacBooks vorgestellt. Genau zu sagen MacBook Pros, weil MacBooks gibt es irgendwie jetzt nicht mehr.
Auch das kleine Weiße.
Das ist billig.
Das kostet unter 1000 Euro.
Nee, das hat auch alle Ports.
Ach, das hat Digital Audio in?
Und feierweilig.
Was meinst du, was ich hier gerade tue in diesem Moment?
Und das ist schnell.
This Podcast being brought to you live bei Digital Audio in. Um das nochmal zu betonen. Ich werde gleich noch ein bisschen heulen. Halten wir erstmal fest, was sie getan haben. Sie haben jetzt eingesehen, dass es Quatsch ist, dieses MacBook Pro nicht so zu nennen, weil es ja eigentlich alles ist.
Das MacBook heißt das MacBook Pro.
Das MacBook heißt jetzt, leider heißt es jetzt Twix. Und es hat eine neue Batterie, bzw. es hat diese nicht wechselbare Batterie. Sie nutzen den Platz besser und sie können jetzt irgendwie 7 Stunden durchrocknen, haben sie gesagt. Das finde ich super. Also kannst du mal dieses Ka-Ching-Ka-Ching ausmachen.
Das ist bei dir?
Das bin ich. Das stimmt. Das ist immer.
Wie niemand braucht FireWire 800. Du bist entlassen.
60% mehr. Du musst schon sagen, wenn du den Chat zitierst.
Der weiß es schon.
Ich hätte irgendeine Spur nicht aufgenommen. 60% mehr Colorgammut. Naja, gleiche Auflösung.
Was hat man das bedeutet?
Naja, das heißt, dass sie mehr Farben empfangen.
Der Farbraum ist noch größer, den sie darstellen können. Noch feiner und differenziertere Farben.
Ist das erst jetzt? Also ich meine, ich hab schon irgendwie vor zwei Monaten oder so was gehört, dass oder vor einem Monat, dass neue MacBooks jetzt mit einem anderen Display ausgeliefert werden, wo sie einen dunklen irgendwelche MacBooks nebeneinander gehalten haben. Also die, die nach außen hin als die absoluten identischen Geräte, also unibade MacBooks.
Es kann sein, dass sie die schon signend eingebaut haben und dass sie jetzt aber erst mit den neuen Modellen behaupten, das wäre jetzt offiziell.
Also gerade im kleinen MacBooks soll sich ja zwischendurch schon einiges gebessert haben.
Hab ich auch gehört, aber kann ich selber nicht bestätigen, nehme ich jetzt auch einfach mal zur Kenntnis. Das kann ja sein, dass das alles ganz toll aussieht, kann auch sein, dass das einfach nur so eine Behauptung ist. Und dann toll, man kann jetzt irgendwie bis zu 3 Gigahertz da rein hauen in den Prozessor, wenn man irgendwie bereit ist, den Aufpreis zu bezahlen. Man kann irgendwie 8 GB RAM da reinhauen, wenn man bereit ist, den Aufpreis zu bezahlen.
Hat der mehr RAM Slots, das Ding?
Da braucht man die 4 GB Module, die so richtig Geld kosten. 400 Euro pro Module oder so.
Mit anderen Worten, das sind die, die ich auch in Mines reinkriege.
Ich hab erwartet, dass da mal 16 GB steht, was aber wahrscheinlich sogar geht, wenn die Module erst mal rauskommen.
Das ist wieder die alte Leier, das weiß man jetzt nicht, aber ich meine 8 GB RAM. So, dann 256 GB SSD, war auch schon bei dem 15 Zoll eine Option. Preise sind ein bisschen gesunken.
Naja, und es ist eine Konfiguration hinzugekommen.
Ja, genau das Kleine. Also bei den 15 Zollern ist ja...
Intergrund, beleuchtete Tastatur.
Ihr seid noch bei den kleinen 13 Zollern.
Ich bin noch bei dem Kleinen.
Achso, na gut, dann erzähl mal erst mal Kleine.
Das haben sie ja als erstes vorgestellt.
Wir wollten ja in dem ersten 15 Zoll vorgestellt.
Stimmt.
Ah, nee, stimmt, du hast recht. Stimmt, das ist ja hier auch das... Ah, Entschuldigung, ich bin... Okay, wir sind beim 15 Zoller. So, und das Ding ist billiger geworden. Weil es jetzt ein Modell gibt, wo nicht diese GT-Grafikkarte mit drin ist, sondern nur die Mobility.
Nur noch die Build-in sozusagen.
Die 9400er.
Ja, das ist klug. Das heißt, man kann sich jetzt auch für weniger Geld so einen 15 Zoll kaufen. Und das macht es natürlich schon etwas attraktiver. Weil ehrlich gesagt, ich brauche jetzt diese High-End-Grafikkarte nicht unbedingt. Mir sind andere Sachen wichtiger.
Die brauchen glaube ich ganz viele Leute nicht.
Das glaube ich nämlich auch. Und dieses Hin- und Her-Schalten ist ja eh bekloppt.
Aber am Glück ist das total bescheuert.
Also da wäre es interessant, ob das mit Snowlapper jetzt vielleicht mal live geht.
Haben sie nichts zu gesagt, ne?
Nee, leider.
Naja, unten ist der Kartenslot. Ja, jetzt wird es traurig. Also keine SIM-Karte, kein UMTS.
Ja, das hat mich aber keine Sekunde gewundert.
Schlimm?
Ich denke immer noch, dass es eines Tages irgendwann mal kommen wird, dass die Geräte mobil werden. Aber ich finde es noch nicht so schlimm, dass es jetzt noch nicht so weit ist.
Hallo, wir haben alle ab nächster Woche Tethering. Da brauchen wir keinen.
Da müssen wir auch nochmal drüber reden nachher.
Da müssen wir nochmal drüber reden. So, und dann haben sie einen SD-Kart-Slot eingebaut in das 15 Zoll Teil.
Also ich meine, man muss ja mal sagen, in der PC-Welt gibt es ja die SD-Kart-Slots schon seit Jahrzehnten.
Parallel-Ports?
Die gab es ja schon noch viel länger, die wurden ja schon abgeschafft.
Die SD-Kart-Slot ist wichtig, das ist überfällig. Für SD-Karts.
Alle benutzen SD-Karts, überall. TomTom hat so ein Ding, jede Kamera hat so ein Ding.
Wie oft steckst du eine SD-Karte in deinen Rechner?
Wie oft steckst du eine Express-Karte so rein? Also eine SD-Karte habe ich gleich schon benutzt, eine Express-Karte noch nie.
SD-Karten benutze ich regelmäßig. Kameras irgendwie anschließen.
Was ich natürlich ein bisschen schade finde, eine SD-Karte könnte man auch über USB anschließen. Das ist schnell genug. Aber eine Express-Karte kannst du halt nicht.
Aber wofür braucht man eine Express-Kart-Slot?
Wenn du zum Beispiel wirklich eine UMTS-Karte drin haben willst und nicht so einen schwulen Dongle, der dir die ganze Zeit irgendwie abreißt. Schwul im Sinne von metrosexuell.
Ja, schon klar.
So einen metrosexuellen Dongle. So ein parfümiertes, cremiges Deo-Teil.
Also ich überleg jetzt, ich hatte früher irgendwann meinen PC-Kart-Slot in meinen Powerbooks und in meinen MacBooks hab ich jetzt meinen Express-Kart-Slot. Und ich warte immer noch darauf, dass ich irgendwann auch mal eine Karte kriege, die ich überhaupt reinstopfen kann.
Also technisch gesehen ist es ein Rückschritt. Aber wahrscheinlich haben die von ihren Nutzerzahlen, der meint ja auch irgendwie weniger als 1%, würden wir den Express-Kart-Slot nutzen. Aber wahrscheinlich schon ein paar mehr Leute würden mal den SG-SD-Kart-Slot nutzen.
SD-Kart ist super.
Also erst letztens, meine Mama will bei meiner Oma immer irgendwie die Fotos von der Kamera gucken und dann sag ich immer, hast du einen SD-Kart-Adapter dabei? Und sie immer, äh, wie hat der so was nicht? Weil die hat halt irgendwie PC. Und dann sag ich, nö, hab ich nicht. Und dann bin ich immer befreit davon, meiner Oma stundenlang irgendwelche Bilder zeigen zu müssen. Voll toll.
Also ich hab immer einen SD-Kart-Reader bei mir.
Okay, vielleicht bin ich da nicht die Zielgruppe. Das einzige Gerät, wo ich überhaupt eine Flashkarte drin habe, ist halt ein Memory-Stick.
Memory-Stick? Ach, dieses Sony Zeug?
Ja, das ist natürlich scheiße.
Aber SD-Karten kannst du so schick ins Portemonnaie packen und die sind schön klein und so.
Ja, okay. Ich hab auch den Kommentar bekommen, das sei jetzt die neue Diskette.
Das ist auch ein bisschen so.
SD-Karten ist die neue Diskette.
Also jetzt sind wir sozusagen die Disketten losgeworden. Ich dachte ja, die USB-Sticks sind irgendwie die neuen Disketten. Die hat jeder irgendwie seinen Schlüsselpunkt.
Das sind ja SD-Karten, fast die schickeren Disketten. Das sind so kleine, schöne, flache Dinger.
Die musst du dann noch mal irgendwo hinstecken. Die hast du dann nicht an deinem Schlüsselbund.
Kannst du auch machen. Dann gibt es ja SD-Karten, dann gibt es ja Mini, Mikro und noch irgendwie eine kleinere Kurse. Dann gibt es immer Adapter in Adapter in Adapter.
Es gibt natürlich Leute, die diesen PCI-Express schon glücklich für sich haben.
Klar, die müssen sich jetzt halt einen 17 Zoll kaufen.
Die werden sich bedanken.
Also wie gesagt, technisch ist es ein Rückschritt. Wahrscheinlich usability-mäßig ist es für die meisten ein Fortschritt. Der hat auch ganz schön lange gedauert. Und ich denke mal auch, sieht man ja auch, Apple hat sich ganz schön lange versucht zu verweigern gegen diesen SD-Kart und andere tausende Formate, die in der Zwischenzeit schon gekommen sind und die doch wieder weggehen. Und SD-Kart ist halt doch so ein bisschen übrig geblieben, hat sich ein bisschen gehalten und dachten, okay, machen wir es halt rein. Ich glaube nicht, dass die es gewollt haben. Das war wahrscheinlich nicht so eine einfache Entscheidung.
SD-Kart ist eindeutig der Gewinner von diesen ganzen Kartenformaten.
Ja, das hat sich ja schon eine Weile abgezeichnet.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was die ganzen PC-Laptops noch haben. Da müsste man fast mal eine Sendung oder tausende Anschlussmöglichkeiten, die die haben. Kompakt-Kart oder wie heißt die? Kompakt Flash. Kompakt Flash hatten die bestimmt auch mal die ganzen PCs, oder?
Also bei diesen Netbooks und Laptops ist SD-Kart tatsächlich das. Also bei diesen Netbooks auf jeden Fall. Die haben eigentlich vor allem SD-Kart-Reader.
Also ich finde es nicht so schon, weil ich habe wirklich einen Gepresskart, auch noch keinen gesehen, der so etwas hat. Außer als so eine UMTS-Teile. Aber da kommt so eine Tease. Ich hoffe, dann geht das.
Gut, ich würde sagen, wenn man einen PCIe-Express-Slot braucht, dann ist man bestimmt sauer. Weil das ausgerechnet jetzt so dieses goldene Mittelklasse-Modell, diese Möglichkeit nicht mehr bietet, ist schon für etwas, was sich Pro nennt, eine Einschränkung.
Aber ich glaube, es sind weniger sauer als Leute, die sich freuen. Aber ich glaube, die Leute sind mehr sauer als die Leute, die sich freuen. Vor einer Menge. Also vor dem, wie doll die sich ärgern.
Ja, sowas.
Wir haben jetzt nur einen, der sich ärgert. Aber doppelt so viel wie die beiden, die sich freuen. So gesehen gleicht sich das wieder auf.
Die Frage ist halt immer, welche Märkte verärgerst du?
Ich probiere mir das gerade grafisch vorzustellen.
PCI Express brauchst du irgendwie für High-End Grabbing und naja.
Also ich habe wirklich mal geguckt, was es da so für Karten gibt, die für mich auch unter Einsatzweise interessant wären. Also eins hier, was halbwegs hinkommen könnte, wäre so eine SSD-Card, die man einfach reinstopft. Aber auch da gibt es nichts Vernünftiges.
Firewire, noch mal irgendwie ein Extra-Port, noch mal ein Bus.
Ich brauche nicht mal den ein.
Gibt es diese Firewire-Switches?
Na ja, aber die erhöhen ja nicht deine Bandbreite. Na ja, aber ihr habt schon recht. Ich sage mal so, das macht wahrscheinlich Sinn. Dieses 15 Zoll-Teil hat ansonsten auch irgendwie alle Schnitten noch und ist an sich jetzt mit der kleineren Grafikkarte, mit der Option und dem niedrigen Preis. Was ist der Preis in Deutschland? 1,6 glaube ich. Hab ich jetzt noch gar nicht geguckt. Das war noch ein Dollar, oder?
Okay, wahrscheinlich gleich.
Ich hatte mir schon die deutschen Preise angeguckt.
1.700 US-Dollar, aber das sind ja immer diese Netto-Preise. Also 1.600 Euro. Ja, das war vorher viel mehr. Das war vorher 1.900 oder so. Minimum Preis.
Nee, ich glaube 1,8. Nee, es war ziemlich exakt der Preis von der Mittleren.
1,8.
1,8 statt 1,6, 200 Euro Unterschied meinst du?
Ja, die Preise sind schon ganz schön runter. Ich glaube Apple passt sich da auch ein bisschen der Krise an.
Man weiß immer nicht, wie die Preise vorher waren. Man muss sich das eigentlich immer für den Screenshotten...
Ich hab die Rechnung noch zu Hause.
Okay, aber in derselben Ausstattung? Auch mit 4 GB Arbeitsspeicher?
Nee, nur mit 2 GB.
Das will ich wohl meinen.
Aber das war eine 320er Platte. Und eben die mit Grafikkarte.
Na jetzt haben sie da so ein bisschen gespart. Aber es ist sicherlich kein Fehler da, niedriger einzusteigen.
Also wenn ich es jetzt holen würde, würde ich mir ein 6er holen und mich freuen, dass ich das Geld für den Arbeitsspeicher spare.
Die deutschen Preise sind auch wieder geil. Also das kleine kostet 1599 Euro, das nächste ist mit 1798,99.
Hä, wo hast du denn die Preise her?
Von storeapple.com.de.
Also ich bin hier auf einer Seite, wo steht 1799.
Du bist auf derselben Seite wie ich und du hast da andere Preise stehen. Guck mal, was ich hier habe. Guck mal, wir haben jetzt beide die gleiche Webseite offen. Bei mir steht ernsthaft 2099,01 Euro.
Du bist wahrscheinlich eingeloggt und hast du vielleicht irgendwelche...
Bin ich eingeloggt? Nee, ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Du bist nicht eingeloggt?
Ich bin auch bei 2099,01.
Vielleicht kriegst du andere Preise.
Vielleicht krieg ich andere Preise.
Nee.
Aber dafür kriegst du einen ganzen Cent Rabatt.
Aber du kriegst einen Cent Rabatt, wenn du das mittlere bestellst.
Tja. Das ist so wie bei Amazon irgendwie. Jeder kriegt jetzt andere Preise. So, so. Also, ist ja schön, was...
Vielleicht hat der wieder diesen Intel-Rechner-Bug hier, also wo die eh...
Voll falsch rechnet oder was? Also irgendwie find ich, dass meine Preise besser aussehen als eure.
Was kosten denn die kleinen Preise?
Das sind irgendwelche komischen Rundungsfehler, die ihr durchschlagen. Aber dass ihr jetzt wirklich hier bei zwei Rechnern, die nebeneinander stehen, auf derselben Seite unterschiedliche Sachen anzeigen, das ist schon ein bisschen komisch, ne? So viel zum 15 Zoll. 17 Zoll hat sich nicht geändert, ne? Also es ist nicht so, dass sie jetzt komplett PCI Express ausgemistet haben, sondern es gibt nach wie vor das 17 Zoll-Gerät und da ist noch alles genauso.
Naja, die ist ein bisschen schneller und so. Schnellerer Prozessor und...
Stimmt, ich dachte mal...
Was, hast du dann noch Speedbump bekommen? War das nicht schon so?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, da hat sich jetzt nicht geändert. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist das das Einzige, was jetzt ein Express-Card-Slot hat. Und da sie ja das schon vorher auf die neue Batterie-Generation aktualisiert hatten, ihr erinnert euch, das war ja vorher schon, kam ja später als die anderen und war dann wiederum einen Schritt weiter. Dann eben schon die Vermutung, dass sie jetzt bei den anderen mit den Batterien auch nachziehen. Ich meine, sie haben jetzt im Prinzip plus zwei Stunden Batterielaufzeit, offiziell. Das ist schon signifikant. Auch das Kleine. Und das finde ich ist eine Ansage. Also das ist wirklich ein echter Mehrwert.
Da werden sie natürlich aber auch wieder ein paar Leute ärgern, die wirklich irgendwie so mit zwei, drei Batterien sich so ein paar Tage oder wie lange auch immer über Wasser halten.
Ich glaube, das macht keiner.
Na ja, bestimmt drei.
Die laden wir alle mal hierher. Eine, dann können sie ganz laut über Apple schimpfen.
Die sollen sich einfach einen zweiten Rechner kaufen, den sie mitführen. Tja, wo leben wir denn? Sonderwünsche. So, und jetzt kommt das Drama. Ich hab diesen Stream gesehen, muss dir einfach mal vorstellen, was in mir abging. Und dann dieses MacBook Pro, 13 Zoll. Die guten Sachen ist, feier war ja 800, dachte ich mir so. Alter Schwede, da mussten die Audio-Jungs ihnen so aufs Dach gestiegen sein, die müssen denen so die Fresse eingehauen haben in den letzten halben Jahren. Das kann ich mir echt nicht anders vorstellen.
Die haben das einfach in das Alte nicht reingekriegt, in das Letzte. Platzmäßig.
Es ist nach wie vor dasselbe Gehäuse.
Ist dasselbe Gehäuse, aber ist ein anderes Motherboard.
Na ja gut, das ist ein anderes Motherboard. Hätten sie vorher auch gebraucht, wenn sie vorher weiter hätten.
War eine politische Entscheidung, gehe ich mal davon aus.
Ich glaube auch, dass sie das einfach meinten, das weglassen zu können. Und jetzt haben sie es wieder eingebaut.
Hat jemand noch so eine Seitenaufnahme? Ich habe ja irgendwann mal hier von der lustigen Theorie erzählt, die irgendjemand propagiert hat.
Was meinst du für eine Seitenaufnahme?
Na ja, von so einem MacBook, wie das von der Seite aussieht an den Anschlüssen.
Jetzt?
Na jetzt ist es kein Problem, aber bei dem alten vorher. So.
Bei dem alten MacBook.
Bei dem alten MacBook, dem von gestern früh quasi. Na ja, wie das an der Seite, wie die Anschlussleiste aussah.
Na ja, genauso wie bei deinem 15 Zoller, bloß ohne Firewire.
Äh, nee, ich hab zum Beispiel...
Und ohne diesen Express Card Slot.
Und hatten die auch zwei USB? Also wie haben sie das jetzt reingequetscht? Das meine ich jetzt.
Na ja, sie haben halt jetzt da einen SD Card Slot, sie haben diesen Klau, Kensington-Dingsbumms auf die andere Seite gelinkt.
Haben sie schon mal gespart und haben sie ja noch an einer Stelle gespart.
Und dann haben sie halt noch an einer Stelle gespart.
Jetzt geht's los.
Genau. Und ich war schon wirklich auf der Seite, ich hab mir schon eine Preiskonfiguration zusammengestellt, hab geguckt, was die Upgrades kosten. Ich weiß nicht, ich hätte das Ding wahrscheinlich heute gekauft. Es wäre einfach der Tag gewesen, wo ich mir ein neues MacBook gekauft habe. Und ich war so sauer, hab ich festgestellt, dass das Ding keinen Audio-Eingang mehr hat, keinen digitalen. Und dass sie nur noch eine Buchse haben. Könnt ihr jetzt mal sagen, wie scheiße ihr das findet?
Ich weine.
Ich auch nicht. Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß. Das braucht wahrscheinlich auch wieder keiner. Das ist eine total rationale Entscheidung. Aber es hat mich leider davon abgebracht, dieses Gerät zu bestellen.
Kauf dem 15 Zoll.
Also die rechnen halt damit, dass Leute, die den digitalen Audio Eingang benutzen, die müssen ja auch irgendwie einen digitalen Audio Ausgang haben. Das heißt, für unterwegs ist es eher wahrscheinlich nicht so wirklich was, sondern mehr so lokal.
Also ich bitte dich, ein Laptop ist heutzutage nicht mehr für unterwegs.
Eben.
So, und zu Hause kann man sich auf den fünften Zoll hinstellen.
Also die denken halt nicht, dass einer, der irgendwie fett mit digitalen Ausgängen rumspielt und dicke Aufnahmen macht, dass der sich so ein kleines 13 Zoll hinstellt.
Ja, das ist... Ja, was...
Glaube ich.
Du, aber wenn sich vorher schon die ganze Audiowelt darüber beschwert hat, dass kein Firewire mehr dran ist, warum nimmt man dann der Audiowelt dann die andere großartige Schnittstelle, die dieses Gerät hat?
Wahrscheinlich haben sie jetzt ihre ganze Firewire-Hafen wieder dran bekommt, die sie bisher immer aufgenommen haben.
Aber Firewire ist scheiße.
Wie? Aber du hast doch gesagt, nein, du hast doch gesagt, dass ohne Firewire geht gar nichts. Jetzt haben sie auf dich gehört und jetzt ist das auch wieder richtig blöd.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, ich hab nicht gesagt, dass ohne Firewire gar nichts geht. Ich hab nur gesagt, dass das dazu führt, dass ich länger warten muss, bis ich mich entscheiden kann für dieses Gerät, weil ich halt nicht weiß, ob ich nicht unter Umständen noch angewiesen bin auf Audiogeräte, die Firewire haben.
Genau.
Und da gibt's eine ganze Reihe von Geräten, die da durchaus für mich eine Option sind. Deswegen hab ich mir dieses Gerät nicht gekauft. Jetzt ist es so, jetzt ist Firewire drin, sodass das sozusagen von mir abfällt. Das Hintergrund beleuchtet Tastatur, hätte ich gerne noch als Goodie mitgenommen. Und jetzt fällt aber der digitale Audio-Eingang weg und den benutze ich täglich. Also der ist für mich vollkommen essentiell. Ich könnte dieses Gerät jetzt hier live in diesem Moment nicht als Aufzeichnungs- und Streaming-Computer verwenden.
Dafür hast du doch jetzt Firewire. Gibt es doch nicht so schicke Firewire-Audio-Devices?
Nee, es gibt keine schicken Firewire-Audio-Devices.
Ich dachte, du hast doch gesagt, USB wäre schreut wegen einer Latenz und ein Firewire, das ist es. Und deswegen wollten die ganzen Audio-Typen Firewire wieder beim kleinen MacBook Pro haben.
Also, erstmal, Firewire und USB, wenn egal, wie toll sie programmiert sind, was sie nicht sind, die Treiber, ja, also erstmal sind die alle scheiße. Aber selbst wenn sie nicht scheiße wären, handelt es sich einfach um Kupfer, was deinen Rechner mit dem restlichen Zeug verbindet.
Ist nicht galvanisch getrennt, meinst du.
Genau.
Und man hat das halt immer mal wieder.
Aber du kannst ja so ein Firewire-Device mit optischem Eingang holen.
Firewire-Device mit optischem Eingang?
Du willst ja einfach einen Firewire-Adapter.
Mit optischem Eingang. Jetzt sag nicht, das gibt's nicht.
So was gibt's nicht.
Klar gibt's das. Hab ich schon für USB gesehen, so ein Scheiß.
Ach so, USB-Soundkarten gibt's doch mit optischen Eingängen.
Klar, dann gibt's das für Firewire auch.
Ja, es gibt riesige, klobige, teure 800-Euro-Blöcke, wo ich dann irgendwie einen 20-Cent-Port benutze. Klar, klar gibt's sowas, aber was soll ich denn noch alles mit rumschleppen?
Kauf dir einfach einen 15 Zoll.
Ich fand das einfach großartig, dass ich hier einfach so ein kleines Minikabel reinstecke. Es ist galvanisch getrennt, nichts brummt. Das ist dieser ganze Firewire und USB-Kram halt auch alles nicht ordentlich. Und ich brauche keine Treiber. Ich stecke das da einfach rein. Ich habe so die Schnauze voll von Treibern, die mir den Tag versauen. Na gut, vielleicht ist das jetzt eine Option. Das 15 Zoll ist jetzt wirklich ein sanes Gerät, obwohl er halt wieder so mit dem SD-Card ist. Ich halt's mal. Ich hätte mir jetzt fast einen Computer gekauft. Das soll ich sagen. So, MacBook Air ist billiger geworden. Und zwar habe ich jetzt auf Deutschpreis auch noch nicht nachgeguckt.
Die SSD-Variante umsucht unglaublich viel. Wie viel? 700 Dollar billiger die SSD-Variante?
Das haben sie gesagt. So, jetzt gucken wir noch mal. Also, Einsteigerpreis ist jetzt 1400 Euro.
Also bei mir sind es 1399.
Du bist entlassen. Übrigens hier meint einer, dass der...
Wo meint das einer? Im Chat? Ja. Meint einer was?
Dass der Audio-Eingang selectable ist und man kann ihn auf Ausgang stellen. Also man kann ihn nur unter Switchen.
Es steht aber nichts mehr von Audio-Eingang auf der Webseite.
Der meint, also hier im Chat meint es einer, wenn wir darauf eingehen wollen, da meint einer, dass er so auf der Apple-Homepage steht. Combined Optical Digital Output slash Headphone Out und Klammern User Selectable Analog Audio Line In.
Aber nicht Digital Line In.
Genau. Also du hast halt da ein Aus, du kannst halt da dein iPhone Headset reinstecken und so weiter. Das funktioniert im Prinzip genauso wie der Jack vom iPhone oder vom iPod Touch.
Was ist das eigentlich für ein Kack Standard da? Ich meine, da ist ja auch so eine Art Diode, die Licht macht über Glasfaser oder Plaste, was die da so benutzen, um da Kommunikation zu machen, um dein Audio da rüber zu schicken. Warum geht das nicht in zwei Richtungen?
Because that's the way it's designed.
Stimmt, bei Ethernet und so braucht man ja auch immer zwei.
Ja, naja gut, da kann man jetzt nichts dran ändern. So ist der Standard halt. Das ist halt SPDIF, beziehungsweise SPDIF ist ein Protokoll, was man eben über diese optische Anschlussleitung fahren kann, aber die ist halt unidirektional und ADAT ist das andere Protokoll, was man darüber fahren könnte. Da haben wir ja schon drüber geredet. Das unterstützt Apple halt auch nicht, was halt wirklich, das wäre halt ein bold move, wenn sie mal, wenn sie irgendwie, was weiß ich jetzt, dann kaufe ich auch sofort das 15 Zoll, dann denke ich auch echt nicht drüber nach, wenn sie das machen. Einfach so ein kleines Treiberchen, was ADAT macht, sodass man einfach über diese eine analoge Schnittstelle in Echtzeit acht Audiokanäle rein rausmachen kann. Da gibt es so viel Equipment auf dem Markt, mit dem man das benutzen könnte. Vielleicht hört uns ja einer zu, der gut programmieren kann, der mal Bock hat, diesen Soundstein zu machen. Ich kenne mich da nicht so gut aus, aber mir wurde gesagt...
Das ist bestimmt eine Hardware, oder?
Bitte?
Dann ist schon so ein Fertig-Shift drin.
Ja, man könnte das Protokoll mit diesem Stein halt realisieren. Das war eine Aussage. Ob die sich halten lässt, das weiß ich nicht. Das kann natürlich sein, dass sich das jemand mal genau anschaut und feststellt. So einfach ist es dann auch wieder nicht. Aber bisher habe ich da so recht keinen Argument dagegen gefunden. Schöner wär's. Also, fassen wir mal zusammen. Grundsätzlich ist das ganze Line-Up besser geworden. Das 15 Zoll, also wenn man jetzt mal von diesem Konflikt mit PCI Express absieht, denke ich, war das schon ein deutlicher Schritt nach vorne. Das 13 Zoll ist sehr viel attraktiver geworden. Für die meisten. Also gerade mit der Hintergrundbeleuchtung, wobei das billigste Modell hat, das glaube ich auch immer noch nicht.
Vorher hatte er nur die bessere Ausstattung.
Achso, jetzt haben es alle.
Und jetzt haben es alle, weil es ja Pro ist.
Ach stimmt, das gab es.
Was haben jetzt alle?
Das gab es ja auch.
Hintergrundbeleuchtung.
Aber es ist ja ein Pro-Muster, so ein bisschen.
Genau, irgendwo müssen sie ja auch mal was bringen. Genau, das stimmt schon. Und la la la. Sie sind schon in die nächste Generation, so mit 8 GB RAM, bla bla bla. Also das ist jetzt irgendwie auch bis in das kleinste Modell, ist das einfach alles ordentlich.
Nicht zu vernachlässigen der Speed Bump.
Genau, und billiger. Also ich finde vor allem, dass billiger ist, glaube ich, etwas, was hilft.
Also ich habe gestern doch schon kurz geschluckt. Also ich meine, als ich das gelesen habe oder gehört habe.
Geschluckt inwiefern?
Na ja, wie gesagt, vor drei Wochen habe ich einen 2,4 für 1,8 gekauft.
Du hast ja einen 2,4 Gigahertz für 1,8 gekauft.
Das war die alte Variante.
Und jetzt gibt es gar keinen 2,4 mehr. Und es gibt bei allen sechs los.
Und ich habe nochmal einen Hunni für Ram drauf gelegt. Oder so.
Naja, so ist das Leben.
So ist das Leben.
Gut, weiter geht's.
Schnorleport.
Schnorleport. Ei, Schnorleport. Das war ja wirklich träge. Also ich meine, da war ja nun wirklich nicht viel Neues dabei. Sehr wenig Neues war dabei.
Naja, insofern nicht, weil viel durch die Blog schon gegangen ist und öfters mal offensichtlich die Weller Passizige.
Naja, auch vieles, was sie schon bei der letzten WWDC vorgetragen haben.
Also das Exposé mit dem Dock zu verbinden und so weiter, das war schon ganz okay.
Ja, es ist ein kleines Usability Enhancement.
Ja, aber es ist gar nicht mal so richtig. Na doch, das Dock ist schon natürlich Schnorleport-Style, aber es ist ja eigentlich ein Zusatztool so ein bisschen.
Ist das für Leute, die ihr Dock immer sichtbar haben?
Na ich hab mein Dock immer sichtbar.
Ich auch.
Ja, das ist ja meine Informationsquelle auf der Programme rennen. Ich bin ja ein Programmeschließer.
Ach du bist ein Programmeschließer, wenn ich mein Dock immer anhätt.
Ich bin da schon so lange dabei, ich hab das so auf einem Amiga, da musstest du halt Programme schließen, da hat es halt nur zwei MB und die waren teuer.
Ja, aber siehst du, kaufst du den 5. Zoll, dann kannst du das Dock immer offen lassen.
Ich hab da zu viele Icons drin. Ich benutze das Dock eigentlich nur als Launcher. Sonst gar nichts, ich dreck da nichts drauf. Ich benutze auch dieses, wie heißt das, Stacks? Nicht. Tim arbeitet ja auch nicht mit seinen Rechten.
So ein long time joke.
Ja, ich hab ihm das immer vorgeworfen, dass er mit seinem Mac gar nicht arbeitet. Stacks auf diesem Dog benutzt du das?
Wenn man den Ordner... Willst du den aufpoppen? Total. Echt?
Wofür?
Ich hab da immer ein paar Ordner drin. Ich hab einen Ordner auf meinem Server drin, ich hab den Programmer-Ordner noch mal drin.
Was guckst du denn da in diesen... Was schaust du da rein, weißt du nicht sowieso, was da drin ist? Weißt du nicht, was in deinen Ordnern drin ist?
Ich muss die manchmal aufmachen. Weil da Dateien drin liegen, die ich gerne öffnen möchte. Ich nehme den Fein, um Programme zu starten, und Dateien zu öffnen.
Ich bin Launchbar-User. Du hast alles über Launchbar laufen? Alles, was ich regelmäßig brauche, ruf ich mit zwei, drei Tasten drücken. Was soll ich denn da ewig mit der Maus-Rumpf-Uhr werken? Und wichtige Ordner, wichtige Programme, wichtige Dokumente, Launchbar, zack, fertig. Da hab ich dann irgendwie Control Space, zack, zwei Buchstaben, wumm, zack, return, da guck ich doch gar nicht auf den Bildschirm. Da guck ich doch nicht auf den Bildschirm, das dauert ja Stunden. Ach darum, der Maus da rechts, irgendwie 1194 Pixel nach links schieben.
Aber mal ehrlich, du weißt doch, wie deine letzten Dokumente alle hießen und so?
Meine letzten Dokumente hab ich in Recent Files. Da geh ich in das Programm und sage, zack, return, cursor rechts, dann hab ich da meine Recent Files und dann, zack, return, ruf ich die auf und fertig.
Bumm, zack, return.
Ne, mal ehrlich, also wenn ich hier... Gucke mal, Textmate, ja, ich will irgendwie ein File, was ich irgendwie gestern in Textmate editiert habe. So, dann mach ich Ctrl-Space, TM, dann hab ich oben Textmate, dann drücke ich cursor rechts und dann hab ich alle letzten 20 Files, die ich da irgendwie bearbeitet habe, hab ich da drin, ruf ich auf, zack, return, zack, return.
Also ich benutze...
Bumm, zack, return.
Also ich benutze die...
Denk mal, die Sendung, dein Name ist klar.
Ich hab's auch schon notiert.
Ja, aber ich...
Ich auch immer.
Ich benutze die ständig. Okay, ist super, ist super.
Ich bin schon wieder, ich bin so raus aus dem Standard-Profil. Also wir halten fest, die Stacks haben sich verbessert und viele Leute freuen sich darüber.
Und das Exposé halt, das war schon cool.
Das Exposé, okay, das will ich erstmal ausprobieren. Das sah in der Tat ganz gut aus, dass man so über Exposé einen weiteren Job machen kann.
Der Presenter, der war ja neuer, der war ja vorher noch nicht auf der Bühne.
Dieser Cargirihari...
Redericksen oder so hieß der doch, oder?
Nee, war das nicht so ein italienischer Name?
Ich dachte, ah, jetzt hat der Bertrand sich noch jemand geholt, der demlich langsend hat.
Ich glaub, der hat noch gefehlt zum Franzosen oder so, aber jedenfalls war der ganz schön gut.
We have a year in new, fine there. A lot of most beautiful icons.
Du hier war im Film. Wie heißt der Schauspieler?
Roberto Benigni.
I click an icon. Oh, Snow Leopard is a beautiful god. Coco Finder, du hast es gesagt. Sie haben es gesagt, sie können nicht mehr zurück. Ich meine, es war klar, we nailed it, weil 64-Bit heißt einfach Coco, aber jetzt haben sie es gesagt.
Haben sie es vorher nicht gesagt?
Ich glaube nicht.
Das haben sie vorher nicht gesagt.
Es war immer nur so klar, aber jetzt haben sie es zugegeben.
Es war klar, wenn man Screenshots gesehen hat.
Wenn da noch ein Button nach Carbon aussieht, dann gibt es sowas auf der Rübe. Aber sie haben ja so... Da gab es ja diesen einen Slide. Warte mal, da habe ich mir extra noch den Screenshot abgeschäft.
Habt ihr den gesehen?
Der war so ähnlich wie bei dieser iPhone OS. Mit diesen ganzen versteckten Features, die sie durch...
Ja, da habe ich auch alles durchgeguckt. So, Empty Trash ist jetzt schneller. Habt ihr das gelesen?
Das sollten sie plakatieren. Schneller Papierkorb entleeren.
Schneller abbrechen.
Der Eject-Mechanismus ist jetzt irgendwie more advanced.
Der Eject-Mechanismus ist tatsächlich...
Der ist more advanced, weil wenn du jetzt zwei Laufwerke, zwei Partitionen hast und du machst davon einer Eject, kommt so ein Fenster und dann fragt er dich, wie willst du gleich das ganze device ejecten?
Das machen schon die Alten. Das macht Leopard auch schon. Nee. Ich hab's auf meinem Rechner schon gesehen und ich hab ja kein Snow Lepard.
Doch, doch, stimmt.
Was ist denn dann aber more advanced? Zum einen, das hab ich auf der Seite einfach gelesen, da steht das da. Zum einen ist es nämlich, dass er in vielen Fällen, wo er bisher immer gesagt hat, nee, kann ich nicht auswerfen, weil, oder kann ich nicht auswerfen, dass er das in Zukunft nicht mehr macht.
Stimmt, er sagt nämlich dann, welches Programm irgendwie das auswerfen will.
Und es passiert wohl nicht ganz so häufig einfach.
Ach so, was man derzeit nur mit diesem Why-Not-Unmount-Programm hinkriegt.
Genau, das ist dann Build-In.
Ja, das wurde aber auch echt mal Zeit. Das betrieb, seitdem man nicht sagen kann, welcher Prozess irgendwie eine Ressource erhältst, ist da wirklich eine Frechheit.
New Services Menü. Das ist ja Tim, was will, Tim will im New Services Menü am liebsten.
Das ist das geilste Feature im ganzen Snorlebot. Man kann jetzt Services ausschalten. Man kann sie einfach aus dem Sinn weg.
Geh.
Sterben.
Verglühe. Nee, aber man kann sich auch selber welche anlegen.
Schön. Ich will sie ausschalten.
Ich find's geil, dass man mit Automator irgendwelche...
Du benutzt auch Services, ja? Was kommt noch alles, Max? Du benutzt Stacks, du benutzt SD-Karten und jetzt benutzt du auch noch Services?
Was kommt als nächstes?
Ich benutze die Funktion, dass man schon jetzt Tastaturbefehle ändern kann, indem man den Namen des Menübefehls eingibt in den Systemeinstellungen und dann den Shortcut ändern kann.
Wie gibst du den Namen eines Menübefehls ein, wenn du mit mehrsprachigen Programmen arbeitest? Das ist ja wirklich der größte Schrott. Das ist auch ganz schlimm.
Was?
Na ja, du musst auch Keyboard-Shortcuts heute darüber anlegen, indem du den Namen des Menübefehls eingibst.
Genau.
Aber dieser Name des Menübefehls ist ja abhängig von deiner Sprache.
Das finde ich eher sogar angenehm. Ich will jetzt ja eigentlich nur mein Programm ändern.
Dann lockst du dich in einer anderen Sprache ein und dann musst du deine ganzen Shortcuts ändern?
Ich lock mich nicht in einer anderen Sprache ein. Im Wesentlichen geht es ja darum, dass eines der wenigen Programme, wo man es nicht ändern kann, das eigentlich schon eine Schlimme ist, ist Textmade. Da kann man keine Shortcuts ändern. Das ist sowieso nur auf Englisch. Darum sind die Shortcuts nämlich auch so dämlich. Darum hast du nämlich so Tabwechsel mit Apfel, Ecke Klammer rechts, Ecke Klammer links. Und das habe ich auf Apfel, L und Ö geändert.
Also diese ganze Tastatur mit Funktionstastenbelegung finde ich, auch nach dem, was ich jetzt an Screenshots gesehen habe, bei Snorl App, das ist immer noch wirklich Windows 95. Also das kann doch nicht das Problem sein, dafür mal ein ordentliches User Interface machen, wo man einfach auf eine Tastatur guckt und dann sieht man auf jeder Taste, welche Funktionalität da drauf ist und wenn da mehrere drüber sind, dass da irgendwie ein Collision angezeigt wird, rot darfst du nicht, ist doppelt belegt und so weiter. Wieso kannst du sowas nicht visualisieren? Das geht doch nicht. Ich finde das rückständig mit diesen komischen Listen, da musst du da durchscrollen und so weiter. Zeigen sie mir nicht einfach die scheiß Tastatur an und sagen mir einfach da drückst du drauf, dann passiert das, das muss doch visualisierbar sein.
Ich weiß genau, umgekehrt haben will eigentlich. Ich möchte ja nicht wissen, was passiert, wenn ich A, B, C, C, H drücke, sondern ich will wissen, wie blende ich Programme aus?
Wie blendest du Programme aus? Da gehst du einfach ins Help-Menü und suchst danach. Dann zeigt er dir genau den Befehl an. Aber man will ja auch manchmal wissen, wie ist denn meine Tastatur belegt? Häufig drückst du einfach eine Taste und du weißt doch überhaupt nicht, was passiert denn, wenn ich auf F11 drücke? Was passiert denn?
Das City not touching the blinking lights.
Wenn du keine Ahnung von deinem Mac hast, dann drück da nicht drauf rum.
Ich finde das rückständig. Sie haben da Chor-Animation und diesen ganzen Klim-Bim.
Es gibt so eine Erweiterung.
3D und OpenCL. Sind sie nicht in der Lage?
Das heißt KeyQ, glaube ich. Und damit kann man sich anzeigen, dass wenn man die Apfel-Taste gedrückt hat, es zeigt einem alle Shortcuts ein, die so gehen und welche du drücken kannst.
Na gut, aber wir waren ja eigentlich bei was anderem. Wo waren wir?
Wir waren bei CocoFinder.
Ejecten. Services-Menü. Also man kann die als ausschalten. Ich möchte das noch mal festhalten.
Und ich möchte festhalten, man kann sich eigenen Automater zusammen basteln. Das finde ich gar nicht schlecht. Es gibt die Möglichkeit, sich eigene Services in Automater zusammen zu basteln.
Und dann?
Dann kannst du sie einbauen, zum Beispiel in Finder oder Safari.
Dann hast du noch mehr Shortcuts, die die Shortcuts zu deinen Lieblingsprogrammen überlagern.
Dann kannst du mit der rechten Maustaste, kannst du dann, also mit, wie heißt das, wie heißt das?
Secondary-Click heißt das.
Das stimmt ja. Wie komme ich auf rechte Maustaste?
Nazi-Click.
Und dann kannst du eine Datei anklicken, dann kannst du damit automatisch irgendwelche Aktionen durchführen.
Also so Kontextmenü-mäßig.
So Kontextmenü-mäßig. Dann kannst du die selber vorher zurechtbasteln. Dann kannst du den Kontextmenü-Eintrag basteln, mit dem du die Daten automatisch, Bilder runterrechnen kannst, mit dem du die per Mail verschicken kannst, oder irgendeine andere Platte kopierst.
Okay, ist alles in Ordnung, das kann man alles machen, aber es ist einfach überfällig gewesen, dass man diesem Betriebssystem verbieten kann, irgendwelche Programme, dass irgendwelche Programme, nur weil sie installiert sind, also nur der Vorgang des Kopieren eines Programms auf meinem Rechner und sonst keinerlei weitere Interaktion, führt dazu, dass ich in anderen Programmen, die nichts damit zu tun haben, meine Lieblings-Shortcuts nicht mehr benutzen kann. Das geht nicht. Ich sag nur, Apfel kleiner. Apfel Shift kleiner. Wenn ich Omni-Outliner installiert habe, kommt mir überall, und damit will ich durch meine Fenster durchrotieren, vollkommen legitimer System weiter Shortcut. Haben Sie so festgelegt? Ist super, ich rotiere gerne durch meine Fenster, kaum ist Omni-Outliner installiert, kommt dieses Teil hoch. Oh, du wolltest ein Clipping erstellen! Und dann wird irgendwie die aktuelle Text-Delektion in so eine neue Outline, in so ein New Document reingefeuert, die ich nicht haben wollte. Ich kann durch meine Fenster nicht mehr durchsagen, ist es einfach BD. Und das kann man jetzt endlich ausschalten.
Ich glaube, ich träume heute Nacht auf. Das ist ja noch so ein Next-Step-Feature, das mit den Services, ne? Und jetzt, wo Steve irgendwie krank war, haben sie es schnell genutzt, um es irgendwie zu streichen.
Genau, genau, genau.
Wenn er tot gewesen wäre, hätten sie auch eine zwei Tasten raus ausgeliefert. Ich glaube, ich träume...
Als erstes, wenn Steve tot ist, bekommen wir das Betriebssystem, das wir schon immer haben wollten.
Also ich glaube, ich werde heute Nacht davon träumen, so mit Wahnsinn, wie du durch deine Fenster rotierst und plötzlich vom Omni-Outlader daran gehindert wirst. Was haben sie noch so schönes? New Eject Manager.
Ja, New Eject Manager, das haben wir jetzt. Jetzt kommt auch...
Customizable Cancellation.
Das können sie auch nicht wirklich ernsthaft meine.
Gibt es ja noch ein Cancel, was irgendwie ewig dauert?
Ja, das stimmt aber. Doch, wenn du kopierst, wenn du Dateien kopierst und du drückst auf Cancel, dann dauert es manchmal einfach unglaublich lange, bis das endet.
Manchmal auch, wenn du irgendwie probierst, mit einem Netzlaufwerk zu verbinden oder sowas.
Ich hab auch irgendwo gelesen, dass Time Machine jetzt schneller starten soll. Davon war allerdings in der Keynote selbst nicht zu sehen.
Wir haben kein Wort über Time Machine.
Aber ich hab das im Internet gelesen.
Auf der Webseite. Aber es gibt da so eine Firma, hat auch apple.com, hat auch so eine Webseite und da steht eine Menge über Time Machine drinnen, dass es nämlich deutlich schneller geworden sein soll. Generell. Und dass das erste Backup unglaublich viel, viel schneller gehen soll.
Da hab ich nur eins zu sagen. Zeit wird's. Das war so langsam, dass man manchmal einfach nicht einen Backup fertigstellen konnte in einer träglichen Zeit.
Ja, das war es wirklich. Also das ist echt.
Und wo ich sehr gespannt bin, ob sie das Problem lösen mit dem Fortsetzen von abgebrochenen Backups. Weil also nicht nur, dass es lange gedauert hat, bis dein erstes durch ist, sondern wenn das aus irgendwelchen Gründen fehlschlägt, weil keine Ahnung, dein WLAN weggebrochen ist oder du musst halt einfach das Haus verlassen und musst es einfach abbrechen. Dann hast du so ein halbfertiges... Ja, aber dann hast du so ein angefangenes halbes Backup. Und wenn du dann halt nochmal sagst, jetzt Backup, dann guckt er sich erstmal das an und braucht nochmal ein paar Stunden, nur um festzustellen, wo er weitermachen soll. Das dauert dann doch länger. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass es hier teilweise eine Woche gedauert hat, bis er überhaupt erstmal wieder in den Modus kam, regelmäßige Backups vorzunehmen.
Installationen sind hier eh nicht vorzeigefähig. Eine Woche.
Ja, aber das ist einfach die Realität.
Hier. Hier, genau.
Ja, und das ist halt einfach nur Standard. Ich hab ja noch nicht mal irgendwie...
Vielleicht haben sie da jetzt Faster Cancellation eingebaut.
Faster Cancellation.
Das ist super. Was gibt's noch auf dem Bild?
Faster Icon Drawing.
Icon Drawing?
Wenn die schneller Icons zeichnen.
Naja, aber das ist doch nicht schlecht. Also ich meine, wenn das Ding generell schneller wird, ist das doch schon...
Ja, aber Faster Icon Drawing, das klingt so wie dieses Improved Reliability. Warum konnten sie denn die vorher nicht schnell zeigen?
Ich glaube, die haben jetzt wieder ein bisschen an ihrem Chore Graphics da, also an... Na nicht Chore Graphics, sondern ein bisschen mehr auf die Grafik gerade ausgelagert.
Na, nee, ich...
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach so dadurch, dass sie Coco nutzen, können sie jetzt einfach Chore Graphics messen und benutzen, wo sie vorher einfach von Hand gemalt haben.
Na und ihre Grand Central Zeug hier, Grand Central, wie heißt das? Ja, aber das wird ja, also das steht hier nämlich auch Fewer Threats When Idle.
Ja, ja, das ist das.
Das haben sie ja nochmal erklärt bei Mail und so, da muss man erstmal nochmal genauer gucken, was das so bringt.
Contextual Menu Consistency ist auch ein Feature. Sie haben jetzt mehr Konsistenz in ihren Sekundärklicks.
Ja, aber die eigentliche Nachricht, die da fett oben drüber stehen müsste, ist Coco. Und nochmal fett 64-Bit. Und der Rest ist Pille-Palle nebenbei.
Aber es gibt hier noch einen Feature, was ich bemerkenswert finde, und das kommt dann auch später nochmal beim Safari zu tragen.
Out of Process Plugins nehme ich mal an.
Genau. Und davon, das war mir neu. Da hatte ich noch gar nichts von gehört im Vorfeld. Dass sie jetzt ein Konzept haben, wie man Plugins in eigene Prozesse auslagern kann.
Deswegen auch, dass sie jetzt beim Safari crashen können, ohne den Safari mit runterzureißen.
Das heißt aber auch, dass sie im Finder crashen können, ohne den Finder mitzureißen. Das ist doch richtig. Generell kann das bedeuten, dass Plugins von Programmen überhaupt grundsätzlich nicht mehr...
Na das ist wahrscheinlich so.
Gerade beim Finder war es ja irgendwann mal lustig, wenn man es geschafft hatte, irgendwie ein korruptes JPEG, was in Finder gecrashed hat, irgendwo einen Oner zu haben, dann brauchst du bloß den Oner aufmachen, dann ist der scheiß Finder abgeschürzt.
Ja und dafür gibt es ja den Quick Look Demon, der ist ja auch schon ein eigener Thread. Und multithreaded und alles mit Watchdog. Und was wahrscheinlich der Launch die macht, aber ok. Und wenn der crashst, ist es dem Finder ja auch egal. Also wahrscheinlich haben die das einfach nochmal vervielfältigt.
Kann schon sein, ja.
Und deswegen auch die Faster Icon-Dings, weil das jetzt wahrscheinlich ein ganz anderes Plugin macht.
Die machen wahrscheinlich einfach wirklich sehr viel mehr parallelisiert und weniger Hänger und deswegen ist das Ding insgesamt schneller. Ich bin gespannt.
Ich auch.
Ich bin wirklich gespannt.
Man muss leider nur so lange warten.
Was war nochmal der Release? September.
September, ohne genauen Tag aber noch. Also anfangs könnte aber auch Ende sein. Geh mal von Ende aus, wie immer.
Finde ich aber beruhigend. Also ich meine nicht, dass ich es nicht gerne haben wollen würde, aber ich finde es gut, dass sie sich noch ein bisschen Zeit lassen können. Und da sind sie immer noch vor Vista draußen.
Vista 2 meinst du?
Ja, ja.
Da haben sie auch ordentlich drauf eingeschlagen.
Wobei ich nicht weiß, warum das nötig war.
Weil es Spaß macht.
Schneller installen. 45 Prozent schneller.
Ja, und das fand ich auch nochmal interessant. Weil es gibt ja schon immer noch Leute, die können sich halt nicht so einen dicken Rechner leisten. Die haben immer noch so eine uralte Kiste von irgendwie 2000 damals. Und wenn das Snow Leopard jetzt irgendwie 6 GB weniger braucht, dann kann man auch mal auf so einen älteren Rechnern vielleicht mal wieder auf einer vielleicht noch zu kleinen Partition ohne alles neu machen zu müssen, Snow Leopard installieren.
Na ja, mit älteren Rechnern eines nicht.
Natürlich nur mit Tricks natürlich, aber...
Na es geht ja eh nur Intel. Snow Leopard ist Intel.
Doch, das ist Intel. Wer hat das gesagt?
Das haben sie gesagt.
Doch, ich hab keine Nr. unterschrieben. Das Snow Leopard ist komplette Due.
Ja, die Developer-Version noch.
Nicht der Kernel.
Doch auch.
Aber sie haben angekündigt, dass es nur für Intel ist.
Punkt. Glaub ich nicht.
Haben sie gesagt.
Wer? Wann? Nee, wirklich.
Waren einer von diesen Vögeln, deren Namen man nicht kennt, weil sie alle nicht Steve Jobs sind. Ja, Snow Leopard ist für Intel. Punkt.
Wie deine PowerPC. Aber was?
Aber ich meine, damit läufst du viel besser auf Netbooks in Zukunft.
Aber das heißt, die ganz coolen, quad-wassergekühlten G5 können jetzt keinen Snow Leopard machen?
Die sind doch eh alle schon durchgerostet.
Das sind einfach die paar Büchsen da draußen. Zählen echt gar nicht.
Ey, mein Dual-G4 500 MHz. Ja, da könnte von diesem Grand Central Dispatch noch richtig was raus. Ich könnte dich schwören, dass es echt noch mal schneller ist als der normale Laptop.
Das ist die Apple-Verschwörung.
Das heißt, ich kann dir sagen, was passiert. Alle werden irgendwie sich die letzte Developer-Beta, was keine Ahnung, die 354 ist, die ja auch schon kurz vor fertig ist, werden dann sich die installieren auf ihren alten Power-PC-Kisten.
Ich kann dir sagen, was passiert. Es hat niemand mehr alte Power-PC-Kisten.
Klar, man, ohne Ende.
Natürlich gibt es ja aber die Notwendigkeit, da jetzt unbedingt noch ein Upgrade zu machen von Leopard. Klar werden die dann theoretisch viel schneller usw. Aber am Ende des Tages ist es einfach nicht mehr so wichtig.
Und probier mal, ich glaube, meines Wissens lässt sich noch Leopard...
Was heißt denn hier guck mal?
Ich schrei jetzt auf der Webseite drauf, da steht...
Sie schmeißen den ganzen PowerPC raus und das ist auch...
Good thing, ne.
Ja, das ist auch schon mal hier ganz wichtig für irgendwie ihre... Wir brauchen 6 GB weniger Platz. Sie haben ja von Fall System Compression gesprochen, da war sie immer noch nicht so richtig.
Ja, das will ich ja gerne wissen. Wahrscheinlich meinen sie, dass sie diese XEB-Dateien ein bisschen Luft rausgelassen haben.
Aber sie könnten einfach den Button klicken und das ganze Ding für PowerPC bauen.
Ja, sie könnten, aber warum soll sie das machen? Weil dann müssen sie es nicht nur für PowerPC bauen, dann müssen sie es auch für PowerPC testen.
Dann hätten sie plötzlich vier Plattformen, so haben sie nur noch zwei.
Und sie müssen dann auch PowerPC supporten.
Das ist der CNA 354 Bild, der hat irgendwie einen Intel 64-Bit, einen normalen i3-86 irgendwie und einen PowerPC-Körnel drauf.
Aber keinen PPC 64-Bit? Für den würde es ja noch Sinn machen.
Also 64-Bit nicht für PowerPC machen, sehe ich ja irgendwie ein oder okay oder von mir aus, keine Ahnung, aber sodass sie gar keinen PowerPC mehr machen.
Die haben Prioritäten.
Pass auf, sie haben jetzt wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile einfach mitgebaut, weil...
Oder sie schreiben so hin und die CD, die man kauft, die ist trotzdem für PowerPC.
Das haben die drauf.
Da gucken wir nochmal.
Seit wann gibt es keine PowerPC Max mehr?
Das ist noch gar nicht so lange her.
Ende 2006 oder Anfang 2007 irgendwann, oder?
Man vergisst das schnell, ne?
Also Anfang 2006 kam der erste Intel raus. Wie MacBooks waren? MacBook Pros, doch. Das war Anfang 2006. Da hab ich mir den gekauft im März, weiß ich ganz genau.
Warte mal, ich glaube, ich hatte schon die 3 Jahre her. Ich hatte die 3. MacBook Pro-Generation gekauft und die hab ich jetzt vor 1,5 Jahren gekauft.
Also es ist jetzt, wenn Snow Leopard rauskommt, ist das MacBook Pro fast 4 Jahre alt. Das heißt, der Power PC Rechner, der letzte da rauskommt, ist dann 4 Jahre alt. Also das letzte Power PC Modell, was vorgestellt worden ist, das war glaube ich September 2005 und das ist dann sozusagen 4 Jahre her. Das ist schon völlig okay, dass sie nur Intel-only macht. Und ich finde das auch gut. Das heißt, dass sie sich total darauf konzentrieren können, ihre Optimierungen dazu zu delivern. Darüber haben wir auch schon geredet.
Weißt du aber, wie man Software gut testen kann, indem man das so multiplattformmäßig macht? Weil dann fallen gleich nochmal mehr Bugs raus.
Ja, aber sie haben multiplattformen. Sie müssen das Ganze auch für ARM rausbringen. Und da haben sie genug zu optimieren. Und da haben sie no lack of processor support. Sie sind aber ganz froh, dass sie von 3 auf 2 Prozessoren runterskalieren können. Was liest du? Liest du schon wieder dieses Internet?
Ich lese schon wieder dieses Internet. Und da steht drinnen, dass man mit den neuen Macbooks auch von einer SD-Karte booten kann. Und das ist natürlich eine lustige Sache, sich so eine 16 GB SSD zu holen.
Ach, 16, 64.
Und dann? Und dann von dem Ding zu booten. Und dann hast du die Festung.
Konnte man von dem USB-Stick nicht booten?
Aber ein USB-Stick steckt so draußen dran. Genau, das gleiche Argument, was du über dein Modem erzählt hast. Und dann? Dann bootest du davon, hast einen kleinen Rechner, fährt die Festplatte im Idealfall nicht mehr hoch. Und das könnte auch mal von der Geschwindigkeit her ganz spannend sein.
Aber wie viel Gebirg kriegt man da drauf? 32, 64?
Da geht schon richtig was drauf.
Und ich hab neulich mal einen Podcast geschnitten, und da war lustigerweise, also im Raw-Format, da kann man die Festplatte rausnehmen. Naja, ich will manchmal nicht zu weit gehen, aber...
Naja, aber ist bestimmt nicht schnell.
Ne, aber kommt doch auf die SD-Karten an. Es gibt auch schnellere. Aber jetzt nicht so wirklich schnell, das ist schon richtig.
Aber es ist cool, um mal ein anderes OS auszuprobieren und so. Das stimmt, dafür ist es geil.
Also als Diskettenersatz ist der SD-Kart schon ganz okay.
Ja, es ist gebongt. So, was haben sie denn noch gezeigt? Dann haben sie hier so PDF Text Selection. Nifty. War echt ein Problem.
Ja, ist ein kleines, schönes Detail.
Das ist schön. Also man kann jetzt sozusagen in Spalten selektieren. Und das ist insofern, was sagten sie? Sie hätten AI angewendet. Künstliche Intelligenz. Das gehört schon dazu, weil PDF gibt das nämlich nicht her. Also diese Spalteninformation steht da nicht wirklich drin.
Das geht wirklich zeichenweise, ne? Das ist eine Zeilenweise. Oder je nachdem, wie du es formatierst, auch Zeichenweise.
Ja klar, wäre möglich, aber in üblicher Weise hast du halt immer so Line by Line. Aber du hast eben nicht diesen Kontext, hier ist eine Spalte. Also von Zeile zu Zeile steht das sozusagen im PDF als Einzelinformation drin. Das ist schon ganz nett. Und dass sie da auch nochmal Rendering-Speed-Fortschritte haben, sie hatten ja bei Preview gesagt, irgendwie hier JPEG geht irgendwie doppelt so schnell und tra la la. Und PDF ist irgendwie auch fixer geworden durch die eine und die andere Maßnahme mit 64-Bit. Das ist schon wünschenswert. Gerade wenn ich so daran denke, so komplexe PDFs zu öffnen, das kann schon dauern.
Wir haben ja auch nochmal erklärt, dass 64-Bit nicht nur für mehr Speicher da ist, also ab 4 GB, sondern halt, dass es auch mehr Register hat und so weiter. Und weil es halt eigentlich ein Architektur-Change ist, auch demnächst, habe ich ja schon tausendmal erzählt, aber die Parameter über die Register irgendwie an die Funktion weitergegeben werden und nicht mehr über den Stack, was halt schneller ist.
Was ich nochmal gelesen habe, hoffe ich kriege es jetzt halbwegs zusammen. Das ist eine ganz spannende Sache. Bisher hatte das Betriebssystem und jedes Programm seinen eigenen 32-Bit-Adressraum, um den möglichst komplett nutzen zu können. Ach nee, Betriebssystem und Programme hatten jeweils einen eigenen 32-Bit-Adressraum. Das führte dazu, dass das eigene Programm relativ viel RAM hat. Das führte aber auch dazu, dass diese ganzen Optimierungen... Das hast du mal zu Ende erzählt. Wenn ein Programm seinen eigenen Code ausgeführt hat und dann ein System-Call gemacht hat, musste der Adressraum geswitcht werden, was erstmal ein bisschen Zeit kostet. Und zweitens mussten dann diese ganzen Optimierungen, dass der Prozessor schon mal vorplant, was muss ich als nächstes machen, und das schon mal mitberechnet und diese ganzen Caches, die werden bei jedem Adressraumwechsel geleert. Und das kostet natürlich ein bisschen Geschwindigkeit. Microsoft umgeht dieses Problem bei der 32-Bit-Version von Windows, indem sie einfach Betriebssystemen und jedes Programm in einen 32-Bit-Adressraum mappen.
Deswegen haben die auch nur 2 Gigabyte pro Programm, richtig?
Genau, da hat der einzelne Prozess dann weniger RAM, den er nutzen kann. Aber er holt ein bisschen mehr Geschwindigkeit aus dem Prozessor raus. Das Problem erledigt sich komplett mit dem 64-Bit, weil da wird es einfach in einem gigantischen 64-Bit-Adressraum gemapt. Und dadurch kann man den Prozessor viel besser ausnutzen.
Okay.
Also 64-Bit ist definitiv ein Schritt nach vorne.
Naja, aber ich mein, es ist ganz klar. Es nutzt, gerade bei Apple ist das Schöne, also mit Mac OS X, dass erst jetzt die ganzen Fähigkeiten von den aktuellen Intel-Prozessoren auch genutzt werden können, wenn tatsächlich alles...
Also, dass sie jetzt sozusagen voll draufsetzen können, die latest features zu supporten und die ganzen anderen Crafts nicht mit schlippen müssen, gar keine Frage.
Genau.
So, weiter geht's in der Keynote. Dann kam Safari 4.
Ja, Leute, einen entscheidenden Change gemacht. Also, ihr habt ja natürlich während der Sendung gehört, ihr klickt ja schon in Safari 4 und habt ja alle runtergeladen, richtig? Ja. Und der entscheidende Change ist, vorher hatten wir ja nur so diesen kleinen Drehkreisel da in der Adressbar, den man irgendwie gar nicht sehen konnte. Man wusste gar nicht, so wird jetzt schon geladen. Hab ich schon gedrückt, weil ich brauchte immer ein bisschen Feedback. Deswegen fand ich den blauen Balken im Hintergrund in der Adressbar viel cooler. Aber jetzt haben sie es gewechselt, jetzt kommt da so ein dicker Block rechts, wo steht, dass er lädt. Und der geht dann auch, wird ein bisschen, also der ist dickblau. Und wenn die Seite dann da ist, dann wird es ein bisschen grauer. Also man hat jetzt ein bisschen mehr Feedback. Jetzt finde ich es besser.
Das ist überhaupt das erste Mal, dass ich einen zweistufigen Progress Bar sehe. Das erste, wenn ich es richtig interpretiere, ist, wenn ich die HTML-Seite lade, dann ist das Ding so lange dunkelgrau.
Bis er anfängt, was anzuzeigen.
Ja, also wenn ich es richtig sehe, ist es bis er die HTML-Seite als solche geladen hat. Und der Rest ist dann sozusagen alle Verweise, also alle Bilder. Oder? Stimmt man Eindruck?
Ich hatte immer so die Ane, dass es von dunkelgrau nach hellgrau wechselt, wenn er anfängt, das anzuzeigen.
Und das finde ich noch cooler. Das gibt einem auch irgendwie diesen Unterschied, mit irgendwie löst nicht auf und kommt überhaupt erst gar nicht zur Potte. Und die Seite mit ihren ganzen Ressourcen ist schwer zu laden. Das kann man jetzt ganz gut unterscheiden.
Aber wollen wir mal den wesentlichen Unterschied so better sagen? Die Tabs sind wieder da, wo sie vorher waren.
Das war wohl ein Loser-Konzept, ne?
Ja, fand ich aber auch nicht so toll da oben. Es war so weit weg. Also so eine Seite war unten und dann kam eine andere Information und dann kam welche Seite ich hab oben drüber. Also es war so...
Das ist ja aber auch eigentlich logisch.
Nee.
Doch. Total.
Logisch ist es schon, weil die URL gehört ja sozusagen...
Ins Fenster?
Da drüber.
Ja, aber die Adresse ist ja aber dann trotzdem wieder für alle gleich. Das ist so mittendrin, das passt irgendwie nicht.
Auf jeden Fall scheint es nicht so richtig... Es hat nicht so richtig Freunde gefunden.
Ich find's jetzt wieder besser jetzt sowieso. Also...
Ich leider auch noch nicht darunter. Ich fand's auch... Der Klatter, den das oben im Menü erzeugt hat, der war wohl auch irgendwie zu hart. Es war einfach alles zu durcheinander und wo man anfassen und wo man verschieben kann und mit was für Elementen und dieses komische Riffel-Teil, was sonst eigentlich immer ein Resizer ist, ist da dann ein Mover. Also das passt irgendwie. Es hat irgendwie alles nicht gepasst. Ich denke, das müssen Sie nochmal neu angehen und damit ist glaube ich auch diese Vision von so einem Multidocument-Interface, also so Taps im Document-Interface von Programmen ist irgendwie erstmal auf Eis gelegt, würde ich mal sagen.
Ansonsten gab's noch die Information, das halt jetzt, Plugins, also er meint halt besonders Flash, angeblich ist Flash der Hauptgrund, warum Programme auf Mac irgendwie abstürzen, also Safari halt.
Ob das mal so stimmt?
Unter Garantie. Also ja, das ist auch das, was zum Beispiel der...
Aber seitdem alle Klick-to-Flash benutzen, kann doch gar kein Flash mehr abstürzen.
Das kann schon helfen, aber ich bin mir deshalb so sicher, dass Sie da richtig liegen mit dieser Aussage, weil das auch der Brent Simmons von NetNews war ja, der meint das auch. Also das NetNews war ja, dass die allermeisten Crashs sind WebKit-Crashs und davon sind die allermeisten einfach Flash.
Und auch Google geht ja dazu über, mit Chrome haben die ja auch... Ja, also das ist ja direkt in deren Demo...
Plugins auch noch in einem eigenen Prozess.
Plugins laufen in einem eigenen Prozess, damit man mal sehen kann, wo die ganze Prozessorleistung hingeht. Das kann man jetzt endlich mal sehen. Und Flash neigt ja dazu extrem viel.
Ich hoffe, dass man das jetzt auch im Safari sehen kann.
Das wird, naja, das wird man in Zukunft dann, naja, jetzt noch nicht, aber mit Sloan Labboard dann. No Labboard.
Ich bin schon mal gespannt, wenn es dann überhaupt noch Flash gibt. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt vorbei mit Flash.
Naja, nee, so schnell.
Flash auf Desktop wird das noch eine, hat das noch eine schöne Zeit vor sich.
Jaja. Windows auch.
Ist da zwei.
So.
Schönes Icon.
Das ist schwul.
Metrosexuell. Das Icon.
Ein Kardinal. Keine Ahnung.
Kenn mich nicht aus.
Die dänische Farbenlehre.
Ja, das heißt ja nicht umsonst schwul rosa. Das kommt ja irgendwo her.
Aber wir wissen alle, was wir uns davon versprechen. Ich fand's mal wieder sehr schwammig und ich hab mich gewundert, dass sie nicht mehr da gezeigt haben. Also diese Demo, na ja, der Quicktime-Player, da heiden jetzt automatisch der Titel. Also ging's noch, könnte nicht mal was zeigen, was interessant ist. Wo ist die Demo, dass sie jetzt 10 Jahre nach BOS mal dasselbe machen können mit BOS. Nämlich irgendwie 10 Filme gleichzeitig laufen lassen, irgendwie in einem Programm.
Das ging damals auch schon.
Du weißt doch, wie es ist mit Quicktime. Also weder programmieren die Leute nicht ordentlich dafür, bauen es nicht richtig ein. Sogar ihr blödes iTunes ist langsam.
Ist auch Carbon deswegen.
Ja, aber du machst da irgendwie start und dann dauert es 5 Sekunden, bis der Film anfängt und irgendwie auch es abbrechen und dann ruckelt es. Dann schließt du dein iPod an und dann ruckelt es. Und es ruckelt und ruckelt und ruckelt. Du tust irgendetwas in diesem Programm und es ruckelt. Es ist wirklich nicht fein. Und jetzt hoffe ich einfach, dass durch Quicktime X sich das ändert. Das wird abzuwarten sein. So, und jetzt habe ich nämlich noch, und das bezieht sich dann auch später aufs iPhone. Sie haben ja dann noch mal hingewiesen und das haben sie auch schon mit dem iPhone US 3.0 gemacht. Ja, dass sie ja jetzt mit Quicktime X auch HTTP-Streaming drin haben.
Das würde mich auch mal interessieren. Da hätten wir mal nachschlagen können.
Also was ist das für ein Standard, von dem da die Rede ist? Also Streaming im Sinne von, wir hatten ja schon mal so ein kleines Streitgespräch, aber Streaming im Sinne von wirklich, ich kann dem Server sagen, ich möchte jetzt gerne in der Mitte anfangen. Und wenn ich da rumscrubbe in meinem Client, dass er jederzeit sagen kann, jetzt will ich aber das, das sozusagen über HTTP.
Das ist diese Ranges oder was?
Laut Wikipedia ist HTTP-Streaming nichts weiter als als du legst die Datei auf den Server an der HTTP und ab und sie wird ausgeliefert.
Ja, aber du musst ja die Medien auf Basis von Zeit adressieren und nicht auf Basis von Bytes. Und du weißt ja nicht vorher, bei welchem Bytes.
Dafür kann er ja am Anfang erstmal eine Liste runterladen, wo die Stellen mit der Zeit sind und dann kann er mit seinen Ranges dahinspringen. Die haben sozusagen dann einen Header, die Dateien.
Streaming Header.
Das ist ja das auch, was die machen. Wenn die einen Movie, dann kann man den ja hinten und dann werden halt diese Informationen irgendwo an den Anfang des Movies gelegt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es stimmt, das ist jetzt ein bisschen Spekulation, aber so könnte es sein.
Da kann man vielleicht mal einfach...
So wie bei Avi ist das ja auch, da sind ja die Header auch. Sonst waren die ganz schlau am Ende der Datei, glaube ich.
Ja, aber was soll denn da alles drinstehen? Du kannst doch, wenn da so zwei Stunden Film ist, nicht für jeden Frame im Header reinschreiben, wo der ist.
Nein, nicht für jeden Frame, aber so auf die Sekunde.
Du kannst ja den Film in 20 Teile... Also, wenn man ganz doll spekuliert, dann könnte man den Film in 20 Teile aufteilen. Der springt dann hin und kann da dann ja noch mal genauere, wieder was nachladen, wo jetzt die nächsten feineren Abteilungen sind. Aber so richtig glauben, tue ich das nicht.
Besonders effizient, schnell klingt das.
Na ja, aber du kannst es leicht irgendwo, du schmeißt einfach eine Datei irgendwo hin und sie ist da und du kannst das auch per Amazon SS9 oder SS3 ausliefern ohne eine eigene Infrastruktur zu brauchen. Und ich nehme an, das wird so ein bisschen, weil bei Flash ist es ja mittlerweile üblich, bei den üblichen Playern, YouTube und Konsorten, dass man jederzeit zu einer Stelle auch klicken kann, die noch gar nicht geladen ist. Das war ja früher so, muss man immer bis zum Ende...
Ja, aber dann weiß der Server, wo das ist. Also ich hab das ja bei ChaosradioCC CDE auch eingebaut, dieses mit, ich hab da so ein Light-HTTPD und da kannst du halt auch in diesem Flash-Teil klicken mit, ich will das jetzt in der Mitte gucken, aber dann ist das so konfiguriert, dass der Flash-Client dem Server sagt, gib mir dieses Video an Sekunde sowieso und der rechnet lokal dieses Fragezeichen-Sekunde-Position um in die tatsächliche Stelle in der Datei. Das heißt, der Server wertet lokal die Datei aus. Also der weiß, dass es sich um eine MP4-Datei handelt und er weiß sie zu lesen und es ist der Server, der bestimmt, an welcher Stelle er jetzt ausliefert.
Und warum erlässt man sowas nicht dem Client?
Weil der Client die Datei nicht hat.
Der kann noch die ersten paar bytes von der Datei haben.
Ja, aber Frames, du weißt doch nicht, wo die Frames sind.
Man muss ja auch nicht auf die Sekunde genau reichen.
Auf die Sekunde genau heißt auf den Frame genau, weil das ist das, was auf die Sekunde genau heißt, dass du den richtigen Frame hast.
Außerdem kann man doch grob vorhersagen.
Also entweder machen wir das über so eine Keyframe-Liste, die sich irgendwie geladen wird oder...
Wenn du den falschen Frame kriegst, dann weißt du ja nicht, dass es der falsche ist.
Ja, spielt dir auch keine Rolle. Du willst ja auch nur, ich möchte ungefähr zur Mitte rein.
Ja, das ist halt die Frage.
Nee, du sagst nicht ungefähr zur Mitte, sondern du sagst, es gibt nicht ungefähr zur Mitte.
Das ist doch da, wo ich hinklicke auf so ein Scheiß-iPhone.
Ihr wisst es beide nicht?
Ja, aber da ist dann eine Zeit mit verbunden. Du weißt, da hast eine Stunde Film vor dir, dann klickst du in die Mitte und dann sagt der Kleint im Prinzip, ich möchte jetzt bei 30 Minuten 00.
Oder er kriegt vorher ein Inhaltsverzeichnis mitgeliefert und da steht drin, dass du bei 30 Sekunden ist.
Ja, aber dann müsste jeder einzelne Frame eine Byteszahl haben. Dann müsstest du für jeden einzelnen Frame in deiner Datei...
Oder eben du scheißt auf das Frame und machst es zum Beispiel alle Sekunde oder alle 5 Sekunden. Weil so genau...
Ja, aber das sind immer noch eine ganze Menge, bei zwei Stunden Video.
Bei zwei Stunden Video sind pro Sekunde, sind das insgesamt 7200 Informationen. Sagen wir mal, dass jede Information 8 Bytes groß ist. Dann ist man dabei saftigen... Super, jetzt müsste man noch mit dem Kopf rechnen können.
Also man könnte das...
Dann ist man dabei, ich sag mal, 30-40 Kilobyte für einen 2-Stunden Film. Das ist...
7200 Sekunden mal 30 Frames. Das sind 216.000.
Du willst es aufs Frame genau. Ich sage nicht aufs Frame genau. Ich sage, einer pro Sekunde reicht. 7200.
Sekundengenau kann er dann immer noch ein bisschen nachspielen. Dann lädt er die Sekunde und springt eine Sekunde weiter.
Genau.
Ein bisschen buffern muss er ja eh.
Und zur Not kann man ja übrigens auch so vorgehen, wahrscheinlich.
Aber du musst ja dann auch noch die B-Frames sozusagen zurückrechnen. Du musst ja auch an eine synchronisierbare Stelle springen.
Genau, das wird die Information sein. Er wird einfach nur sagen, an Sekunde so und so habe ich ein Keyframe und das bei so und so viel Bites. Du hast alle 25 Keyframes und so weit.
Nein, Keyframes können dynamisch sein.
Okay, also...
Aber du musst ja sowieso immer bei einem Keyframe anfangen.
Wir halten fest, wir haben keine Ahnung. Wir fragen uns, was jetzt wohl damit genau gemeint sein könnte. Also welcher Standard gemeint ist. Und das ist jetzt die Chance für die Besserwissenden und unseren Hörern in den Kommentaren uns zu belehren.
Aber auf jeden Fall, so Quicktime-HTTP-Streaming ist eigentlich ein total alter Hut. Also sie müssen da offensichtlich nochmal ein bisschen was nachgebessert haben.
So wie ich ihn halt verstanden habe, ist es schon so ein bisschen so wie, jetzt kann man HTTP so benutzen, wie man bisher nur RTP benutzen konnte. Das ist das, was ich da rausgehört habe.
Also ich gehe mal fest davon aus, dass es weiterhin so ist. Ich lege es irgendwo auf den Webserver und wir haben jetzt so ähnliches Streaming.
Ja gut, aber warum betonen sie das so, wenn sie das doch jetzt schon in Quicktime auch drin haben?
Weil bisher, also was bisher eben noch nicht geht, ist...
Oder haben die es nicht?
Jetzt kommt der schon wieder an.
Was bisher eben nicht geht, ist, also bisher fängst du immer am Anfang an. Und du kannst bei einem Quicktime-Film, kannst du nicht...
Kann ich jetzt schon Http-Streaming machen mit Quicktime?
Ja.
Du gehst auf apple.com, gehst und dann so einen Werbespot anguckst, dann ist das ja Http-Streaming. Dann wird die Quicktime-Datei per Http ausgeliefert.
Ja, Apple macht das immer so, dass sie einen MOF runterladen.
Genau, dann wird ein MOF...
Ja, aber in dem MOF steht, hier bitte per RTSP zugreifen.
Nö, das ist in dem MOF...
Dann könnte man ja spulen, man könnte bei der Keynote nicht hin und her...
Bei der Keynote ist was anderes. Ich meine die Werbespots. Das ist Http-Streaming.
Ist das so? Nein, da sind wir wieder bei unserer Diskussion vom vorletzten Mal.
Das ist progressive Download. Ja, aber das nennen die Quicktime, Http-Streaming oder auch Fast Start. So war das bisher.
Fast Start heißt wahrscheinlich, die packen diese Keyframe-Information an den Anfang...
Sie haben das ganze Http-Streaming genannt, weil...
Die Hörer steigen uns jetzt aus. Zurecht.
Die sind schon alle weg.
Wir vertagen das, wir gehen in Klausur, wir lassen uns belehren und dann berichten wir. Wir sind verwirrt. So, man kann jetzt hochladen, haben wir korrekt vorhergesagt, beziehungsweise ausreichend Gerüchte wiedergegeben. Mobile Me hochladen, YouTube hochladen und so weiter.
Und dieses Trimming, was übrigens auf dem iPhone genauso funktioniert.
Genau, was nur ein neues User-Interface ist. Weil Trimming ging auch heute schon vorher.
Ja, aber es war total scheiße vorher.
Ich benutze das täglich. Man kann ja schön mit Cursor links, Cursor rechts, Frame-by-Frame genau die Stelle anwenden.
Ja, man muss genau diese Dinger erwischen, um dann den doch mal zu schieben, weil die so klein sind. Ist doch voll blöd.
Nee, du klickst den an und gehst dann irgendwie mit Maustast links, rechts und drückst einfach O und I. Dann hast du deine In- und Outpoints, machst du Copy, Paste. Wer soll das wissen? Das war schon immer so.
Ja, gut, weil du zufällig ein Manual von QuickTime von 1991 hattest, so wie wir in der letzten Sendung festgestellt haben. Hat aber nicht jeder.
Wahrscheinlich fehlt das auch in der Hilfe einfach.
In und Out.
Ja, was soll ich denn so was wissen?
Na, das steht im Menü.
Ah ja, noch nie benutzt.
Das steht doch hier im Menü, oder nicht?
Ist doch egal. I und O, jetzt weiß ich.
Oder steht das nicht im Menü?
So spät, jetzt gibt es ja demnächst Trimming.
Ich guck mal.
Warum lernt man erst Sachen, wenn es sie nicht mehr gibt?
Stimmt, das steht nicht im Menü. Wieso steht das nicht im Menü? Es wurde wirklich Zeit, dass sich da was ändert.
Ah, aber es steht da eine Anleitung drinne.
Irgendwo steht das auf jeden Fall.
Inner Hilfe. Auswählen und abschweren als Teil seines Films.
Was lernen wir wieder? Man sollte doch öfter mal die Doku lesen.
Das hilft.
Mir ist bei der Gelegenheit mal wieder aufgefallen, was QuickTime eigentlich mittlerweile für ein mächtiges kleines Programm ist.
Der Player.
War der schon immer?
Ja, war er schon immer. Ja, mein ich ja. Ist mir bei der Gelegenheit mal wieder aufgefallen.
Ach so.
Darum fing der Satz so an. Und ich find irgendwie QuickTime mit diesem neuen Interface, das mag ich total gerne, weil das ist so, das ist so ein kleines, unauffälliges Programm. Das ist so wie Text-Edit für Filme und Audio-Daten. Man muss nicht iMovie jedes Mal starten oder sowas. Hätten sie auch draufschmeißen können. Sondern es ist ein Programm. Und ich benutze QuickTime Player mittlerweile fast täglich. Das ist echt irre. Sowohl zum Abspielen, als auch zum Aufnehmen von Medien.
Und Trimmen und so.
Und gut, dass das endlich mal wieder...
Ich trimme da auch meine Podcasts.
Ich trimme mir was.
Ich trimme mir was. Und es gibt keinen QuickTime Pro mehr.
Oh, definitiv?
Danke, ist das endlich vorbei.
Oder es ist immer noch Spekulation.
Nein, haben sie...
Haben sie es gesagt in der Keynote?
Wir haben es in der Keynote... Haben sie es in der Keynote gesagt?
Ich kann mir nicht erinnern, dass sie es gesagt haben. Wie auch immer. Dann sind sie auf jeden Fall weiter marschiert auf 64. Bitte, das sollten wir jetzt auch machen. Haben wir ja schon fast durchdiskutiert. Es wird alles schneller, es wird alles sicherer. Und dann haben sie irgendwie noch mal ihr Grand Central präsentiert. Na ja. Und nichts dazu gesagt.
Nichts dazu gesagt, außer dass man jetzt viel mehr Threads hat und dann viel weniger Threads. Bei mir zum Beispiel.
Was ganz interessant ist, das ist nämlich so ein Konzept in diesem Ding. Du gibst sozusagen die Thread Creation ab an dieses Subsystem. Du sagst halt wirklich, hier sind Tasks, die sind zu parallelisieren.
Und wenn du fertig bist, mach die auch wieder weg.
Und das Ding genau legt für dich nach Bedarf Threads an, verteilt die Aufträge auf diese Threads in Abhängigkeit von wie viel Kurs und was weiß ich, was da noch alles Eingabeparameter für die Entscheidung sein mögen. Und in dem Moment, wo die Dinge abgearbeitet sind und keine Tätigkeiten mehr sind, werden sogar Threads wieder gelöscht, sodass insgesamt weniger Threads da sind, was halt das Scheduling befördert, weil eben nicht so durch so viele Threads durchgeklappert werden muss.
Das klingt mir so ein bisschen nach so einer Art Garbage Collection für...
Für CPU-Items, genau. Das könnte man so sagen.
Sie haben auch gesagt, dass alle Apis jetzt irgendwie Support für diesen Grand Central Dispatch haben. Was auch immer das genau bedeutet, da bin ich ja noch gespannt. Weil was ich mir schon immer überlegt habe, so als Programmierer, wenn man zum Beispiel sagt, du hast eine Million Objekte in so einem Array und du willst es sortieren. Sortieren gibt es ja so einen Call irgendwie. Und das ist eigentlich ein super Job für mehrere CPUs. Und eigentlich könnte man, könnten die ja jetzt schon auch ohne Grand Central Dispatch irgendwie einbauen, dass wenn die Sortierfunktion da aufgerufen wird, dass es irgendwie auf mehrere CPUs verteilt wird, ohne dass dein Programm irgendwas davon missen muss. Aber es ist irgendwie noch nicht so. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das sich vielleicht demnächst so ein bisschen ändert.
Schauen wir mal.
Bei meinem Programm ist es eh gebrockt, bis fertig sortiert ist. Und ob der dann eine oder zwei CPUs benutzt, kann dem Programm ja mal egal sein. Dann ist er schneller fertig.
Na du solltest doch schon mal einen Thread starten, oder?
Na warum soll ich denn das machen? Eigentlich will man dem Developer ja diese Arbeit abnehmen. Es soll ja möglichst viel automatisch verteilt werden.
Wenn du dein Code so programmierst, dass eine Zeile später das sortierte Ergebnis erwartet wird, dann hat das System wahrscheinlich keine andere Chance, als dein...
Wieso? Dann kann man trotzdem zwei CPUs benutzen.
Ja, okay, aber das müssen wir halt... Wir haben ja sicherlich das System auch geschrieben, um es selber zu nutzen. Es geht ja nicht darum, dass es nur für die Anwender ist, sondern Apple entwickelt ja die meisten Programme auch nach wie vor selber.
Naja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall haben sie halt in diesem Grand Central allerlei Abstraktionen mit irgendwie Cues und Blogs und Events und Pipapo und es erfordert schon noch eine gewisse, explizite Unterstützung, aber es ist halt so, dass es überhaupt erstmal ein Subsystem gibt, in das du diese Entscheidungen, wie viele Cores halt jetzt wirklich zu benutzen sind und wovon sie benutzt werden, einfach delegieren kannst. Und das ist sehr, sehr, sehr sinnvoll. Es bleibt abzuwarten, wie viele Programme davon wirklich nutzen, ziehen werden, also wie viele Programmierer das jetzt tatsächlich benutzen, aber es ist sicherlich der einfachere Weg hin zum Multithreading, als der wirklich alles von Hand zu machen.
Also wenn es sich bei mir lohnt, dann wird es sich vermutlich bei so ziemlich jedem Programm lohnen.
Es lohnt sich, ja. Also mir würde fast kein Programm einfallen, wo sich das nicht lohnt. Allein schon um so User Interface, Interaktionen von dem, was eben sonst noch so passiert, zu trennen. Ich habe ja schon vor langer, langer, langer Zeit mal so Multithreaded programmieren. Das ist schon eine kleine Herausforderung. Und man braucht wirklich auch guten Support vom Betriebssystem. Aber wenn man es erstmal so im Kopf hat und wenn man es erstmal drin hat und wenn es für einen selbstverständlich ist, Multithreaded zu programmieren, dann ist es irgendwie auch okay. Aber man hat schon eine Menge damit zu tun.
Ich hab das mal probiert, noch zu System 7 Zeiten, als es da diesen Thread Manager gab. Da hab ich das mal so ein bisschen. Ich glaube, ich hab es nicht geschafft, 1, 2 zu starten. Das war echt die Hölle.
Ich hab das unter OS 2.2.0 getan.
Also diesem IBM Betriebssystem.
Das war gut.
Also bei System 7 war das ganz furchtbar. Da gab es noch kein echtes Multitasking. Und da gab es dann dieses Threads, und das war dann irgendwie so reingehackt, und das war alles ganz schrecklich.
Kostet?
Nein, eins haben wir noch vergessen. Wichtigen Punkt. Na? Exchange.
Stimmt, hab ich mir nicht aufgeschrieben. Aber was gibt es da groß zu berichten?
Na ja, also Mail. Also dass Apple überall Exchange und Betriebssystem integriert hat. Ich kann iCall, kann Exchange. Was sehr cool ist, dass man es jetzt einfach und ohne irgendwelche Umwege mit seinem Google-Kalender synchronisieren kann auf diese Art und Weise. Ich kann endlich im Büro, wo ich auch manchmal arbeite, auf mein Adressbuch zugreifen, auf das Firmen-Einheitliche, und muss nicht immer dämlich nach den E-Mail-Adressen von den einzelnen Leuten fragen, nach den Telefonnummern. Es sah mir so aus, als ob man durchaus auch zumindest im Adressbuch mehrere Einträge anlegen könnte. Wie mehrere? Dass ich mehrere Exchange-Server habe. Weil im Mail kann man im Augenblick nur einen Exchange-Server anlegen. Und wenn man, so wie ich, freier als Freier bei mehreren arbeitet, hat man ein Problem. Und im Adressbuch sah es mir auch so aus, auch da auf dem iPhone, müssen wir mal gucken, wie es dann mit dem iPhone als 3.0 ist, ist es ja so, du kannst nur entweder das Adressbuch vom iPhone nehmen oder das Exchange-Adressbuch, aber beides geht nicht. Und das ging bei dem Adressbuch jetzt, was Apple da implementiert hat, definitiv auch. Also das haben sie erwähnt, da sind meine privaten Daten und dann kommt der Exchange selber dazu. Das sieht mir nach einer relativ runden Lösung aus.
Das wäre ja auch zu erwarten. Also man, das kann ja nicht...
Haben sie auch gesagt, so Apple-Style.
Und sie haben gesagt...
Also der Apple-Style und iCal, also ich meine, da ist schon echt einiges im Argen. Es gibt so Sachen, da ist es wirklich so scheiße unflexibel. Wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Termin per E-Mail reinkriege. Und dann sage ich, mach mir daraus jetzt einen Eintrag in iCal. Und zwar über dieses Datadetektor. Dann erzeugt er mir den. Und dann kann ich aber in iCal keine URL mehr eintragen nachträglich, weil das URL-Feld ist reserviert für den Link auf die Mail. Wo ich sonst, wenn ich mir manuell einen anlege, dann kann ich da irgendeine URL reinmachen, was weiß ich, womit halt dieser Event zu tun hat, die Adresse, wo die Einladung für die Party ist oder so. Und das geht dann einfach nicht. Dann sitze ich da vorne und denke, wieso geht das nicht?
Wobei, das wusste ich gar nicht, dass dein Link auf die Mail gesetzt wird. Das ist eigentlich gut.
Ja, klar, aber warum macht man das nicht separat? Stattdessen geht einem das Feld flöten, nicht? Oder ich kriege einen Termin jetzt von jemand anders, mit so, wir stimmen uns sozusagen ab, benutzen jetzt aber keinen Shared-Kalender, sondern kriege das halt so per Mail. Wir würden das ja auch manchmal machen. Da kann ich das nicht ändern. Da kann ich den Inhalt nicht ändern. Wenn ich dann erfahre, dass das eine halbe Stunde später ist, kann ich das nicht ändern.
Dann muss der andere den Termin nochmal rumschieben. Das ist wirklich albern, ja.
Geht's noch? Dann muss ich den immer löschen und selber anlegen. Tolle Automation. Ich finde, iCal ist schon noch ein bisschen so eher so ein Spielzeugkalender. Und warum sie sich auch nicht durchringen können, mal einen Wochenview zu machen, den ich auch Woche für Woche durchblitzen kann. Entschuldigung, ich hab's falsch angefangen. Was ich haben möchte ist, ich möchte keine römischen Kalender haben. Ich möchte nicht so denken wie die alten Römer, sondern ich möchte denken, wie es eben ist. Ich möchte von Woche zu Woche planen und ich möchte mal zwei oder drei Wochen anzeigen können gleichzeitig. Und ich möchte Woche für Woche voranschreiten und nicht nur in diesem Monatsview wirklich einen Überblick über mehrere Wochen haben. Sondern ich möchte immer die letzte Woche, die nächste Woche und die aktuelle Woche haben und dann möchte ich runter scrollen und möchte, dass Woche für Woche kommt und nicht so arbitriere Aufteilung, die gerade darauf basiert, wie viel der Römischen Kaiser es gerade gegeben hat. Wo leben wir denn? Das ist 2000 Jahre her. Und ich muss darunter leiden. Ja, ich finde das eine Frechheit.
Also Frechheit ist jetzt...
Doch, ich finde das eine Frechheit. Gregorianischer Kalender ist eine Frechheit. Ich meine, der ist einfach unlogisch, von vorne bis hinten. Zwölf Monate hat das Jahr, bla bla bla. Das ist Quatsch.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist nach 2000 Jahren auch relativ schwer rauszukriegen.
Ja, aber wozu? Man kann doch einfach wochenweise... Warum ist dieses Programm nicht in der Lage, einem die Kalenderwoche anzuzeigen?
Das stimmt, das ist echt total...
Immer noch nicht. Macht sich? Nein.
Ja, aber jetzt klickt er pro Woche.
Ja, aber es zeigt nicht die KW-Nummer an.
Du weißt einfach nicht, in welcher Woche du bist und das ist die einzig wirklich relevante Information, wenn du Business machst.
Ja, wobei es gibt auch ungefähr 48.000 Arten, die Kalenderwoche zu zählen.
Ja, dann muss...
In Deutschland gibt es nur eine. Nein, es gibt einen deutschen Standard dafür.
Ja.
DIN-Norm. Der ist aber bestimmt eine DIN-Norm. Und das ist aber in anderen Ländern dann nicht zwangsläufig auch so.
Dann sollen sie das einbauen und so, nur weil die Amerikaner wie immer noch nicht das metrische System begriffen haben und nicht wissen, dass es auch andere Länder gibt.
Ja, aber dieses MkW 38, das ist so was, das...
Ja, aber das ist doch mal eine Information. Dann kannst du sagen, in drei Wochen, und du bist in MkW 42 und dann weißt du, dass du halt in MkW 45 irgendwie jetzt bist. Und nicht irgendwie, was haben wir denn jetzt hier? Und dann August und wie viele Tage hat denn der? Das ist doch alles geblockt.
Also dieses MkW, das ist mir ehrlich, das ist mir jetzt viel zu beamtenhaft.
Ich will einfach Kalender Pro haben. Was ordentliches.
10.7.
Ja, ja, aber wir haben jetzt Exchange Support.
Und nicht so ein Programm, was in jedem Betriebssystem release, ein User-Interface ändert und es wird immer schlechter. Mal ehrlich, diese komischen fliegenden Sprechblasen, die sie da jetzt eingebaut haben, sind im Vergleich zu dem Sidebar, den sie noch in Tiger hatten, ein echter Rückschritt. Du findest sie wirklich besser? Ich finde die furchtbar. Man kann sich die Daten eines Events nicht gleichzeitig angucken, während du da rum, sondern du musst die ganze Zeit dieses komische Kartenteil dann auf dein Bildschirm verschieben. Und wenn du es verschiebst, dann zeigt diese Spitze von diesem Teil nicht mehr dahin, worauf es sich bezieht. Ich meine, was ist denn das für ein User-Interface?
Abonnier dir doch einfach so einen externen Kalender, der dir mal die Kalenderwoche anzeigt.
Hab ich. Naja, aber ich hab nicht in iCal, sondern dann muss ich dann immer in mein Menübar gehen, um zu gucken, was die aktuelle Kalenderwoche ist.
Nee, kann man nicht so einen Kalender, wo schon einer so einen Kalender macht, wo er immer am Montag irgendwie hinschreibt, welche Kalenderwoche gerade ist.
Ja, guck mal, wenn ich am Ende eines Monats bin, dann kann ich nur... Guck mal, was haben wir jetzt? Okay, jetzt sind wir gerade mitten drin.
Aber das ist wirklich wichtig.
Es ist der 29. So, dann will ich wissen, was nächste Woche ist. Die einzige Möglichkeit ist, dann in den nächsten Monat zu gehen, dann sehe ich aber nicht mehr den aktuellen Tag. Wieso kann ich mir nicht ein View machen, wo ich immer die letzten zwei Wochen und die nächsten zwei Wochen sehe und der aktuelle Tag, die aktuelle Woche ist einfach immer in der Mitte? Das kann doch nicht so schwer sein. Mann, wirklich. Ich halt jetzt Maul. Ich sag nichts mehr zu Kalender.
Hol mal, pack mal die Karte zur Seite und hol mal die nächste Karte.
Wir können über Exchange reden.
Ich finde es gut, dass es das brauche.
Nein, ich finde es auch super, dass es eingebaut wird. Das wurde auch Zeit. Das nimmt natürlich der Plattform einen großen Malus in der Business-Welt.
Es gibt sogar noch einen Vorteil. Ich meine, sie haben es auch erwähnt. Wenn du das bei Microsoft haben willst, das Gleiche musst du das Windows-Betriebssystem kaufen und dann noch den ganzen Office-Scheiß oben drauf. Und hier kaufst du ein Betriebssystem und hast den ganzen Mist.
Ja, aber nicht den ganzen Mist, aber schon so ein bisschen zum Gucken reicht es.
Da gibt es aber bestimmt noch eine ganze Tonne von Features in Outlook, die sie halt jetzt mit ihrem Kinder-IQL nicht abbilden.
Natürlich, natürlich, aber wobei sie haben ja sogar diese Raumplanung und sowas alles drin, haben sie ja ganz stolz gezeigt. Und sie wollen ja weiter in die Richtung gehen.
Das sah aber auch echt shady aus. Mal ehrlich, da mit irgendwie ja in diesem Event-Ding. Dann tauchen da mal so ein bisschen die Räume auf. Aber so richtig, dass du mal so siehst, welche Räume gibt es denn eigentlich und solche Views. Also da fehlt mir links einfach so die Icon-Leiste. Weißt du, so wie bei iTunes, wo ich sage, alle Termine, alle, was weiß ich, alle Räume, alle Ressourcen. Alle, alles.
Alle, alles.
Da fehlt einfach noch...
Ja, aber das ist, egal.
Icon ist so das Eye-Foto für Termine. Und was ich haben will, ist Aperture für Termine. Zahlen ich auch gerne nochmal 29 Dollar extra.
Und 29 Dollar kostet der ganze Spaß. Das finde ich ja.
Aber nur für Leopard-Use.
Ja, das Leopard-Upgrade. Also wenn du schon Leo hast, dann kostet es nur 99,20 Dollar.
Muss ich da meine Rechner mitnehmen? Wie läuft das?
Ja genau, wie läuft das? Ach echt?
Nur mit als Upgrade?
Ja, da wirst du irgendeinen Kaufbeleg vorweisen oder so.
Und wenn man es noch nicht hat, muss man vollen Preis zahlen.
Ja, ist doch in Ordnung.
Kaufbeleg vorweisen? Ob ich noch irgendwo die Kaufbeleg für meinen Leopard-TVD rumfile?
Und wenn man es beim Rechner dabei hätte, zählt das?
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht muss es...
Hatte ich nicht.
Ich hatte es dabei.
Ich habe hier aber noch 10,4 hier.
Das weiß ich gar nicht, ob das dann auch zählt, aber ich vermute mal ja.
Ich habe sogar einen Leopard gekauft.
Na ja, gut, das war es zum Mac.
Jetzt können wir endlich über das iPhone reden. Ich freue mich jetzt total. Ihr meintet, es wäre nicht Snowstar? Ja, es war wirklich nicht Snowstar.
Doch, Snowblab, ich glaube, diese ganzen unten drunter Features, also auch mit dem Finder, ich glaube, das rockt. Da sind so lauter kleine Sachen, die du einfach mal schicken kannst. Zum Beispiel, Jack zeigt an, was das Problem ist. Das sind so Sachen, wo du irgendwie minutenlang das scheiß Programm suchst. Und das macht dein Leben einfach mal einfacher. Dieses Exposé sah auch echt aus, als wenn es ab und zu mal das Leben einfacher machen würde.
Safari mit den einzelnen Prozessen ist großartig.
Genau.
Und dann hat man so das Gefühl, wow, sie schaffen eine solide Foundation für weitere Expansionen, die so geil sein werden, dass wir noch nicht mal verfolgen können.
Und wenn das Grand Central dafür sorgt, dass alles plötzlich flutscht, weil eigentlich hat man ja noch genug CPU, dann finde ich das auch gut. Also deine Kiste hier zum Beispiel, die ist doch immer am Lüften, obwohl sie gar nicht mal voll CPU-Ausschlag hat, oder?
Richtig.
Und die ist auch schon träge, obwohl sie die CPUs noch gar nicht voll am Ausschlag sind.
Richtig?
Ja.
Ja und ich denke mal, mit Grand Central könnte das eventuell besser werden.
Ich habe Hoffnung für die Performance dieses Systems.
Weil, dass mein Rechner ruckelt, finde ich nicht so schlimm, aber wenn er ruckelt, dann will ich aber auch beide CPUs am Anschlag sehen und sozusagen das Gefühl haben, okay, er kann wirklich nicht mehr, weil er muss jetzt so viel machen, dann ruckelt das. Aber wenn die irgendwie beide nur so auf der Hälfte sind und das ruckelt, dann sehe ich das nicht einmal. Eigentlich könnte er noch ein bisschen mehr irgendwie da powern.
Das stimmt. Aber das will ich auch erstmal sehen. Das will ich wirklich erstmal sehen. Da habe ich Hoffnung und so, aber ich bin skeptisch. Aber ich finde es gut, sie haben noch Zeit bis September. Sie wollten sozusagen vor Vista rauskommen. Wir wollen rechtzeitig rauskommen, damit das noch so in den Weihnachtsverkauf rausschaut. Also, dass sie noch genug Zeit haben, um das alles fertig zu machen.
Dass die Developer schon ein Nearly-Final-Build kriegen.
Ja, aber ich denke mal, dass auch wenn die Developer sich dann erstmal jetzt an den Nearly-Final-Build ranmachen, dass er eins ist.
Die machen sich ja die ganze Zeit schon an die Builds ran.
Ja.
Gibt es bei Pirate Bayman?
Insofern, was nicht war, kein neues User-Interface, was so viel gerumort wurde.
Ach so, weil der Kokua jetzt, ach so, ja auch mit der Optik und so, dass das Aqua verschwindet. Ja, war nicht.
Nichts.
Ja, schade eigentlich, oder?
Also ich hätte jetzt mal was anderes als Aqua nicht so schlimm gefunden. Aber ich habe auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, das kommt ja mit US-11.
10.7.
Gibt es noch einen 10.7?
Bestimmt. Ja. Solange sie Mac OS X, Mac OS X nennen, denke ich mal, werden sie dann diese noch zur Verfügung stehenden Incremental-Zahlen noch. Hat ja bisher gut funktioniert. Also irgendwie ist es halt immer 10. Und OS 11, das dauert glaube ich noch ein bisschen.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es jetzt einfach das...
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie bis 10.9 durchziehen.
Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sie bis 10.10 oder 10.11 sogar gehen. Also ich meine, OS 10 ist ja mittlerweile auch der eingetragene Markenname.
Ich warte noch mit dem Upgrade bis 10.42.
Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass zumindest so ein Optical Change, also dass das Aqua verschwindet, dass das irgendwie mit OS 11 kommt oder 10... Keine Ahnung, wie die das dann umbenennen. Vielleicht lernen sie das auch OS X 2.0 oder weiß nicht, wie sie das machen. Ich sehe, die werden sich da schon was einfallen lassen.
Wir haben jetzt 100 Minuten diskutiert und wir waren noch nicht mal beim iPhone.
Aber eins weiß ich noch kurz anders.
Zum iPhone gibt es ja auch nicht so viel zu sagen.
Man merkt ja auch, bei Windows war es ja mal DOS, dann war es Windows 95. Das war damals noch relativ cool, als es rauskam. Endlich mal irgendwie bunt und schick und toll. Also besser als dieses 3L, was wir das hatten. Und weil es so cool war, haben wir uns gedacht, alles klar, das ist ja so cool, dann nennen wir es das nächste auch so, nämlich Windows 98. Und ab da ging es ja, das ging auch noch, dann kam ja wohl Windows 2000, aber seitdem haben die doch jedes Mal den Namen gechanged, oder? Weil es war einfach nur noch doof. Und immer wenn was doof ist, was macht man? Man wechselt den Markenname, weil der Markenname scheiße ist. Also dann heißt es irgendwie ME, dann heißt es Millennium, oder? Dann heißt es XP, dann heißt es irgendwie Vista, und Vista war auch blöde. Also heißt es jetzt wieder Windows 7. Also andauernd wechseln die Namen. Was macht... Apple ist das gleich von Anfang an Erfolg. 10.1, 10.2, 10.13, 14.5.
Man kann auch sagen, es heißt immer Windows.
Naja, nee, es ist schon immer... Wenn es Vista richtig cool gewesen wäre, hätten es jetzt Vista Pro oder wie auch immer genannt, aber nicht irgendwie Windows 7.
Also das mit dem 7, ja klar, das haben sie gemacht.
Aber hätte das bei Apple mit den Katzen nicht hingehauen, dann hätten sie es mit den Katzen auch sein lassen.
Klar.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die eigentliche Ressource. Das will ich ja damit sagen. Aber wahrscheinlich gehen am Ende auch die Katzen aus. Ich meine, was soll denn jetzt noch kommen?
Keine Ahnung.
Gepard?
Säbelzahntiger.
Mammut.
Ist bestimmt auch schon einiges ausgestochen.
Mein Mac OS X Lolcat.
Hab ich aus dem Chat geklaut.
Hey, I heard you like the speed, so I put some speed in your performance. Ja, das wär doch mal was.
I have stolen some resources from you.
I crashed your hard drive. Ich kann es mir sehr schön vorstellen.
So eine traurige Katze.
Pekko OS 10.7 LOL-Cat.
iPhone.
US oder?
Na ja, wir gehen in der Reihenfolge.
Dann kamen sie erstmal mit dem Ganner schlechthin.
Ja.
Also eigentlich haben sie erstmal iPhone OS 3.0 nochmal komplett wiederholt, was sie schon bei diesem letzten Meeting gemacht haben.
Da gibt es übrigens irgendwo ein Interview mit dem AT&T und so einen AT&T Manager. Und den haben sie auch gefragt, wie es dann mit dem MMS aussieht. Und dass es halt noch ein bisschen dauert, weil AT&T muss da was umstellen und so weiter. Und der hat dann hinten rangezogen, dass der AT&T und Apple, dass sie ja eigentlich versucht haben, MMS irgendwie zu verhindern, weil sie es ja eigentlich blöde finden, aber sind halt nicht drum rum gekommen.
Ja, weil es ganz interessant ist. Ja.
Weil ja alle eigentlich sagen, die so ein bisschen mehr sich mit Computern und Online beschäftigen, dass sie sagen, MMS ist doch voll der Scheiß, viel zu teuer, braucht keiner, kann man über E-Mail...
Aber AT&T findet MMS total toll. Ich glaube nicht, dass AT&T... AT&T findet MMS...
Ja, warum brauchen die denn so ewig? In Europa gibt es das doch schon seit Jahrzehnten.
Es gibt, ich glaube, es gibt es auch bei AT&T schon seit ewig.
Nee, nee, der meinte, sie müssen irgendeine Softwareumstellung machen, oder was auch immer, und deswegen kommt es erst irgendwie...
Sie müssen sich überhaupt erst mal eine MMS Infrastruktur zulegen mit diesem Ganzen.
Natürlich.
AT&T hat doch schon eine MMS Infrastruktur.
Wo denn? Was?
Sie bieten MMS an in den USA, ist für mehr neu. Ich. Wer denn? Wer macht denn das?
Die sagen, wir haben ZFS vergessen in OSTem.
Ja, hat Apple auch.
Das stimmt.
Apple auch, Punkt. Die haben das vergessen. Anders können wir uns das nicht erklären.
Stimmt, das müssen wir noch erwähnen. Was hast du rausgefunden? Auf der amerikanischen Webseite ist keine Erwähnung mehr.
Bei OSTem Server haben wir die Seiten neu gestaltet. Bei Klein war es ja noch nie drin. Bei OSTem Server war es drin. Jetzt haben sie die Seiten neu gestaltet. Da ist es bei OSTem Server auch nicht mehr drin. Auf der amerikanischen Seite, aber mir wurde gezwitschert, dass es in der deutschen und in der englischen, also von Großbritannien, dass es dort auf den OSTem Server Seiten noch erwähnt wird. Aber ich gehe mal so ein bisschen davon aus, dass die deutschen und die britischen Seiten, dass die ja nur Copy und Paste von der amerikanischen sind und dass die sich wahrscheinlich da vereditiert haben und dass der amerikanische Typ die Seite schon komplett neu gemacht hat, weil der macht ja sozusagen das Original. Und deswegen, ich würde mal behaupten, der Fehler ist wirklich auf der deutschen Seite. Also ich denke mal, es gibt keinen ZFS mehr. Was mich ein bisschen wundert, ehrlich gesagt. Weil es jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal verschieben. Und so gesehen, it's that Jim.
Ich befürchte.
Warum? Weil Oracle Sun gekauft hat?
Nee, das war ja schon so ein bisschen vorher in einem US-10-Bild nicht drin. Ich weiß nicht, was da genau los ist. Vielleicht ist es denen doch zu unstable oder zu heftig oder keine Ahnung. Also ist mir ein bisschen unklar.
Aber das ist ja, guck mal, das ist doch sogar die englische Seite. Die haben es doch nicht mal übersetzt. Was?
Guck mal bei Textbacks, da klick mal drauf. Du bist jetzt auf der britischen Seite, oder wo?
Nee, ich bin auf der deutschen.
Also jetzt mal runter scrollt.
Hier taucht hier noch ZFS auf.
Genau, und wenn du das gleiche jetzt auf der amerikanischen Seite machst, dann steht da kein ZFS mehr.
Aber ist ja lustig, die ist ja sogar die englische Seite. Also ist ja wirklich nur Copy und Paste. Ich dachte, da hätten sie wenigstens noch zwischendurch irgendwas übersetzt.
Die deutsche Mac OS X Server Seite.
Das ist englisch.
Zum Thema File System.
Zum Thema Textback. Aber hier hatten, gerade hatte ich auch noch ein anderes Bildchen.
Aber die Frage ist halt, ob man vielleicht die Kernel-Extension und ZFS-Commands irgendwie einfach von den alten Builds irgendwie sich durchreichen kann oder ob Apple irgendwas dagegen tut, dass die nicht mehr gehen oder so.
Das ist tatsächlich das einzige Wort, was fehlt auf der ganzen Beschreibung.
Ja, das sieht schon schwer nach Absicht aus, oder?
Ach, das sieht schon schwer nach, haben sie im letzten Moment rausgeschmissen aus.
Oder so, ja.
Welche Seite, kannst du mir die mal kurz zeigen?
Krass.
Der exakt einzige Unterschied im Bereich der Seite.
Damit habe ich nicht gerechnet. Warum?
Ja, warum?
Weil sie noch nicht so weit sind, weil es komplizierter ist, das System zu integrieren, als du dachte.
Ich denke auch, das ist schon auch ganz schön kompliziert und es hat auch noch so seine Macken, aber irgendwie...
Du meinst, sie haben einfach am Ende festgestellt, dass es irgendwie...
Ganz schön viel Arbeit ist auf so einem Filesystem. ZFS ist wirklich schon ein ganz schön komplexes Filesystem. Und es hat auch eine Menge Features, die man erstmal so einfach auf so einem Laptop, wo man keine weiteren Platten hat, nicht braucht und die für den User auch ganz schön komplex sind.
Wir schmeißen das ja um zwei Jahre mindestens zurück.
Ja, dann müssen wir uns ewig weiter mit HFS Plus rumschlagen. Oder die haben irgendwie was ganz anderes. Vielleicht ist ja noch irgendwie... doch irgendwie Butter FS irgendwie cooler. Oder die machen jetzt rein auf X4. Oder vielleicht haben sie Reiser aus der Zelle geholt.
Mal billig zu haben. Während seine Kollegen irgendwie noch den Dreck von dem Highway aufsammeln müssen, muss er dann irgendwie bei Apple im Keller schufen.
Genau, wie gesagt, der arbeitet bei uns, er lasse ihn auch nicht raus. Er muss hier seine Strafe absitzen. Und seine Strafe ist, er muss für Apple arbeiten. Ist ja für so einen Linux-Groder bestimmt der Tod.
Verliert er jedes Street Credibility mit?
Oder die nutzen jetzt Hammer FS von Dragonfly BSD.
Ich glaub da nicht dran.
Mein Tipp ist folgender. Also es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten meiner Meinung nach. Entweder sie halten einfach nur das Maul, weil sie noch nicht wissen, ob sie es delivern können und sie finden es nicht, dass es so wichtig ist, das jetzt anzukündigen. Und es kommt dann trotzdem, zumindest in der Server-Variante, sodass es einfach drin ist. Und wenn nicht, dann kommt es in irgendeinem Dot-Dot-Release später. Aber I predict ZFS kommt innerhalb der Laufzeit von 10.6 als Feature.
Du meinst es kommt noch?
Rietweit, ich denke es kommt noch.
Ja, ich hoffe.
Also wenn es nicht kommt, dann ist es tot. Dann kommt es nie.
Das würde ich so nicht sagen. Wir haben das doch schon ein paar Mal durchgekaut. Der Bedarf für etwas wie ZFS ist so groß. Irgendwas müssen sie liefern und sie kriegen aber FS Plus nicht dahin.
Aber ein Dateisystem, wo eine Firma wie Apple mehrere Jahre dran sitzt, das ins Betriebssystem zu integrieren, scheint mir nicht die perfekte Lösung zu sein, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Das müssen mehr Firmen machen als nur Apple das integrieren.
Das kann doch Apple egal sein. Jetzt fahren sie auf HFS Plus. Es ist auch nicht so, dass die anderen sich gerade viel Mühe geben würden, HFS Plus in ihr Betriebssystem anzubauen.
Aber sie werden bewusst.
Was sollen sie denn machen? Sollen sie ein eigenes Betriebssystem entwickeln? Das kostet sie genauso viel Zeit.
Ein nicht so komplexes Datei-System entwickeln. Welchen Teil sollen sie dann bitte rauslassen?
Welchen Teil sollen sie bitte weglassen von ZFS?
Eins, was nicht so vertikal senkrecht durchgeht durch alle Schichten des Betriebssystems.
Aber das ist doch genau der entscheidende Vorteil.
Aber auch offensichtlich ein ziemlicher Nachteil. Weil man dadurch nicht so einfach mal reinschmeißen kann.
Okay, ja natürlich, gut, es dauert halt das zu integrieren. Aber das ist das, was moderne Betriebssystementwicklung einfach die Herausforderung ist. Du musst einfach für die Zukunft gerüstet sein. Und wenn du halt ein Betriebssystem, ich meine, wenn sogar FreeBSD das integriert bekommt, dann können sie mir nicht erzählen, dass sie das in ihr Mac OS X nicht reinkriegen. Ich sag dir, sie haben die Scheiße noch. Sie haben es allerdings jetzt aus dem offiziellen Versprechen rausgenommen, weil sie es in 10.6.0 nicht delivern. Aber sie werden es nachreichen.
Punkt.
Meine Wette steht so.
Vielleicht hab ich nicht recht.
Kann ja sein. Jetzt Schluss mit Mac. Lieber Chet, haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen?
Ach so, ich hab übrigens noch mal kurz nachgeguckt. Es gibt, also es gibt, ich hab zumindest auf der AT&T-Seite hab ich mal nach MMS gesucht und es gibt diverse Hinweise, wie man sein Telefon für MMS richtig konfiguriert.
Okay, gut, gab's das auch schon.
Das ist, die haben irgendwas, was ich gehört habe, dass sie irgendwas mit den iPhone-Verträgen machen müssen.
Ja, ich will von diesem MMS nichts hören, ich halte das für unfug.
Und die Telcos lieben es, weil es ist teuer und unfug. Man könnte auch eine SMS, äh, eine Mail verschicken.
Unfug. Anyway, iTunes, kommen wir zu den iPhone-Features. 3.0. Also wir können glaube ich das, was schon angekündigt wurde, weitgehend überspringen, was wirklich neu ist, was aber jetzt auch keine Überraschung war. Man kann halt jetzt auch, äh, Filme laden vom iPhone. Nein, jetzt geht es erstmal um iTunes.
Und sogar über Edge laden.
Offensichtlich.
Also das ist, ähm, was was ja sehr, also.
Warum nicht?
Naja, weil bisher konnte man ein Haufen Zeug nicht über, ähm, über die Luft laden. Ja, ist doch schön.
Jetzt kann man auch Podcasts irgendwie in voller Länge laden. Ich finde das auch in Ordnung.
Genau.
Ist doch gut, dass sie sich da jetzt nicht mehr wehren. Apple kann es egal sein. Und wenn sie die Netze jetzt eingesehen haben, dass sie das Internet vielleicht auch einfach mal delivern sollen, umso besser. Ja, dann kommt hier irgendwie Parental Guidance in den App Store.
Na, dann besteht ja mal der Hauch einer Hoffnung, dass es in Zukunft nicht mehr zu absurden Ablehnungen kommen wird.
Ja, und dass es auch richtig Adult Content gibt jetzt. Alter, richtig. Jetzt verkaufte ich die Scheiße erst.
Jetzt erst mal den Grund erfahren, warum man das iPhone mit einer Hand halten kann.
Ja, super.
Die gute Abwaschbarkeit hatten wir uns ja letztes Mal schon unterhalten.
Jetzt ist es ja noch ein Schritt besser als beim neuen. Was ja später kommt, haben sie diesen Oleophobik irgendwie, Code irgendwie auf der Scheibe. Das heißt so Öl abweisend.
Was?
Haben sie das gesagt?
Ich weiß nicht, haben sie nicht gesagt. Kann man den Spex lesen? Oleophobik steht da. Was ich mal heiße, Oleo meinen ja bestimmt Öl mit. Und das ist halt Fett abweisend. Du kannst es besser als abwischen.
Das neue iPhone ist Öl abweisend.
Oleophobik, ja.
Das ist ja mal ein Wort.
Oleophobik, demnischen. Jetzt sind die alle am Klicken.
Damit so Flüssigkeiten nicht so drauf haften bleiben.
Das wird wahrscheinlich dann im Zweifelsfall so in Zusammenhang. Wie schreibt sich das? Fingerprint-resistant Oleophobic Coating.
Fingerprint-resistant heißt das.
Nimm das Fett nicht anders. Das Fett hat ja auch irgendwie Ideale. Und es bleibt lieber an deinem Finger kleben als an so einem komischen Display.
Was ist denn das denn für ein Zeug?
Das könnte dieses, wie heißt das? Dieser Effekt, den sie schon seit Ewigkeiten...
Also alles, was man heutzutage nicht erklärt. Nanotechnologie.
Wie heißt denn dieser Effekt?
Wie bei der Lotus-Pflanze?
Genau, Lotus-Blüteneffekt.
Ja, das ist dieses Nano-Coating. Genau, wie bei diesem... Wie heißt dieses Klo ohne Wasser? U-Matic?
Klo ohne Wasser? Das ist ja disgusting.
Uri-Math. Toller Name, ne? Heißt das, glaube ich. Es gibt so Klos ohne Wasser... Also Pinkelbecken, meine ich.
Ohne Wasserspülung.
Das ist schon so Herrenklo.
Weil es einfach keinen Tropfen dran hängen bleibt, weil alles sofort weggeht, weil es so durchrennt.
Genau, mit einem Wort, man kann jetzt ab sofort auf sein...
Und die spülen auch gar nicht? Du pinkelst da rein und...
Wird nicht gespült.
Da bleibt nicht mal ein Hauch von Feuchtigkeit hängen?
Ich bin jetzt nicht mehr mit dem Mikroskop.
Also man kann ja heißen, dass es irgendwie null Adhesion hat, oder wie man das nennt. Das kann ich mir ja nicht vorstellen, dass es so richtig gar keine Adhesion gibt.
Na ja, vielleicht nicht null, aber zumindest so wenig, dass es ausreichend einmal... Nee, dass es vielleicht ausreicht, einmal am Tag da nochmal ein bisschen Wasser am Ende des Tages nachzugehen, was du eh machen musst. Aber das halt sozusagen jetzt nicht...
Interessant.
Wir müssen das jetzt auch nicht so vertiefen, das ist mir dann auch ein bisschen zu unpassend.
Aber...
Gibt sowas auch für...
Wie auch immer. Fingerabdrücke bleiben nicht haften und kleine Kinder dürfen jetzt demnächst auch im Upstore einkaufen, weil das, was sozusagen nicht war... Also die Developer wurden ja explizit darauf hingewiesen, dass...
Sie ihre Programme nochmal neu einreichen sollen, wenn das Feature dann da ist.
Was wir nicht so gesagt haben, ist so nach diesem Motten, wenn ihr das nicht macht, dann fliegt ihr raus. Das ist ja im Prinzip die Ansage. Mal gucken, wie viel von den 50.000 Ups nächste Woche noch im Store sind. Naja, zwei Wochen Zeit haben sie. Tethering, oh Mann. Das soll ja ganz gut funktionieren, hat mir der Twitter gesagt, von den Leuten, die das ausprobiert haben. Aber wie es kommt, ist noch nicht so ganz klar. Und es wird jetzt hier auch in deutscher Land, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, wollte T-Mobile noch ankündigen, zu welchen Konditionen sie Tethering unterstützen.
Hab ich jetzt gerade da noch nichts gefunden bei den neuen Tarifen und Preisen.
Der Chat sagt uns, es heißt Trockenurinal. Ich wollte das nicht weiter vertiefen. Kann ich da mal ein CRE drüber machen. Genau, tolle Idee. Ja, dieses Tethering ist ja eigentlich das Einzige, was einen so ein bisschen beruhigt, dass die MacBooks immer noch keinen UMTS haben. Dass man jetzt einfach sein iPhone nehmen könnte. Ja, ich finde das auch okay. Die Frage ist, was will die Telekom dafür berappen und vor allem wie soll das dann vonstatten gehen? Muss man dann dieses Feature auf seinem iPhone explizit freischalten? Ich meine, wie soll denn die Telekom wissen, dass er jetzt als iPhone im Dienste von einem Rechner Internet macht und nicht selbst?
Na, es ist ja nicht auf allen aktiviert. Es kann ja jeder Provider selber sagen, habe ich das? Oder gibt es die Option wirklich nicht?
Was heißt das, der Provider sagt meinem iPhone, dass er jetzt bestimmte Dinge tun können soll?
Ich nehme an, er wird eine interne Liste haben mit den Providern, die freigeschaltet sind und die nicht freigeschaltet sind.
Wer wird eine interne Liste haben?
Das iPhone, das OS, das Betriebssystem. Und das lässt sich dann ändern über diese berühmten IPCC-Dateien, diese iPhone Carrier.
Die man aber nicht mehr updaten kann.
Soll wohl immer noch gehen, problemlos mit iPhone OS 3.0.
Ich dachte, das geht jetzt nicht mehr mit den neuesten iTunes und so. Dass man diese Carrier-Dateien da reinschiebt in sein iPhone.
Das soll wohl weiterhin funktionieren, habe ich gehört.
Ich habe genau gehört, dass es eben nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ich habe nichts gehört.
Und?
Unentschieden.
Drei Leute, drei Meinungen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, sag ich nur.
Und mit denen kann man das dann freischalten, für die einzelnen Provider?
Ja, das war bevor 8.2 rauskam.
Und?
Ja gut, aber das mach ich ja nicht selber. Die Frage ist, was passiert jetzt? Ich ruf bei der Telekom an und sag, guten Tag, ich ändere meinen Tarif, dass ich jetzt auch Tethering hab.
Die wollen natürlich, dass du dafür extra zahlst.
Ja klar, aber dann hab ich ja mein Telefon schon in der Hand.
Überhaupt nicht klar.
Ja, aber ich spiel jetzt nur dieses Ding durch. Wie läuft das? Ich latsch jetzt also in zwei Wochen. Wann kommt das iPhone raus?
Nächsten Freitag.
Nächsten Freitag? Er ist in?
Nächsten Freitag, 19. 19.6.
Der nächste Freitag ist der 12. Juni.
Nee, das ist übermorgen oder in drei Tagen. Also der nächste.
19.
Kalenderwoche plus plus. Was? Kalenderwoche plus plus.
Vielleicht solltest du noch mal probieren, auf Monat umzuschneiden. So Woche schneidet er doch nicht, so dein ganz großes Ding zu sein. Was? Wir haben heute den 9.
Ja.
Und dieser Freitag ist der 12. Und der nächste ist der 19.
Und dann kommt der nächste Freitag.
Dieser und der nächste ist bei dir was anderes?
Ja.
Was? Ja. Nächster Freitag an einem Dienstag ist bei dir in einer Woche danach?
Okay, nächste Woche Freitag kommt das neue iPhone.
Gut, am 19. Juni müssen wir sagen, weil du wirst ja, dieser Podcast.
Die hören die ja alle erst am 20.
Genau.
Also gestern kam eventuell das iPhone.
Egal, oh Gott, wird das eine lange Sendung.
Übrigens muss ich ja mal sagen, ich hab gesagt, es kommt am 18.
Ja.
Ich hab gesagt, es kommt am 18. Ich lag nur einen Tag daneben.
Okay, du hast recht gehabt. Ich hab gesagt Juli. Da lag ich falsch. Zwei Wochen früher, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, bim bim bim, was heißt denn das? Das heißt, dass man dann schon so ein iPhone kaufen kann. Kaufe ich mir das? Das hängt davon ab, wie das mit dem Tethering läuft. Weil ich finde das neue iPhone schon interessant. Aber dazu kommen wir gleich. Dann, was vermutet ihr, dass man dann jetzt 10 Euro im Monat nochmal extra zahlt, dafür, dass sein Rechner mitsurfen darf?
Ja, für alle, die sich bei der Telekom irgendwie am Ausbeuten lassen.
Aber wenn ich jetzt hier mein normales Italien-iPhone weiter mit O2 nutze und da kommt jetzt irgendwie Tellering drauf, dann muss es doch auch so laufen. Ich frage mich immer noch, was ist das für ein Vorgang? Angenommen, ich kaufe jetzt das neue iPhone und ich sage irgendwie Tellering interessiert mich nicht. Und zwei Monate später denke ich mir so, oh, wäre ja doch ganz gut. Was passiert dann? Muss ich dann zur T-Mobile laufen? Stecken die das an so einen USB?
Vielleicht musst du es einmal an deinen Rechner anschließen mit dem iTunes und der machte das.
Und ich kaufe mir das sozusagen.
Auch Activation vielleicht.
Aber diese Tarifgeschichte bei iTunes, das läuft doch schon lange nicht mehr. Das haben sie ja am Anfang mal probiert.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie es machen.
Okay, großes Fragezeichen. Wir haben keine Ahnung. Willkommen bei Mobamex, dem Podcast.
Drei Leute.
Keine Ahnung.
Ein italienisches iPhone, so wie ich demnächst hoffentlich auch. Und ich hoffe mal, dann wird es einfach gehen. So dieses Tellering. Weil ich hätte das schon gerne.
Demnächst müsste es ja auch die iPhone der ersten Generation ganz günstig geben, weil die ja jetzt auch offiziell sich anlocken lassen.
Ja, wieso? Ach so, weil zwei Jahre rum sind. Na ja, meins ist Daueranlock, ist egal.
Was?
Im November dann.
Ach stimmt, das lief ja erst seit November.
Aber auf jeden Fall gibt es im Netz überall diese...
Was läuft erst seit November?
iPhone-Verkauf in Deutschland.
November 2007. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall im Netz, für alle deutschen Provider, diese entsprechenden IPCC-Dateien, mit denen man sich das freischalten kann.
Gibt's schon? Achso, okay, das heißt, deine Feststellung ist, diese Information, dass das freigeschaltet ist, steht in einer IPCC-Datei?
Es lässt sich auf jeden Fall über eine IPCC-Datei freischalten.
Hast du da auch so eine tolle IPPC-Datei für mein O2, dass ich da irgendwie...
Ja, ja, die kann ich dir gerne dann dazu geben lassen.
Kann ich mir die auch jetzt hier schon reindroppen, wenn ich meine Items... Wo diese Rufweiterleitungsgeschichte nicht kommt...
Na, das hab ich durch einen Jailbreak. Ach, vielleicht steht das auch da drin.
Wo gibt's denn IPPC-Dateien für O2 ordentliche?
Ich mach mal weiter, ja? Dann sind sie auf Mobile Safari gegangen und meinen, das ist alles dreimal so schnell. Nachdem sie ja schon vorher festgestellt haben, dass auch der neue Safari 4 total schnell JavaScript macht.
Sind wir jetzt noch bei der Software?
Das hat mir gar nicht gesagt bei Safari 4, dass sie ja geclaimed haben, dass sie... Was war das? Dieser Benchmark.
Sunspider.
Sunspider Benchmark, irgendwie vorher 126 Sekunden und dann... Oh Gott, ich hab's mir interessiert.
14.0, Leopard.
Genau, ganz schnell und danach meinten sie noch mal mit 64-Bit nochmal 50%.
Genau und das mit den 64-Bit fand ich nämlich, weil das war ja so, das war ja gar nicht so klar, ob das so einfach überhaupt möglich ist. Chrome gibt's ja zum Beispiel noch nicht für 64-Bit. Auch nicht unter Windows, weil...
Entschuldigung, was war nicht klar?
Was ist nicht möglich? Die haben doch diesen... Die kompilieren noch quasi JavaScript-Code, um ihn schneller ausführen zu können. Und das ist jetzt nicht einfach so... Ach so. Das kompiliert man nicht einfach mal so für 64-Bit neu, sondern da hat man auch einen komplett neuen Cluster von Problemen, wie zum Beispiel das No-Execute-Bit und sowas, diese ganzen Sachen, diese Sicherheitsmechanismen, die gegen Buffer-Overflow helfen sollten. Und das war so ein Punkt, den ich so spannend fand. Na mal sehen, ob sie mit Jamsnolab hat das schaffen, weil bisher war immer nur die Rede von 32-Bit-Optimierung.
Aber 64-Bit-Safaris gibt's doch schon ewig.
Ja, aber nicht mit dieser Hi-Speed-Engine. Und dass sie die jetzt noch... Okay, unklar.
Aber offensichtlich kriegen sie es irgendwie hin und sie machen irgendwie schnell. Und das Ganze hat jetzt auch Auswirkungen aufs iPhone. Das heißt, man kann davon ausgehen, dass Webseiten-Rendering, insbesondere bei Webseiten, wofür JavaScript beteiligt ist, schneller läuft. Sodass halt so interaktive Webseiten fixer werden. Und generell muss man halt mal schauen, ob das Rendering an sich gut wird. Und dann kam's wieder auf mein Lieblingsthema.
Warte, gucken wir mal, was es bei Safari noch gibt. Du müsstest jetzt einen Punkt auffallen. Plugins.
Ich sehe ein Telefon mit dem 3.0, den Screenshot, und dann gibt es irgendwie die Möglichkeit, Plugins anzuschalten bei der iPhone OS 3.0 Version.
Da hat noch keiner ein Wort drüber verloren.
Das ist immer der Hammer.
Es gibt Plugins auf dem Mobile Safari. Da fragt man sich.
Flash.
Kein Flash. Das ist nämlich einer der nächsten Punkte.
Aber Plugins.
Was könnte das wohl sein?
Es gibt auch auf meinem iPhone den Punkt Plugins.
Du hast 2.0 oder was?
Es könnte so was wie ein YouTube-Plugin sein.
Du hast einen 2 zu 1 und da ist auch Plugins.
Das sind keine Plugins. Ach echt, das gibt es hier auch schon? Ja, offensichtlich. Gut, dass noch niemand ein Wort drüber verloren hat.
Was sind das denn für Plugins?
Das ist mal eine Schwari.
So was wie Maps und so? Was meinst du, wenn ich jetzt ausschalte, dann kommen keine Maps mehr oder was? Was für Maps überhaupt?
Google Maps.
Plugins.
Wenn du auf den Google Maps-Link linkst. Und das bei YouTube, wenn du auf YouTube gehst.
Das war ein Fehlalarm.
Das muss ja auch mal sein.
Das schneiden wir raus. So, dann haben sie aber als nächstes nochmal gesagt, ja ja, und auf iPhone OS 3.0, das hatten wir auch letztes Mal schon mal besprochen, als iPhone OS 3.0 das Thema war, kommen sie wieder mit ihrem HTTP Streaming. Das heißt, dasselbe Framework haben sie jetzt auch mit dem iPhone. Was auch immer das bedeutet. Ah ja, genau. Hier wurde ich nämlich auch erst darauf aufmerksam, dass sie halt auch meinten, dass eben auch Bitrate-Adaption und so weiter mit dabei ist bei diesem HTTP Streaming.
Das wird wahrscheinlich so ein Inhaltsverzeichner sein.
Mir ist das unklar. Ich wüsste gerne, was es ist. Naja, dann haben sie Autofälle in diesen ganzen Klimbeln. Das haben sie ja schon angekündigt. Aber was sie nicht angekündigt hatten letztes Mal, soweit ich mich erinnern kann, ist, dass sie explizit sagen, wir werden mit dem Webkit auch HTML5 Audio- und Videosupport haben. Video im Webbrowser. Was wir letztes Mal schon diskutiert haben.
Genau.
Mit YouTube und Dailymotion und dieser ganzen Kram. Das neue iPhone bzw. jedes iPhone mit iPhone OS 3.0 wird offensichtlich Audio und Video in Webseiten übertragen. Wir werden sie über HTML5 supporten.
Das lass ich ja mal lesen.
Das heißt soviel wie, wir werden Webseiten haben können in denen, die Frage, man müsste mal ausprobieren, diese YouTube irgendwie, youtube.com/html5mitiphone oder S30. Das wäre mal ganz interessant, ob da schon irgendwas interessantes funktioniert. Naja, und dann haben sie irgendwie Language Support, egal, das müssen wir nicht so betonen.
Ja, für alle Leute, die ein Mobile-Me-Account haben, sonst nicht.
Hatte ich ja hier schon mal gerüchtet, dass ich da mal was gehört hatte. Und jetzt wissen wir auch, was es ist. Man kann es halt einfach tracken und man findet es dann wieder über Mobile-Me. Was an sich ein ganz gutes Feature ist, muss man natürlich das notwendige Vertrauen mitbringen irgendwie.
Und das nötige Mobile-Me.
Weil man liefert halt sozusagen seine Position jetzt irgendwie nicht nur dem Staat, sondern auch noch Apple.
Und Google.
Ist das nicht dasselbe?
Weiß ich nicht. Das wäre vielleicht mal gar nicht so schlecht, wenn Steve Jobs mal hier die Bundesrepublik Deutschland auf Vordermann bringen würde.
Du meinst, dann wären erstmal alle......
gibt es auf jeden Fall schickere Webseiten.
Maustasten abgeschafft.
Naja, man kann es halt immer piepen lassen und Remote Vibe haben sie auch noch eingebaut. Also das, was sozusagen als Business Feature schon lange existierte. Und später erwähnen sie das ganz am Ende. Das will ich hier gleich mal aufgreifen. Dass jetzt die Daten auf dem iPhone selbst alle verschlüsselt sind. Und dass sie den Remote Vibe...
Nur bei dem iPhone 2.
Weil die Hardware Krypto haben.
Okay, gut. Und das heißt...
Da geht das Vibe immediately, weil sie einfach...
Den Key wegschmeißen.
Also dein Key liegt auch auf dem Telefon, ist aber verschlüsselt durch dein Passwort und sie brauchen einfach nur noch den Key, der auf dem Phone liegt, löschen.
Zu löschen. Und schon ist alles verschlüsselt und weg.
Ja, außer jemand hat sich vorher den Key halt irgendwie ausgelesen, aber...
Das heißt, ein Remote Vibe dauert nicht irgendwie fünf Stunden durchs Flashrahmen durchschreiben und dann ist da sowieso noch irgendwie forensisch was zu finden, sondern sie bügeln einfach nur diesen Key irgendwie ausreichend aus, sodass da mit Forensik nicht mehr viel zu machen ist, hoffentlich. Und dann ist irgendwie alles gevibe. Das ist natürlich cool.
Das ist cool.
Wobei ich ja schon toll finde, wenn sie den Rest trotzdem noch wippen würden, falls sich jemand ja doch irgendwie vorher geschafft hat, diesen Key dazu holen. Sicher, sicher.
Ja, wir werden es sehen. Aber ich würde mal sagen, so für den Konsumerbedarf ist das schon mal safe enough. Ja, dann kam diese ganze Peer-to-Peer-In-App-Store- Accessories-Kram mit tausenden Demos, das würde ich überhaupt nicht wiedergeben. Aber an einer Stelle habe ich mir hier noch eine Notiz gemacht. Nee, ein paar Stellen habe ich mir eine Notiz gemacht. Da kamen sie wieder hoch mit naja, wir machen jetzt auch Turn-by-Turn-Directions. Und da war, ich habe jetzt leider keine Gelegenheit gehabt, mir das nochmal anzuschauen. Ihr könnt mir mal sagen, was ihr da gesehen habt, aber wenn ich mich nicht irre, haben sie auch gesagt, es gab so einen kurzen Screenshot oder eine kurze Einblendung von Google Maps für Turn-by-Turn-Benutzen. Das habe ich gehört.
Google Maps Turn-by-Turn-Benutzen? Also was?
Also Google Maps Data für Turn-by-Turn-Benutzen. Bei der Präsentation von iPhone OS 3.0. Und da war irgendein 3D-View kurz zu sehen mit so Google Maps typischem Rendering.
Also ich kann mich an diesen Screenshot, also an dieses Bild erinnern. Das fand ich so aus wie, ja, hier haben sie irgendein Bild reingemacht und das bewusst nicht nach Google Maps aussieht.
Muss man nochmal nachschlagen. Also das erscheint mir ein Turn of Things zu sein, oder ist Google hat jetzt irgendwie einen Weg, wie man das defensieren kann oder so? Keine Ahnung, aber das klang für mich anders als das noch beendet war.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Kartendaten ausreichend gut sind, die Google hat, um Turn-by-Turn Directions vernünftig zu machen. Überhaupt.
Ich komm noch bei, wenn du bei Google Maps irgendwie dir eine gute machst, kommt es doch.
Naja, aber, ne, aber so ordnen sie sich jetzt in die linke Spur ein, in 200 Metern ordnen sie sich in die rechte Spur ein. Ich meine, wenn man mit so einem Navi auf der Straße rumfährt, ist ja schon eine genauere Beschreibung als Google Maps geliefert. Im Normalfall.
Aber das ist das, was ich sage. Es könnte halt sein, dass Google das jetzt in der Lage ist zu liefern, aber irgendwie war mir das einfach, die Erwähnung war irgendwie kurz, keine Ahnung. Also, fiel mir nur auf. Da war irgendwie was mit 3D. Ich muss mir das nochmal anschauen.
Die haben wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen wenig drüber erzählt, weil, halt TomTom kam.
Weil sie die Show stellen wollten. Ja, TomTom. Das können wir mal kurz erwähnen. Das sah ja ganz gut aus, vor allem mit diesem CarKit. Das fand ich alles sehr überzeugend. Die ganze TomTom Software kommt aufs iPhone und sie liefern dazu dieses CarKit und sie haben dann auch noch einen GPS-Enhancer mit da drin.
Da frag ich mich ja, wie das funktioniert.
Die haben wahrscheinlich einen eigenen GPS-Chip einfach.
Ich denke, dass sie auch eine eigene GPS-Antenne in diesem CarKit mit drin haben und dass sie sich über das Accessory-Interface...
Antenne oder auch gleich den kompletten Chip? Weil es würde das ja schon nochmal ein bisschen teurer machen.
Naja, so ein GPS-Stein.
Um 6 Euro.
Das ist dann einfach im Preis mit drin von diesem komischen CarKit.
Nee, aber... Nee, obwohl. Ich glaube, wir können sie auch an die ganz alten, also an so ein Telefonesupporten, aber ob das deren Interesse ist, auch noch, ich weiß nicht.
Also meine Erfahrungen mit GPS, mit dem iPhone derzeit sind so, dass ich mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen konnte, dass man damit wirklich Turn-by-Turn machen kann. Es kann natürlich sein, dass die neue Software das verbessert hat, aber die Errors, die ich da manchmal drin hab, ich nutze, also ich teste regelmäßig GPS, zum Beispiel, wenn ich in Zügen unterwegs bin und so, und da krieg ich einfach haarsträubende Ergebnisse. Also mehrere hundert Kilometer entfernt.
Also die Qualität lässt zu wünschen übrig.
Wenn ich dann auf einmal und also definitiv nicht so, dass ich mit Zuverlässigkeit sagen könnte, ob ich jetzt auf dieser oder jener Seite bin.
Ja, also ich hab mit dem GPS eigentlich, also ich weiß nicht, ob es für so was taugt, klar, das ist eine andere Frage, aber ich nutze das regelmäßig, um mich auf dem Fahrrad zu orientieren oder so was und das ist gut. Also so, dass ich weit entfernt war, dass ich mal so zwei Kilometer entfernt war oder so, das hatte ich genau einmal. Da war es natürlich auch eine Situation, wo ich keinen blaßen Schirmer hatte, wo ich bin und das erst nach einer halben Stunde mitgekriegt habe, dass er mich die ganze Zeit in eine komplett falsche Richtung leitet.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall den Eindruck, dass TomTom der Meinung war, es wäre doch wohl besser, wenn man einfach nochmal ein GPS-Steinchen und eine kleine Antenne mit in dieses Car-Kit einbaut und dann einfach eine Differenzsignal hat und damit genauer sein kann.
Na ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass es einfach ganz gut ist, dass das bessere Antenne oder sowas drinnen zu haben, damit das schön durch die Decke vom Auto durchgeht.
Das ist doch eine Glasscheibe vorne.
Naja, aber die sind ja auch gerne beschichtet mit irgendwas gegen Sonnenabweisung und damit auch...
Ja, aber das Problem hat auch jedes TomTom Gerät dann auch.
Ja, aber die haben eure lange Erfahrung, damit dieses Problem zu umgehen.
Genau, die haben einfach Erfahrung, die wissen, wie sie es bauen und vielleicht waren sie sich dadurch sicher...
Also was ich ja eigentlich viel cooler finden würde, wäre meine vernünftige Navigation auf dem Fahrrad. Dass ich Kopfhörer drinnen habe, meine Musik hören kann und dann mir das TomTom regelmäßig ansagte oder welches Navigation auch immer, wie ich mit dem Fahrrad zu fahren habe und gar nicht hier irgendwie mit einer Autoscheibe und sowas.
Vielleicht gibt es ja einen Fahrradmodus.
Also das würde ich...
Gibt es schon TomTom für Fahrrad? Oder? Nee, ich meine, es gibt ja explizit auch Fahrrad-Navigationssysteme. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob TomTom 1 ein Angebot hat.
Also bei meinem TomTom Rider kannst du auch sagen, du willst irgendwie...
Also es gibt für Motorrad, genau. Motorrad und Fahrrad sind ja nochmal was anderes.
Das ist schon ein fettes Teil.
Und Motorräder sind ja andere Routen, als du mit einem Fahrrad fährst.
Kannst du eigentlich noch was für einen haben willst?
Achso, der kann auf Fahrrad routen.
Vielleicht geht's auf dem iPhone auch.
Du und den TomTom Rider für das Motorrad kannst du ja auch ins Auto packen.
Ich frage mich, was das Teil kosten wird.
Das ist eine spannende Frage, oder?
Naja, ich glaube, es wird teuer.
Na billig ist es bestimmt.
Was kostet diese Handy-Software, die sie verkaufen?
150 könnte ich werten, kostet das. Wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen mehr eventuell, weil das CarKit, da wollen die halt Geld für haben und die Software an sich und die Karten haben die ja auch. Und die zockt einen ja ab bei den Karten.
Naja, ich glaube mal, dass die, dass, also ich behaupte einfach mal, dass die kapiert haben, dass es am App-Store sich gut verkauft, was relativ günstig ist und dass sie das dann so das eigentliche App, sagen wir mal, für unter, also so für 9,95 oder so was verklappen.
Also Navigator 7, ich glaube so, heißt diese Software hier für Windows, Smartphone und so weiter, das kostet alles so 99,95.
Das ist jetzt ohne Hardware, ne?
Ja, für Smartphones halt. Für Windows, Smartphones.
Also da könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass es ein bisschen billiger ist durch den App-Store.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Oh doch. Warum?
Glaube ich. Ich wollte gerade sagen...
Leute kaufen das nicht, wenn es so 130 Dollar kostet?
Also ich für 10 Euro oder für 20 Euro würde es mit blind kaufen, für 130 Euro würde ich es nicht machen. Und ich glaube so denken viele Leute.
Ich glaube die wollen dann auch eher das Geld mit dem K-Kit noch verdienen.
Oder mit zusätzlichen Kartenmaterial, was du dem prolaub nach brauchst.
So sieht es aus. Die müssen ja erst mal einen anfixen, verdienen tun die ja dann später.
Wir werden sehen. Ich tippe auf 99.
Ich tippe auf 50.
Ganz kleines Detail am Rande, bevor ich es vergesse, was ich ganz lustig fand, dass Microsoft war ja relativ clever, also wahrscheinlich waren sie nicht clever, aber ich fand es ein lustiger Zufall, dass einige Male die New York Times im Bild war und dass offensichtlich Microsoft die New York Times gerade voll gekauft hat und überall Werbebanner für Bing drauf waren an einer Apple Keynote. Ich glaube, das wäre mit Steve Jobs auch nicht passiert.
Während der Keynote war...
Während der Keynote war hin und wieder mal Safari offen. Und da war natürlich immer die New York Times zu sehen. Und da ist überall Bing-Werbung für diese neue Suchmaschine von Microsoft.
Das wird jetzt bestimmt die Revolution im Suchmaschinenmarkt auslösen, dass die Werbung zu sehen wird.
Naja, aber ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sich da bei Microsoft einige die Hände reiben und dass Steve da ziemlich sauer ist, dass da Microsoft Werbung in seiner Keynote drin ist. Nee, sowas ist dem nicht egal. Doch. Weil sowas wird ja richtig...
Ich sag nur, ich bin Phose.
Die haben den Namen von Palm nicht mal gesagt. Ich glaube, bei sowas sind die richtig pissig.
Das mit Palm war lustig, ne?
Ich kann die Zahlen nicht lesen.
Genau, das ist zu klein, das kann ich nicht lesen. Nee, nicht die Zahl, sondern was da steht oder so.
Ja, nee, der hat ja von den anderen, der hat auch die ganzen Apps gesagt, die es im Store gibt. Und bei Palm meint, da kann er die Zahlen nicht lesen. Wie viele Apps das da gibt.
Aber er hat auch nicht den Namen Palm gesagt.
Mit Palm ist das persönlich, mit dem Prä.
Ich glaub auch.
Das heißt schon wieder, das ist ein gutes Ding.
Das ist der eigentliche Feind.
Ja, wir müssen eh nochmal über den Prä reden. Reden wir erst mal über das neue iPhone. Noch kurz zu der iPhone OS Geschichte.
Also die Software, die wir gerade beredet haben, kommt übrigens nicht am 19.6., wo das neue Telefon kommt, sondern die Software kommt schon am 17.6.
Genau.
Mittwoch.
Wie?
Komm in der Woche.
Ach wirklich? Es kommt erst die Software und dann kommt das Telefon? Dann hab ich ja Unrecht gehabt.
Dass erst das Phone kommt und dann die Software? Ja. Zwei Tage.
Das war's.
Ich schreib mal eine Vakanz hier für einen Moderator-Job bei Mobile Max aus.
Was steht denn noch so zum iPhone? Und jetzt auf deinen Karten, bevor wir jetzt noch weiter über das Telefon selber reden.
Was mir aufgefallen ist in dieser einen langweiligen Spiele-Demo. Und zwar dieses Racing, mit fest aufgemotzten Oldschool-Verbrennungsmotor-Geräten durch Straßen und so, und fährst alles um. Und dann hatten sie dieses neckische Detail mit dein Auto-Radio. Und dann kannst du da die Musik auswählen. Und es gibt ja in iPhone OS 3.0 jetzt das API, dass du eben auf den Musikkatalog des iPhones über das Programm zugreifen kannst. Und da fiel mir einfach nur auf, dass es doch vielleicht mal ganz schön wäre, wenn es Applikationen gibt, die einfach ein anderes Interface als das Standard-iPod-Interface bieten, um den Katalog durchzublättern. Also dass man sozusagen Coverflow weglassen kann und vor allem auch ein ordentliches User-Interface für Podcasts hat. Spiel mir nur einen Podcast ab und wenn der vorbei ist, spiele ich gleich den nächsten Podcast ab. Also man könnte jetzt per Software das fixen, was der normale iPod-Player nicht hergibt. Man könnte einfach eine ordentliche Podcast-Abspielsoftware machen und auch andere User-Interfaces machen und vor allem nicht diesen Scheiß mit Coverflow, wenn du irgendwie dein Telefon im Bett querhältst und so einen Kack. Das fände ich ja großartig.
Einfach eine Option, um Coverflow abzuschalten, wäre mal was hübsches.
Ja, aber es kommt ja offensichtlich nicht. Deswegen fiel mir nur gerade ein, dass man jetzt sozusagen nicht mehr auf die iPod-Anwendung angewiesen ist, um auf dem iPhone auf die Library zuzugreifen. Und das wäre ja toll.
Aber ich fürchte...
Und wenn ihr irgend einer zuhört, der irgendwie iPhone-Software macht, sagen wir mal drüber nachdenken, sowas zu bauen.
Aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das so sein wird, dass, wenn man von seinem eigenen Programm aufzugreift, dass sobald man das Programm beendet, die Musik aufhört.
Ich glaube, das... Gute Frage. Ich hoffe nicht.
Ansonsten könnte es nämlich so eine Späße nicht...
Ja, aber das iPod-Programm kann ja auch beenden und er spielt ja weiter. Also ich denke, das ist schon auf der selben Ebene...
Ich bin mal sehr gespannt.
Das iPod-Programm läuft im Hintergrund weiter.
Das iPod-Programm? Ich hab ja so... Bist du sicher? Ich hab ja einen Jailbreak. Und...
Da weißt du ja mehr als alle anderen.
Und in einem Jailbreak gibt es das Programm Backgrounder. Und das zeigt an, seit ein paar Versionen, welche Programme man jetzt gerade auf dem Hintergrund gestellt hat.
Ja.
Und das zeigt an, welche Programme laufen noch. Und das zeigt auch die von Apple an. Und da guck mal unten rechts, da hat der iPod ein kleines Icon noch dran. Und Safari hat auch noch ein kleines Icon dran. Safari läuft nämlich auch im Hintergrund weiter.
Verstehe.
Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwas anderes, so das SMS-Programm starte und das dann wieder beende, dann seh ich kurz das Icon noch, wenn der Prozess noch nicht ganz beendet ist. Und...
Vielleicht war es auch nur ein Wunsch. Das ist ja nett. So, dann gab's noch zwei Anwendungen, die ich ganz interessant fand. Nämlich diese Sache mit dem eBook, dass sie das so in den Mittelpunkt gerückt haben. Ob sie da wie Amazon treten wollten, keine Ahnung. Aber offensichtlich scheint eBooks auf dem iPhone durchaus ein Markt zu sein, wenn sie sich da so engagieren.
Ich glaube, sie wollten auch eine Nicht-Spiele-Anwendung für dieses In-App-Buying zeigen. Weil ihnen das sehr wichtig ist.
Ja, das mag sein.
Haben sie doch mit TomTom.
Naja, aber die haben noch nichts von In-App. Doch, doch.
Hat er? Weiß ich gar nicht mehr. Naja, okay, ist auch nicht so wichtig, dann diese 7K-Anwendung.
Das ist geil.
Großartig, oder?
Das will ich auch haben.
Lass mit deinem iPhone rum und unlocks einfach das Auto vor dir über dein iPhone. Das heißt, alle ihre Autos sind sozusagen am Internet. Das ist natürlich auch nochmal eine interessante…
Alle ihre Autos lassen sich per Internet aufschließen.
Alle ihre Autos lassen sich per Internet aufschließen. Hacking Opportunity, sag ich nur.
Das wäre für die deutschen Bahnfahrer, weil das auch mal eine solche Option ist.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie sich darüber Gedanken gemacht haben. So, ich hab mir hier notiert, 27. Juni kommt das iPhone OS 3.0.
Nicht falsch notiert, das kommt nächste Woche.
Hab ich falsch notiert? Ich hoffe, dass der Chat mich jetzt rettet. Chat, wann kommt iPhone OS 3.0?
Früher ist es immer TAT.
Genau, was sagt der TAT dazu?
17.
Oh, 17, ihr seid gemein, ihr seid fies.
Du darfst auch noch bis zum 27. warten, wenn du willst.
Okay, jetzt sind wir endlich, nachdem wir nur... Nachdem wir nur zweieinhalb Stunden über andere Sachen geredet haben, sind wir jetzt endlich bei der Hardware angekommen.
Wer will anfangen?
Gibt es ein neues iPhone, so zack. Also das erste heißt 3GS und nicht 4G oder was soll man denn sagen? Darf ich dir das für einen Scheiß erzählen? Weil es soll wohl für Speed stehen.
Ja, tut es auch.
So, und die haben gesagt, es ist halt schneller.
Also wir haben die Features letzte Woche eigentlich korrekt vorhergesagt. Keine nennenswerte Abweichung. Es sind noch ein paar kleine Details dazu gekommen. Also schnellere CPU.
Haben sie aber nicht explizit erwähnt.
Was? Schnellere CPU?
Sie haben gesagt, dass alles um so und so viel schneller geht.
Hätten sie mal was sagen können.
Na ja, gut. Weißte, ist nicht so wichtig. Worüber wir gar nicht geredet haben, ist die nächste Generation OpenGL ES 2.0. Wo halt mehr Features drin sind, die auch bei OpenGL mit drin sind. Dann halt 7,2 Megabit HSDPA. Wir hatten ja noch gemutmaßt über dieses Gerücht mit den drei Versionen. Das hat sich ja nur teilweise...
Mit dem Shiner Mobile Dingens.
Ja, mit Shiner ist es sozusagen noch offen.
Dass das alte noch drin bleibt.
Genau, das alte ist sozusagen... Wir haben ja gesagt, oder ich hab zumindest gesagt, sie machen nicht zwei verschiedene Modelle. Dass sie jetzt das alte noch weiterbauen, okay.
Weil sie noch genug davon haben und die raus müssen.
Oder weil sie jetzt wie mit dem alten MacBook einfach einen billigeren Markt...
Apple ist so gut, was das Abverkaufen von bestehenden Beständen abgeht. Das haben die seit Jahrzehnten perfekt drauf.
Kann aber schon sein, dass es irgendwann ausläuft. Aber zumindest ist es ein eleganter Weg, diese Überbrückung zu machen, dass sie nicht wieder dieses Verfügbarkeitsproblem haben. Das heißt, sie verkaufen die alte Generation einfach nochmal ein halbes Jahr länger. Und dann gibt es das irgendwann nicht mehr. Dann gibt es nur noch das Neue, weil sie sehen, dass sowieso die meisten Leute das Neue wollen und dann ist es weg. Und dadurch haben sie natürlich relativ elegant diese Überbrückung hinbekommen. Könnte man jetzt so sagen. Könnte man auch einfach sagen, es geht primär darum, billiger in den Markt reinzugehen. Sie können das alte iPhone billiger herstellen, weil die Prozessoren nicht mehr so viel kosten und so weiter.
Meinst du, dass das ernsthaft so ein großer Preisunterschied ist? Oder ob das nicht eine reine Marketing-Sache ist?
100 Dollar.
Die 100 Dollar. Also ob sie die wirklich rausholen aus den Unterschieden aus.
Und das alte gibt es aber auch nur als 8 Gigabyte-Version, ne?
Na das gibt es bei AT&T gibt es das noch für 149.
Sie kriegen definitiv das Flash-Rahmen billiger.
Naja, aber so ein bisschen Flash-Cost ist ja nun wirklich nicht viel.
Ja, aber die Hälfte kostet halt noch mal sehr viel weniger.
Suntf, ist das nicht stinknormaler, wesentlichen SD-Card-Flash?
Was?
1 Gigabyte?
Weißt du, Geier, was dir das jetzt... Es ist billiger als mehr. Die CPU ist billiger als die andere CPU und die Grafikscheine ist billiger als die andere. Also es ist halt alles billiger.
Ich würde sagen Produktionskosten unterschieden.
Die Kamera ist billiger als die andere Kamera. Aber der Kamera mag das schon signifikant sein. Ist ja auch egal. Produktionsunterschied 20, 30 Dollar, das ist das, was am Ende die 100 Dollar auch ausmacht. So. Kann auch sein, dass sie da auf ein bisschen Marge verzichten und so weiter. Sie wollen einfach in diesen Markt rein.
Jetzt haben sie den App Store. Um nochmal Geld zu verdienen.
Ja, ich denke nicht, dass wir dem App Store wirklich jetzt so viel Geld verdienen. Aber auf jeden Fall ist für sie auch erstmal wichtig, noch mehr Marktanteile zu erzielen. Weil das alles andere auch noch mitzieht.
Nein, App Store sind insofern wichtig, dass du brauchst viel großen Markt um... Also ich meine, sie werben nicht umsonst mit ihrer gigantischen Anzahl an Programmen. Weil das für das Produkt spricht. Und je mehr andere Leute außer dir das Produkt haben, das iPhone haben, desto wertvoll ist es für einen selber.
Na ja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall gibt es nicht wirklich zwei neue Modelle. Sonst gibt es nur ein neues Modell. Und ich bezweifle nach wie vor, dass es eine Mainland China Version geben wird. Wenn das kommt, dann bin ich überrascht. Aber aus den ganzen Argumenten, die ich letztes Mal schon genannt hatte, denke ich nicht, dass das passieren wird. Wir werden sehen. Dann ist eine neue Kamera drin in dem Teil. Wie vorhergesagt, 3 Megapixel oder 1,2 Megapixel, was auch immer.
Mit Autofokus.
Mit Autofokus, mit Auto-White Balance, mit Auto-Exposure, überhaupt Auto, Auto, Auto. Und auch mit Auto-Makro-Funktion. Super, das heißt, man kann jetzt endlich Makro-Aufnahmen machen. Das heißt, das iPhone taugt jetzt endlich zum Barcode-Scan. Was nicht ganz unwichtig ist. Und überhaupt, um einfach mal Dinge aus der Nähe zu fotografieren. Low-Light-Sensitivity verbessert, haben sie gesagt. Und was ich richtig geil finde, ist dieses Tap-to-Focus. Dass du wirklich irgendwo draufstehend bist, und dann sagst du, das hätte ich jetzt gerne scharf. Das ist echt ein super Feature. Ja, dann können sie Video aufnehmen. 30 Frames pro Sekunde. Also 640, 480.
Was okay ist.
Und halt Trimming und YouTube und Movami hochladen, klar.
Was ja auch ganz dezent in ihrem neuen 3GS-Werbevideo schon zeigen, dass das halt das iPhone aufgenommen hat.
Also dieser Werbespot, den fand ich total derf.
Den fand ich auch total verwirrend. Was zeigt dieser?
Da will jemand das iPhone klauen, stellt dann fest, haha, ist ja nur das Alte.
Der sieht wohl gleich aus, meint er.
Und dann kommt aber der Typ rein, der es bewachen muss. Und der hat die ganze Zeit schon mit dem Video aufgezeichnet.
Und guckt sich das an und sieht, dass halt die Kamera um das iPhone rumgegangen ist. Mann, Tim, hast du dir da nicht aufgepasst?
Ich hab mir das zweimal irgendwie angeguckt und hab überhaupt nichts verstanden.
Der ist total scheiße.
Das ist der dezente Inweis, dass das Ding Video aufnehmen kann.
Ich glaub, das begrabt keinen Schwanz.
Ich hab das sofort begriffen.
Was? Ich muss mir den jetzt nochmal angucken.
Guck den jetzt schnell nochmal an.
Nein, das musst du ja nicht jetzt angucken.
Aber der geht doch schnell.
Doch.
Also ich finde, aber so die Werbespots fürs iPhone, die sind generell so...
Da ist jetzt irgendwie eine Kamera, dann dreht er da, dann dreht sich dieses komische Ding um das Teil herum.
Die haben halt total viel Hightech drinnen, um das Ding jetzt zu klauen.
Nein, warte mal, da ist eine Kamera, die das iPhone filmt.
Genau, Produkt-Spionage.
Genau, aber das iPhone filmt auf die Kamera halt.
Und jetzt kommt gleich der Typ rein und filmt zurück, sozusagen.
Und sieht dann, dass da jemand irgendwie da war und guckt ja dann auch ganz kurz nach oben, bevor Ende ist. Also weil er weiß, wo es ja von oben kommt.
Oh Gott, das ist ja der schlechteste Werbespot, den sie je gemacht haben.
Äh, ein Spruch.
Was, es gab noch einen schlechteren?
Also könnt ihr euch noch an diese iPhone-Spots erinnern, wo diese iPhone-People so rumstanden, die dann in so einer Pseudo-Deko wurden so, ja, und ich kann ja mit Visual-Voice mailen, und da kann ich, und ja, und da labert mich jetzt voll gerade, und so, diese ein Zeitlang mal aktuell waren. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die von Apple oder von AT&T waren. Die waren so abgrundtief schlecht, dass man sich wirklich schämen musste fast.
Wo die Leute gesagt haben, wie sie das Telefon benutzen.
Genau.
Das ist doch überzeugend irgendwie.
Das fand ich, aber die Typen waren so unsympathisch.
Apple-User.
Ach, hier gibt es ja noch ganz viele neue Spots.
Nee, nee, die sind alle... Du willst jetzt nicht alle gucken? Ach so, einer ist für den Kompass.
Wir sind hier live.
Ansonsten sind die nicht neu.
Itchy heißt ja Kompass und iBird plus so so iBird.
Das ist so ein Programm, mit dem du eine Phone-Gui bestimmen kannst.
Ach, toll.
Wirklich?
Der ist in App versät.
Der ist in App versät. Howcast.
Das könnte kleben bleiben.
Ist doch schön.
Die bräuchten mal sowas. Hello, I'm a Paul Pree. Hello, I'm an iPhone.
Sag mal, dein O2IPCC, was du irgendwie dir machst, kann das sein, dass es von O2 England ist oder Ireland?
Nee, guck mal, such mal nach o2.de einfach. Zum Beispiel. Oder ich weiß nicht. Du wirst, du wirst. Es ist, ich such die, ich such ein Link raus. Ich will nicht nur englische O2IPCC-Files. Nein, es gibt eine Seite, da gibt es für alle deutschen Provider, gibt es die. Und ich werde mal gucken, ob die überhaupt nötig sein werden.
Also ich finde die Werbung scheiße.
Die Werbung ist total scheiße.
So, sind wir noch beim Thema?
Oder seid ihr gerade woanders?
Beim Thema iPhone?
Okay, dann kommen wir wieder zurück. Also dann haben sie das einzige Feature, was sie jetzt angekündigt haben, von dem wirklich vorher weder was bekannt war, dass sie das tun werden würden, noch irgendwie ein Gerücht da war, ist dieses Voice Control.
Das war schon ein Gerücht, Voice Control.
Aber doch nicht in dieser Dimension. Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, man drückt die Home-Taste länger und dann geht er in diesen Voice-Control-Modus. Und dann kann man ihm sagen, spiel dieses Stück und dann macht es sozusagen richtig Spracherkennung, dass man sich auf bestimmte Titel beziehen kann.
Ah, da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, wie gut das in der Praxis funktioniert.
Ja, vor allem, ob das überhaupt in Deutsch funktioniert.
Das ist die nächste gute Frage.
Also heißt das, dass sie jetzt in jeder unterstützten Sprache, in jeder ihrer, wie viel haben sie jetzt angegeben, dass sie hätten 30 Sprachen da irgendwie Spracherkennung machen können?
Da hab ich ja mal eine Zweifel.
Das scheint mir wieder so ein English-Only zu sein. Ich meine, das haben sie ja auch auf dem Mac nie hinbekommen. Bezweifel ich. Dann ist diese Nike-Plus-Kram da mit drin. Okay, warum nicht? Und More Battery Life und das war's.
Und der Kompass.
Ah ja, genau, und der Kompass hab ich vergessen.
Das ist cool, weil das auch deine Maps, deine Karte gleich ausregelt.
Das ist wichtig.
Du weißt, in welche Richtung du die Straße laufen musst.
Ja, ich renne hier mit dem Telefon rum. Das hat einen Kompass drinnen von Google. Das ist nämlich dieses HTC Mansion. Damit kann ich dann in Street View mich herumgucken. Aber auf die einfachste naheliegende Idee, dass man einfach mal die Karte so zurechtdrehen könnte, wie ich gerade gucke, ist Google offensichtlich nicht gekommen. Das finde ich echt traurig. Aber Apple. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen Apple und Google.
Das stimmt.
Zumindest was die Betriebssystementwicklung angeht.
Also das mit dem Street View, da hin, wo du hinguckst, das ist wirklich so was von beknackt. Weil du eh weißt, wo du hinguckst.
Na ja, aber wenn du irgendwann mal den Zustand hast, dass du da eben die Punkte einblenden kannst und so ein bisschen Augmented Reality, kann das schon ganz knuffig sein.
Das ist jetzt der Reichstag, der gebaut Blabla und Tralala und Tralala.
Im Augenblick ist es ein reines Dino-Feature.
Dann ist es okay, aber so ist es ein reines Nerd-Feature, because we can. So, und jetzt ist meine Liste abgearbeitet.
Really?
Ja, jetzt müssen wir nur noch über den Palm Pre reden.
Über den Palm Pre.
Du hast ja alle Reviews durchgelesen und ich vermute mal du bist begeistert.
Und der Batterie hält länger im neuen iPhone.
Ja, hab ich das eben vergessen zu erwähnen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Hab ich glaube ich kurz gesagt. Hatte ich ja vorausgesagt.
Das kommt auch am 19.06. in Deutschland schon. Aber, und in Italien auch, aber in Belgien zum Beispiel, wenn man sich ein iPhone da kauft, mir kommt es erst eine Woche später. Tschechien weiß ich jetzt nicht genau. Weil, meine lieben Hörer, ich mag euch ja alle ganz doll.
Ich will so ein Phone haben.
Ahja, das ist die große Frage, nicht? Wo gibt es das Ganze in Unlocked?
Genau.
Das ist tatsächlich eine spannende Frage.
Weil bleibt das alles genauso wie es war?
I want it. Also unsere Hörer haben ja letztens schon irgendwie angeboten, weil die besorgen sich ja auch alle irgendwie. Und du hast ja deins auch über Kontakt gekriegt, richtig?
Oder? Ich hab, ja, über Twitter.
Über Twitter. Das sind ja unsere Hörer. Und ich will so ein Phone haben.
Ich will auch so ein Phone haben. Und ich befürchte, dass mal wieder der T-Mobile... Also ich bin durchaus, ich überlege... Also ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ich unter Umständen so einen T-Mobile-Vertrag eingehe, aber es ist...
Ach du hast ja jetzt auch keinen, stimmt. Nee, ich will keinen T-Mobile-Vertrag.
Ich will eigentlich auch keinen. Andererseits habe ich auch nicht so wieder so eine Lust, so viel Geld auszugeben für dieses Telefon.
Doch, ich schon.
Also ich bin ehrlich gesagt...
Nee, weil guck mal, mit dem Teasering... Also ich will meinen Data planen, ich will das einfach irgendwie...
Teasering heißt das.
Whatever. Ich will das einfach freehanden. Und ich will nicht bei T-Mobile irgendwie für Teasering...
Also schon allein...
Don't tether me, Bro!
Aber schon allein im Urlaub, die SIM-Karte auswechseln zu können und so.
Und was die da verlangen für das Teasering.
Ja klar, aber dafür hab ich ja jetzt mein altes iPhone.
Ich hab noch nicht zwei iPhones mit mir rum.
Naja, im Ausland würde ich dann halt das andere iPhone benutzen.
Aber wisst ihr was?
Das was du jetzt hast.
Ja, ich hab ja so ein Auslandes iPhone.
Und wenn du im Ausland unterwegs bist, willst du dann auf dein Kompass verzichten?
Ja, für eine Woche Österreich irgendwie.
Auf dein Tom-Tom.
Na toll.
Das ist totaler Blödsinn.
Doch, doch, doch. Auf mein Kompass kann ich echt verzichten, wenn ich dafür wohnen will.
Dann brauchst du auch kein neues iPhone. Wofür eigentlich?
Für die, für die neue Kamera.
Also ich bin ja ehrlich.
Und die brauchst du im Urlaub nicht.
Erwischt.
Na ich kann...
Jungs, drei neue...
Ich muss ja mit dem Ding nicht telefonieren, um damit zu fotografieren.
Ha, ich will erst mal gern Twitt picken. Ah, ich kann das ja per Blutdruck hin und her schicken.
Das wird damit enden, dass du beide Telefone mitnimmst. Das ist doch blöd.
Der Trend geht zum Zweitelefon.
Ich will Unlock Telefon haben. Diese, diese...
Ich will auch ein Unlock Telefon haben, aber es ist wirklich...
Dieses Nazi-Locking, das will keiner.
Naja, ich auch nicht.
Siehst du, so. Und dann zahle ich halt mal 200, 300 Euro mehr. Die spar ich ja danach an den Tarifen locker wieder rein.
Also ich bin ernsthaft beim Überlegen, ob ich nicht einfach überspringe.
Ja, hab ich ja gemacht. Ich hab ja euer übersprungen. Das jetzt hier hab ich übersprungen. 3G hab ich ja verpasst.
Mal sehen, wie lange ich das durchhalte. Also wahrscheinlich, wenn ich dann das erste Mal sehe, wie bei jemand anderem, dass der Fahrrad dreimal so schnell startet, wie bei mir, dann wär ich auch ins Savanne geraten.
Also Schnelligkeit ist schon etwas, was ich vermisse.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was der iPhone 3 bringt.
Es geht nicht.
Dann nimm mal so ein HTC Magic und scroll mal da drüben, dann weißt du, was rucklig ist.
Ja, aber die Ups sind okay schnell.
Ja, aber so vom Gefühl her ist es rucklig.
Also das ist ein S-Programm auf dem iPhone.
Ich vergleich mich doch jetzt nicht mit so einem Windows-Mobile-Gerät.
Hallo, das ist ein Android.
Was? Ach so, das ist Magic.
Bist du wohl aufhören?
Ja, ist schwierig zu sagen. Also ich würde sagen, in diesem, was nicht 3.0-Features sind, es ist eigentlich nur die Geschwindigkeit und es ist die Kamera. Aber das mag schon einen Unterschied machen. Für dich ist es natürlich viel interessanter als iPhone 1.0.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also für ihn jetzt mit HSDPI und allem.
Wir starten das Programm Kuchen.
Mehr Speicher, schneller.
Also wenn es Tschechien ist, könnte ich dir unter Umständen auch was vermitteln, weiß ich nicht. Und ansonsten gucken wir mal, was so die Hörergemeinde hergibt. Da wissen wir dann demnächst mehr. So, und? Ist das jetzt der Pre-Killer?
Das neue iPhone?
Was ist denn Pre-Killer?
Na ja, das, was den Palm Pre killt.
Ich hab mir da noch nicht weiter angeguckt von dem Telefon. Das kam ja erst vor kurzem raus. Was gibt es denn da Neues?
Das kam am Sonnabend. Das ist ein, ähm, das, also, nach einhelliger Meinung, von der Bedienung her, das erste Telefon, das mit dem iPhone aufnehmen kann und in einigen Punkten auch gut überlegen ist.
Und was ist das für ein OS? Kein Android, sondern was ganz Eigenes.
Man kann mit dem PalmPri Käse schneiden.
Das ist das WebOS heißt das. Hat man schon mal. Also das ist eine komplette Neuentwicklung auf, äh, also das ist basiert auf Linux.
Auf dem Linux Kernel.
Auf dem Linux Kernel. Und, ähm, das ganze GUI und sowas ist komplett HTML.
Nee, das sind keine Webapps, sondern ihre Native API ist JavaScript.
Und HTML.
Und ihre Layout-Sprache ist HTML und CSS. Also sie benutzen die Web-Standards, aber du hast schon ein Application-Framework, was über das normale, äh, Environment, was du innerhalb einer Webseite hast, hinausgeht. Also du hast auch Media-API, also wie du Coco auf dem iPhone hast, hast du halt das WebOS-API da, wo du vorher auf dem iPhone Objective-C programmierst, programmierst du JavaScript und ja.
Na wie, wollen die denn mal richtige Programme anbieten?
Das sind ihre richtigen Programme.
Und JavaScript. Okay, ich seh jetzt total beschleunigt und geht ja auch in schnell.
Ja, naja klar, doch, wirklich, das muss man auch so sehen. Also JavaScript ist eine Programmiersprache, von der wir noch mehr hören werden in Zukunft.
Also das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist...
Leute programmieren ja auch in Ruby und in Python.
Also das find ich, so dieses WebOS, diesen Ansatz finde ich nach wie vor, das ist das, was ich mir von Apple gewünscht hätte. Weil es gibt... Na weil du...
Weil du kein Objective-C kannst.
Ja, weil niemand Objective-C kann.
Klar, man ist voll easy, musst dich nicht mal reinhängen.
Ja, du musst dich reinhängen. JavaScript können auf diesem Planeten so so viele Millionen Leuten.
Ja, JavaScript musst du dich auch reinhängen.
Ja, aber ich meine, wie viele können das schon? Wie viele Leute entwickeln jeden Tag Webseiten?
Na, aber warte, vergleiche jetzt, wie viele Leute schon JavaScript können, mit denen, die halt, also du vergleiche nicht mehr, welches schwer ist, sondern nur, die hatten JavaScripten nehmen können, weil es schon so viele können.
Nee, das kann, nein. In JavaScript programmieren können nicht viele.
Das ist wahrscheinlich schon ein paar mehr als Objective-C.
Da wär ich mir nicht so sicher.
Also zum einen meine bestehende Web-Applikation, die zum Beispiel sowas wie...
Wer programmiert denn ernsthaft in JavaScript? Ich bitte dich. Die meisten Leute benutzen irgendwelche vorgefertigten Frameworks, wo jemand anderes für sie JavaScript programmiert hat. So, und dann machen sie hier so ein bisschen Glue, und dann wird hier das eine oder andere HTML-Element ausgetauscht. Aber dass jetzt wirklich seriöse Anwendungen kleinzeitig in JavaScript, mit dem JavaScript-Objektmodell und so weiter entwickelt werden, und dass da seriöse Apis benutzt werden, das ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass du die Tür aufmachst, und es kommen irgendwie Horden reingestürzt.
Es kommen keine Horden rein, aber es ist einfach so, dass das... Also erstens bestehende Web-Applikation, die du schon hast, den JavaScript-Anteil, den auf so einen WebOS zu portieren, ist natürlich dramatisch weniger, als das jetzt im Objective-C alles nachzupuzzeln. Und zum Zweiten ist es, also ich meine, man weiß ja, was so ein Objective-C-Programmierer zur Zeit pro Stunde bekommt, und man weiß, was ein JavaScript-Entwickler an der gleichen Zeit bekommt. Und man ahnt dann, woran das auch liegen könnte.
Was bekommt denn der eine und was der andere?
Ich weiß nicht, was die genauen Tarife sind, aber ich...
200 Euro krieg ich die Stunde.
Hätte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht für so unrealistisch.
Na schön, wenn's die Hälfte wäre.
Ist ja auch egal.
Okay, die Hälfte ist als JavaScript-Programmierer kann durchaus realistisch sein. Aber... Also, ich find's keine eigene Art, hier hinzupacken, die keine Sau kennt.
Aber das ist doch grad das Coole, die haben halt auf ihrem iPhone das benutzt, was irgendwie Tausende von Milliarden von Entwicklern auf Mac OS kennt.
Tausende.
Schon seit Jahren irgendwie programmieren.
Genau, und das hat Palm einfach nicht. Und was jetzt Tausende von Programmierern...
Also, wann gibt's denn JavaScript in Webseiten?
Na, schon eine Weile, mein Freund.
Aber wie lange?
Ja, aber wie viele?
Okay, jetzt diskutieren wir schon wieder...
Das brauchen wir nicht zu diskutieren. Es gibt sehr, sehr viele JavaScript-Programmierer. Wie gut die das alle können, das sei dahingestellt.
Anyway, JavaScript hat in Zukunft, ich bezweifle, dass es eine riesige Programmer-Base gibt, aber ich denke, dass der Pri schon in der Lage ist, eine gewisse Programmer-Base anzuziehen.
Und dass ich im Zweifelszeit JavaScript lernen kann, um damit Web-Applikationen entwickeln und nebenbei dann auch noch Prime-Prey-Applikationen entwickeln kann, ist definitiv was wert.
Es ist auch definitiv kein Fehler, JavaScript zu lernen, denn diese Sprache ist here to stay. Und ich denke, da wird eher noch mehr mit passieren als wenig.
Und mal ehrlich, die Arbeit am Programmieren ist nicht die Sprache lernen, sondern ist das ganze Drum-Rum-Lernen.
Ja, aber du musst, guck mal, du musst, also wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich hierfür, wenn ich hierfür ein Programm entwickle, würde ich probieren, Was ist denn hierfür? Fürs iPhone. Gut. Würde ich probieren, möglichst viel in HTML zu machen. Weil das kann ich dann auch auf Android zum Laufen bringen, weil das kann ich dann auch auf WebOS zum Laufen bringen. Das ist die JavaScript, das ist die Linguafranca.
Aber guck mal, du bist doch Mac-Journalist. Was sind die beschissensten Programme auf deinem Mac? Das sind immer die, die nur Rapper sind für irgendwie Tools, die von anderen Rechnern kommen. Du willst irgendwie Native für deinen Rechner das irgendwie in Check haben.
Ich schon.
Ist dann nur auch egal. Was haben denn diese Reviews hergegeben? Ich hab nicht so viel Zeit gehabt, mir die anzulesen. Also das Einzige, was ich wahrgenommen habe, ist, dass dieses ganze Multitasking natürlich auch immer gegen die Rahmenwand fährt und dass du letzten Endes sowieso die ganze Zeit dabei bist, deine Programme, die so schön im Hintergrund laufen, gleich wieder zu beenden, damit du neu starten kannst.
Also den Teil hab ich genau, ich weiß nicht, wo du das gelesen hast.
Das weiß ich auch nicht mehr.
Also ich hab gelesen, dass du durchaus ein paar Programme... Also das sind, ich glaube die allerersten Reviews sind auch mit ein bisschen Vorsicht zu genießen, weil das sind ja alles Fanboys, die sind von Fanboys geschrieben, die das Gerät erst mal in der Hand halten und die das auch von Palm, muss man auch sagen, zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen haben, um so schnell Reviews schreiben zu können. Die sind nicht ganz so unbeengenommen wie die Reviews, die noch kommen werden, aber die haben gesagt, man kann durchaus viele Programme offen haben. Der Start eines einzelnen Programms dauert relativ lange, aber dafür lässt es halt im Hintergrund laufen. Dieses Notificationsystem, über das im Vorfeld ja so viel erzählt wurde, ist wohl tatsächlich so gut, wie es beworben wurde. Wo sie jetzt alle ein bisschen dran zweifeln, ist dieses Synergy heißt es. Also es gibt ja, also ein wichtiger Punkt bei dem Palm war ja dieses, oder ist, wir führen deine Adressen aus allen Quellen zusammen. Wir führen die aus Facebook und Facebook. Das funktioniert wohl in der Praxis überhaupt nicht. Das ist, also meinen sie, das wäre und es ist auch so von wegen, wir führen die intelligent zusammen und join die und so funktioniert wohl auch nicht. Also da ist dann Einträge doppelt und so ein Scheißdreck. Aber darüber hinaus ist es wohl ein ziemlich gutes Gerät, von dem alle relativ beeindruckt sind, bis auf die Tastatur, über die einhellig gesagt wird, was für ein Shit.
Ich glaube, das ist doch eine richtige Tastatur.
Das ist eine richtige Tastatur. Ich glaube, da hat sich mittlerweile die Einstellung auch geändert. Was eine richtige Tastatur ist, ist eine On-Screen-Tastatur. Und die ist wohl, also erstens ist das, was du gesagt hast, dass aus mehreren Reviews kam raus, dass die vordere Kante sehr scharf sei, wenn man es aufgefahren hat.
Die müsste ja wirklich sehr scharf sein, wenn das so vielen irgendwie auffällt.
Also das stand in mehreren negativ drinnen, dass man sich damit durchaus die Finger verletzen kann. Und die Tastatur, die Tasten sind wohl deutlich zueinander. Also man kann nicht vernünftig drauf tippen. Aber ansonsten muss ich sagen, scheint dieses Vaporware, was man ja vielleicht im Januar noch vermuten konnte, hat sich ziemlich sicher nicht bestätigt. Wir haben ein Telefon, was in vielen Punkten dem halb gerecht wird. Und das muss man auch immer noch bedenken, ist eine 1.0. Bei Apple haben wir mittlerweile die 3.0. Und haben einige von diesen Features erst peu à peu. Auch Palm wird noch Zeit haben, dass... Copy and Paste. Oder eben, was jetzt zum Beispiel muss man ja auch mal sagen, mit dem App Store, das Apple da geworben hat, wir haben 50.000 Programme und die haben 18.
Und zwar 18 ohne 1000.
18, genau. Könnte man natürlich auch mal dagegenhalten, wie viel gab es denn fürs iPhone 2, 2 Tage nach dem Marktstart. Und da kann man mal sagen, das waren exakt 0. Über ein Jahr lang waren es 0. Die werden durchaus eine ernsthafte Konkurrenz für Apple sein. Zumindest was so diesen, wir machen ein schickes Telefon, was gut zu bedienen ist.
Da würde ich erst mal abwarten. Ich würde das mit der Infrastruktur, die Apple da hingelegt hat, mit dem ganzen Store und das hält die Programmierer. Auch von dem OS hier schon, alle rüberswitchen können ganz auf die Schnelle. Das ist schon ein entscheidender Vorteil. Die bei Pre müssen ja relativ von vorne anfangen, mit allem eigentlich.
Nee, die müssen bei HTML anfangen.
Nee, du musst ja immer noch dieses OS lernen, du musst diese Frameworks kennenlernen. Das ist ja, wie Dennis schon ganz richtig sagt, das ist ja der Großteil der Arbeit am Ende.
Ja, aber ich hab...
Und auch nicht nur das, was die Programmierer machen, sondern die Firma Pre muss ja auch erstmal alles ausbauen.
Naja, aber ich meine, Palmbauten, das ist jetzt auch nicht das erste Smartphone, das sie auf den Markt schmeißen. Die haben schon ein paar Jahrzehnte Erfahrung in dem Bereich und die wissen, worauf sie sich einlassen.
Es ist...
also, ich würde sagen, sie hatten noch genau eine Chance, die ihnen niemand zugetraut haben und die haben sie genutzt.
Ja, also sie haben auf jeden Fall die Gelegenheit genutzt zu überleben. Oder zumindest erst mal vom Markt noch eine Überlebenschancen eingeräumt zu bekommen. Sagen wir's mal so. Aber sie sind halt mit dem drittgrößten Provider in den USA jetzt unterwegs, mit so einem CDMA-Netzwerk und da muss man halt erst mal sehen. Ihr Reach ist da halt auch...
Aber was haben sie zwischen 50 und 100.000 Geräten am ersten Tag verkloppt?
Ja, was heißt das? Geschippt oder verkauft?
Verkauft wohl. An vielen Orten ausverkauft, wobei sie auch nicht viele Geräte hatten, muss man auch sagen.
Ich glaube, da muss man erstmal abgucken. Also ich will ja aus nichts schlecht reden. Das ist bestimmt ein prima Telefon. Das hat nicht umsonst schon, bevor es da war, Lorbeeren eingeheimst ohne Ende.
Ja, ich denke auch, also ich bin auch überhaupt nicht gegen den Pri und ich denke auch, dass es sehr gesund ist, wenn wir da ein bisschen Competition haben und dass sie andere Konzepte ausspielen können, damit das iPhone da sozusagen auch nicht unbedingt immer konkurrenzlos ist.
Und das mit diesem, was sie wirklich gut gemacht haben, dieses App-Switching. Das ist, also ich meine, beim Android, dass es da irgendwelche Hintergrundprozesse gibt und sowas. Das ist ja eher störend. Also das stört mich, wenn das Programm sinnvoll im Hintergrund läuft. Dann läuft es sinnvoll im Hintergrund. Aber es gibt halt viele Programme. Du klickst auf diesen Home-Button. Manche Programme beenden sich und manche laufen weiter. Da musst du über ein Menübefehl, Exit, sagen. Dieses mit den Karten, dass ich da in diesen Kartenmodus gehen kann und was ich gerade an Karten offen habe, das läuft und was an Karten nicht mehr offen ist, ist zu und ich kann die Karten wegschmeißen, ist ein Konzept, was Apple so erstmal toppen muss, finde ich. Das ist, das, das, das fühlt sich, also das sieht sehr gut aus auf den Screenshots.
Ja, ich meine, es ist sehr schwierig über ein Telefon in ein OS was zu sagen, was man noch nicht selber in der Hand gehabt hat. Und ich glaube, da müssen wir noch ein bisschen warten. Ich meine, jetzt wird es ganz interessant sein, ich schätze mal, dass auf der WWDC das ein oder andere Palm-Pri-Gerät herumgereicht wird und unsere Bekannten vor Ort werden sich dann bestimmt auch mal damit auseinandersetzen.
Ja, hoffentlich.
Ja, ich hatte ja auch die Hoffnung, hier noch so ein Live-Bericht irgendwie von der WWDC einzuspielen, aber dem potentiellen Diskutanten ist irgendwie gerade sein MacBook verreckt auf der World Wide Developers Konferenz. Und sprach auch von einem Problem, was sich selbst vor Ort ja auch nicht mit Geld lösen lässt, weil deutsche Tastatur und Unibody... Kannst nicht einfach mal ein Gerät vor Ort kaufen, weil kriegst dann halt einfach keine deutsche Tastatur. Naja, wie auch immer.
Da wird doch hier aber locker los mit englischer Tastatur.
So, jetzt kann uns der Chat noch mal sagen, ob wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen haben, weil ich glaube, wir sind durch, oder?
Wir sind eigentlich.
Also abgesehen davon, dass wir durch sind.
Es hat ja das Plänen und so Features. Es hat auch GPS, Kompass und UMTS und Kamera und alles.
Hat kein UMTS, hat dieses Sprintnetzwerk.
Also es kommt ja eh erstmal nur für dieses CDMA raus, gibt's ja hier in Europa noch nicht, ne?
Genau.
Hat da also gar kein GSM sozusagen?
Nee.
Alles klar.
Hat GPS drin, OpenCompass, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Der Browser soll genauso schnell bis eigentlich deutlich schneller sein als auf dem iPhone, zumindest auf der aktuellen Version. Jaja, das machen sie alle. Was ich auch sehr gut finde.
Aber nicht für mobile.
Na, mittlerweile schon, klar.
Was?
Na, die haben doch diesen, wie heißt das, für Windows Mobile gibt's jetzt diese Plattform, Farinec oder wie das heißt, also dieser mobile Gecko Client. Und den gibt's als Meta.
Mobile Firefox, wie auch immer der heißt. Den haben die da umbenannt irgendwie.
Irgendwas mit F vorne. Und der hat ein komplett neues User-Interface. Das sieht auch ganz schick aus. Das ist so, zieh eine Seite nach links, dann kommt so deine Bookmarks raus, zieh eine Seite nach rechts rüber, dann hast du deine Tab-Leiste und so. Und ich weiß nicht, wie gut da läuft. Ich hab noch nicht gesehen auf Windows Mobile, aber die legen auch langsam zu.
Na ja gut, aber das hat irgendwie alles keine große Bedeutung. Die letzten Web-Statistiken, die wieder mal reinkamen, haben wir schon ein paar Mal angesprochen hier von NetApplications. Die belegen ja nur, dass es im Prinzip genauso weitergeht, wie es bisher schon die ganze Zeit voran ging. Guck mir das nochmal kurz hier an.
Okay, hier hat irgendjemand... Und wer unbedingt auf Teufel kommen raus, iPhone OS heute Abend noch abnutzen will, es ist von den üblichen Tauschbörsen schon unterwegs. Als finale Version auch, die man auch wohl einspielen kann.
Developer können es auch irgendwie runterladen.
Wie spielt man das ein?
Man öffnet iTunes, klickt mit Alt auf den Update-Button und wählt dann dieses EPSW-File aus, was man hat runtergeladen.
Genauso wie man danach die IPCC-Datei installiert.
Also Datei nehmen und mit Option auf iTunes drängen.
Mit Alt, nee, mit das iTunes öffnen, dann gibt es doch das Update und Restore.
Und dann auf den entsprechenden Button klicken.
Mit Alt aber. Dann kommt so ein Datei-Request und dann kannst du dein EPSW-File selber so. Dann update nicht das iTunes für dich automatisch von Apple, sondern du kannst das File auswählen, was er einspielen soll. So kann man zum Beispiel auch die gehackten einspielen.
Oder die EPC-Version.
Damit kannst du auch schon diese 3.0-GM-Seed oder wie auch immer die du das nennst, einspielen-Versionen. Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Wenn dann mein Telefon braun ist, dann habe ich Pech gehabt.
Ah, 340 Restore ist das. Na, das ist mal sehr gespannt, ob das noch wieder restorebar ist danach.
Für das Alte kann ich sagen, hier nicht 3G, sondern noch das davor. Da ist ja kein Baseband-Update dabei. Deswegen kann man das Update einfach einspielen und man behält sogar seinen Unlock. Nur der Jailbreak ist halt weg, wenn man den haben möchte. Da muss man sich das irgendwie wieder aufmachen. Aber mich interessiert der eh nicht, deswegen.
Okay, naja, gucken wir mal, wie wir so doof sind.
Wofür braucht man jetzt eigentlich noch einen Jailbreak?
Also, wollte ich noch mal kurz... Ist das noch interessant hier mit Browertrends, wo wir ja gerade das Thema hatten? Ich könnte hier nur wieder geben, was... Ah, doch, ist interessant. Und zwar macht Chrome echte Sprünge.
Was die Userbase angeht?
Also, wir habt ja erst letzte Woche drüber gequatscht, wo ich gefragt hab, wo es jetzt dieses Chrome mal gibt. Und dann hab ich ja hier so ein Nightly-Bild irgendwie installiert.
Von Chromium.
Ja, kann sein.
Chromium ist die Open-Source-Variante und Chrome ist das von Google. Jetzt gibt's halt beides.
Und dann kam die Nachricht, dass dieses offizielle Beta-Chrome raus ist. Offiziell raus ist und die Release-Nummer in meinem Chromium, die war höher. Also, die Nightly-Bilds sind einfach schon wieder viel weiter als das, was die da als Beta rausgeben haben.
Ja, und Google sagt auch explizit, das ist keine Beta. Also, die sagen, hier hab das, ladet's nicht runter. Also, es ist nicht dafür gedacht, dass man es tatsächlich benutzt oder irgendwie sowas. Garantiert immer noch kein Flash und dergleichen und keine Plugins. Aber es geht weiter mit Chromium. Und damit hätten wir dann langsam, über kurz oder lang, Safari 4 auf Snow Leopard wird bestimmt toll werden mit den getrennten Prozessen. Dann haben wir Chrome. Wow, wir haben als erstes als Apple Nutzer zwei Browser, die getrennte Prozesse können.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, es ist sehr interessant. Also von April auf Mai hat der Internet Explorer 0,6% Marktanteil laut NetApplications verloren. 0,6. Im selben Zeitraum hat Google Chrome 0,4% dazugewonnen. Also zwei Drittel dessen, was der Internet Explorer verloren hat, hat Chrome dazugewonnen. Das ist eine Menge. Und Safari hat sozusagen die anderen 0,2% und ein bisschen ist da noch bei Firefox hängen geblieben. Also sie sind nur noch mit 0,03 plus dabei. Netscape verliert auch 0,1%. Also das wird Ende dieses Jahres, glaube ich, gibt es keinen Netscape mehr.
Netscape? Was wird mit Netscape gemeint?
Netscape Navigator.
Oh, den gibt es noch?
Wie viel hat der?
0,74%.
Okay, gut. Ja.
Und, ähm, d-d-d-d-d, was wollte ich sagen? WebKit ist sozusagen am Kommen.
Ganz klar.
Und innerhalb des Internet Explorer Lagers geht es halt mit 6.0 irgendwie schrittweise halt zurück. 8.0 gibt es ja jetzt auch schon eine Weile und der hat halt relativ große Zuwächse, aber das geht halt voll auf Internet Explorer 7. Die updaten alle und dann wird halt das eine durchs andere ersetzt. Na ja, muss man mal sehen. Safari 4 ist halt jetzt hier noch nicht auf dem Radar. Ich denke mal, das wird auch noch eine Weile dauern, bis das irgendwie sich durchsetzt. Auf jeden Fall ist davon auszugehen, dass diese Internet-Explorer-Dominanz na ja, bald, sagen wir mal, in einem sehr erträglichen Rahmen ist. Sie sind jetzt halt unter zwei Drittel und gefühlt sind sie irgendwie schon gar nicht mehr da. Find ich.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also niemand redet mir so viel über diese Notwendigkeit, da kompatibel sein zu müssen und so. Ehrlich wird nur noch über die Notwendigkeit geredet, dass die mal kompatibel sein müssen.
Da hat wirklich ein Paradigmenwechsel stattgefunden. Also genauso, wie du es gerade sagst. Also früher war es immer oberste Direktive. Wir können das nicht nutzen, weil es geht einem Internet-Explorer nicht und mittlerweile ist es doch eher so eine Screw-It-Einstellung. Ja, geht's halt nicht. Kriegen die doch eh nicht mit.
So, jetzt haben wir unsere drei Stunden voll. Really? Ja, so fast. Genau wie letzte Male. Immer so kurz vor drei.
News?
Außer der WWDC.
Gab's noch andere News?
In einer Woche?
Hab ich vergessen.
Es gab diesen Palmpre-Launch, das war eigentlich alles. Mehr hab ich hier nicht. Ich kann das auch nicht mehr. Ich finde, also mehr als drei Stunden kann ich jetzt nicht reden.
Ja, komm, bis jetzt hier mal.
Diese ganze Apple-Kacke. Mal echt.
Ich will auch mal.
Dass das so interessant ist.
Ey Leute, heute Nacht hab ich wegen euch noch hier stundenlang mir die Keynote angeguckt. Ich hab heute nur vier Stunden geschlafen, nur um jedes Detail dann mit Screenshot hier wieder vergessen zu haben.
Habt ihr denn mein Twitter gesehen? Ich hab jetzt so ein...
Du hast ein eigenes Twitter.
Wieder ein Twitter gesehen.
Was heißt das, dein Twitter?
Was ich getwittert hab. Ich hab mir so ein MyBrew Figürchen angelegt. Ich wollte ja auch mal ein Onlinespiel spielen.
Ach so, ja, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Ich brauch mehr Pupils.
Was ist denn das? Dennis will wieder Zeit tot schlagen und hat sich dazu irgendwie so ein Flash-Avatar gebaut, oder was?
Nee, es gibt so ein Online-Game, das heißt MyBrewt. Und hab ich da vorhin schon in den Chat gepostet. Und da kannst du dir so ein Figürchen machen, tippst deinen Namen ein, dann ändert sich der Optik, kannst die Optik aber auch selber ändern und dann kannst du gegen andere Figürchen antreten. Du kannst selber beim Kampf nicht einwirken, aber du kannst ja jetzt schon deinen Gegner auswählen. Also welche Fähigkeiten der hat und kannst gucken mit deinen Fähigkeiten, ob du den dann schlagen könntest oder nicht. Und dann steigst du deinem Ranking, ist total gekloppt. Aber macht voll Spaß.
Sagt die URL?
Hab schon. Hab ich in irks...
Nein, sagen, sprechen, Audio.
dennisx.mybrewt.com Und da ist dann auch gleich mein Figürchen, da können die sich ein neues anlegen, können gegen meine antreten und dann noch gegen alle anderen. Und dann kann man sich so hoch kämpfen.
Und ansonsten möchtest du noch ein iPhone haben, was du sonst noch wünsche?
Das sind aus der Schokolade...
Ja, wollte ich gerade sagen, die Schweizer Schokolade wäre noch interessant.
Ach so. Wir wollen noch Schweizer Schokolade haben. Wünsch dir was bei Mobamex.
Also was auch richtig cool ist, ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht die Deluxe-Schweizer Schokolade, aber so ein viereinhalb Kilo Toblerone, das wär's.
Viereinhalb Kilogramm? Nein. Viereinhalb Kilogramm.
Ja, ja, ja, ist so ein Riesending.
Haben wir genug Hörer in der Schweiz? Nein, das ist eins. Das gibt's auch bestimmt nur in der Schweiz.
Das sind auch wirklich so ein riesengroßes Stück, du musst die zertrennen, du kannst da gar nicht reinmeißen, das geht gar nicht.
Ach so mit der Flex oder was?
Das sind nicht kleine so reingestapelt, wie bei manch anderen Packungen, so die dann diese große Form ergeben, sondern das sind wirklich so eine riesen Dreiecke dann da.
Das sind so Saurier Toblerone. So wie Urzeitkrebs, gibt es dann noch die Urzeit Toblerone dazu?
Also selbst ein Elefant müsste das eigentlich ein Stück zu groß sein.
Also ich wäre ehrlich gesagt mit einer 450 Gramm Toblerone auch schon zufrieden.
Man jetzt, red doch nicht alles klein.
Naja, also wenn es so groß und sperrig ist, dann red ich es auch gern mal klein.
Das zerteile ich dir dann schon, das geht schon. Ich glaub gar nicht, wie schnell so eine Schokolade weg ist.
Ich hoffe, dass es demnächst mal wieder ein paar absurde, übergroße Gerüchte gibt, die man hier kleinreden kann. Das wäre ganz gut. Aber das ist jetzt eine elegante Wendung.
Aber hallo, das ist mal schön weg von Toblerone.
Das ganz Wichtige mit der Priorität liegt bei der Besorgung der Unlocked iPhones der neuesten Generation. Das ist das Wichtigste. Darauf müsst ihr euch konzentrieren.
Außerdem brauchst du mal eine neue Darth-Vader-Maske. Die alte ist schon abgebrochen.
Nächste Mobile Max in zwei Wochen. Wollen wir uns schon festlegen, terminlich?
So, ich muss nach Hause, mein iPhone ist bald da. Sechs Minuten willst du noch.
Mal gucken, wie es so ist in etwa in zwei Wochen. Wenn wir was machen, dann werden wir wahrscheinlich schon über iPhone 3.0 Erfahrungen reden können. Das wird dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder den Dings einnehmen. Gibt es live. Wer sich schon immer gefragt hat, wie man weiß, wann es live ist, das funktioniert wie immer so. Wir haben einen Google-Kalender, der ist auch auf der Webseite zu abonnieren.
Außerdem steht es doch mal im Twitter, oder?
Da steht es drin. Wir kündigen das bei Twitter an, aber so weiß man es halt auch schon vorher.
Und ich werde noch mal zusehen, dass ich so ein Kalender-Widget einbaue. Auf der Seite.
Genau, und wir bauen auch nochmal so ein Kalender-Widget ein. Und überhaupt versuchen wir sowieso mal ein bisschen, was an unserer Webseite zu machen. Wer da schon mal hingeguckt hat, wird gesehen, dass sich da jetzt auch das eine oder andere auch schon geändert hat. Große Revolutionen sind erstmal noch nicht zu erwarten. Aber wir bleiben dabei beim Mobamex und reden auch weiter hier Stuss. Und freuen uns darüber, dass ihr so fleißig zuhört und Kommentare gibt und uns auch kritisiert, wie das auch in der letzten Sendung verfolgt ist.
Worum kritisiert? Wer war das?
Du liest die Kommentare nicht, was?
Doch, doch, klar. Welche Webseite ist das nochmal?
Mobamex, da gibt es, genau, ich will das jetzt nicht diskutieren, weil ich habe keine Kraft mehr. Aber es gab sehr interessante Einblicke und Kommentare zu dieser OLED-Geschichte und warum Apple kein OLED in ihr iPhone einbauen wird. Wie es ja dann auch nicht passiert ist offensichtlich, weil von OLED haben wir nichts gehört. Und dann gab es hier noch so einen etwas längeren Thread über dieses und jenes. Und über irgendwas wurde sich auch noch beklagt. Das habe ich jetzt aber schon wieder vergessen. Ah ja genau, wie wir über Java und C++ reden und überhaupt. Das geht ja nun gar nicht. Also mir fällt jetzt nichts mehr ein.